raised yesterday by the house leader of
the official opposition concerning
today's statutory debate being held
pursuant to emergency act
in his intervention the member asked for
the chair's interpretation of the
provisions found in subsection 58 6 of
the act
which state that the motion is to be
debated without interruption
he argued that the plain meeting of the
words of these words is that once the
debate begins it cannot be interrupted
for any other business and the house is
required to sit continuously until it's
concluded he also cited past examples of
statutory debates
that had
similar provisions but noted that those
statutes contained explicit wording
allowing for such interpretation and
interruptions
provisions that are absent in the
emergencies act
[Music]
practices
[Music]
is
the members cited a number of principles
to follow in interpreting statutes i
would suggest that a critical one often
site cited by the courts is the
principle of contextual cons
construction
it is described by dredger in
construction of statutes second editions
at page 87 and i quote
the words of an act are to be in the
entire context and in their grammatical
and ordinary sense
harmoniously with the scheme of the act
the object of the act and the intention
of parliament unquote
following
sullivan in statutory interpretation
second edition one
reads on pages 58 and 59 and i quote
there are problems with the plain
meaning rule
in the first place the distinction it
draws between reading and interpretation
is illusory
second the plain meaning rule
expressing expressly requires courts to
distinguish between clear or plain
meaning on the one hand an ambiguous or
doubtful meeting on the other
the distinction has no solid basis
unquote
to understand how the wording without
interruption came to be
the chair has reviewed the evidence
given at the legislative committee on
bill c-77 in the second session of the
33rd parliament originally this section
of the bill
provided that the motion be debated for
three days without interruption
a member moved an amendment to strike
the three-day limit
arguing that he did not want to see a
mechanism for time allocation built into
the act
he instead suggested that it be
subjected to the normal rules of the
house
another member explicitly asked if the
provisions as drafted meant that the
house would be would need to sit for 72
hours straight to consider the motion
the response given both by the
parliamentary secretary and by the
official present
was that the provisions of the act had
to be interpreted
within the context of the house's rules
therefore
any extension to the house's sittings
our sitting hours
would have to occur pursuant to the
normal procedures
this was clearly the understanding of
the members of the committee when they
removed the three-day limit on debate
i refer members to the evidence of the
committee from april 12
1988 especially pages 9 45
and 9 46
the amendment was adopted and the
provision was further amended at report
stage to arrive at the current wording
of the act
at
the chair recognizes this is an
important debate on an urgent matter and
that many members
will wish to express their views
if parties feel the current rule should
be adapt adapted to this context i
strongly encourage the parties to follow
the practice used in past statutory
debates and to arrive at an agreement
i thank all the members for their
attention tabling of documents
introduction of government bills
statements by ministers
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
thank you mr speaker that was two of
them was that both
that was both
okay
president presenting reports of
committees
introduction of private members bills
mr davey seconded by mr desjardins moves
for leave to introduce a bill entitled
an act to amend the income tax act and
the canadian canada student financial
assistance act this motion is deemed
adopted the honourable member for
vancouver kingsway thank you mr speaker
i rise today to introduce an important
bill to parliament the post-secondary
education financial assistance for
persons with disabilities act with
thanks to the honourable member for
edmonton griezbaugh for seconding it and
his tireless advocacy
for diversity and inclusion
this legislation will provide
tuition-free post-secondary education
for all canadians with disabilities this
is not only fundamentally just it is an
investment in our citizens that will
unleash potential and benefit our
society while there has been progress in
broadening inclusion for students in
canadians colleges universities and
trade schools there is still much more
to be done i call on all
parliamentarians to support this vital
initiative to help canadians with
disabilities reach their potential and
share their talents skills and energy
with us all because when people with
diverse abilities succeed we all succeed
mr davies seconded by mr desjardins
moves that the building would be now
read a first time and be printed this
motion is deemed adopted
spearing of this bill
when shall this bill be read a second
time
at the next sitting of the house
and presenting a petition
reading of
senate public bills
and motions the honorable parliamentary
secretary
so thank you mr speaker there have been
discussions amongst the parties and if
you seek it i believe you'll find
unanimous consent to adopt the following
motion
that in relation to the motion for
confirmation of the declaration of
emergency notwithstanding any standing
order or usual practice of the house the
prime minister and the leader of the
official opposition uh the minister
moving the motion and the member
speaking immediately afterwards shall be
allowed to speak for no more than 20
minutes with 10 minutes for questions
and comments and that they be allowed to
split their time with another member and
that the prime minister be allowed to
speak before the minister moving the
motion
katusaki suppose uh circulate the deputy
propose
presenting of petitions
the honorable member for
pitt meadows maple ridge
sent a petition on behalf of numerous
residents in my riding for some time
they've been impacted by increased air
traffic over the neighborhoods these are
not people that live next to an airport
but rather they live between designated
training areas over many miles away from
an airport their quality of life has
been diminished and attempts to find
reasonable solutions have not been
successful they are calling on the
government to legally implement changes
to resolve the matter and regain a
normal peaceful life thank you
presenting our petitions
um mr casey
the honourable member for charlotte
thank you very much mr speaker i rise
today to present a petition signed by
several prince of rhode islanders that
were inspired by the book by seth klein
and very concerned about the climate
emergency they're calling on the
government of canada to enact just
transition legislation that would reduce
emissions by at least 60 percent below
2005 levels that would create good green
jobs and drive an inclusive workforce
uh that will protect and strengthen
human rights and expand the social
safety net thank you mr speaker
presenting petitions of the honourable
member for saanich gulf islands
thank you mr speaker it's an honor to
rise in this place to present a petition
primarily from residents of ottawa who
are very concerned about what might seem
at first to my colleagues in this place
to be a local issue but it's not it's
the destruction of queen juliana park
established to honor the canadian
soldiers who fought for the liberation
of the netherlands 70
7
600 of who of whom died in that conflict
the establishment of queen juliana park
was in the honor of of the of the
sacrifices of canadian soldiers
and of the close relationship that
exists between the people the
netherlands and canada
the the decision to remove 750 mature
canopy trees flies in the face of
everything we hear about trying to
create urban places of green spaces to
restore and and and
restore our souls especially in a time
like this a pandemic being able to
escape to a green place those trees will
be cut down in order to make room for a
new hospital expansion when the national
capital commission which is federal had
already told the city of ottawa the
better location was tiny's pasture these
citizens of ottawa call for the national
capital commission's original
recommendation to be reinstated to
preserve queen juliana park and indeed
the entire central experimental farm as
green spaces and to support the request
for a public inquiry at the federal
level thank you mr speaker
president
presenting petitions the honourable
member for kitchener center
thank you mr speaker i have a petition
from folks in kitchener center who agree
with the member for charlottetown
and
residents of his community as well they
are similarly calling for just
transition legislation they call to
ensure that the targets included align
with climate science and doing our fair
share at least 60 percent below 2005
levels by 2030 ensuring we phase out
fossil fuel subsidies and move that
towards creating the good green jobs of
tomorrow
while protecting human rights and
indigenous rights while we do it thank
you
presidential petition presenting the
petitions
questions on the order paper the
honorable parliamentary secretary to the
government house leader yes sir uh mr
speaker i would ask that all questions
be allowed to stand at this time please
orders of the day
or the day
of statutory order consideration of a
motion for confirmation of the
declaration of emergency
mr medicine seconded by mr trudeau moves
that pursuant to section 58 of the
emergency act this house confirms the
declaration of a public order emergency
proclaimed on february 14 2022
debate the honor right honorable prime
minister
[Applause]
mr speaker
i will be sharing my time with the
minister of public safety
on monday
as we entered the third week of illegal
blockades and occupations
the federal government
invoked the emergencies act
we did it to protect families and small
businesses
to protect jobs
and the economy
we did it because the situation
could not be dealt with under any other
law in canada
mr speaker
we did it
because that's what responsible
leadership requires us to do
for the good of all canadians
the illegal blockades and occupations
have to stop
and the borders have to remain open
we've made progress since monday
on tuesday the border was reopened in
southern alberta after the coots
blockade was dismantled
the rcmp arrested a small group of
people within the larger blockade
and seized firearms ammunition and body
armor
it is believed that this group was
willing to use force
against police officers
on wednesday the blockade in emerson
manitoba
had been cleared without arrests or
charges
traffic and trade at this border
crossing have now resumed
in windsor mayor dilkins said law
enforcement was able to successfully
intercept a new convoy
suspected of heading to the ambassador
bridge
and here in ottawa
law enforcement now has more tools and
resources in order to give the people of
this city their jobs
neighborhoods
and freedoms
back
are wins all accouts yeah emerson
has
support for their work including the
arsenal
including here in ottawa
these
and to all canadians it is consistent
with the requirements of the emergencies
act
that the views of the premiers of all
provinces and territories be carefully
considered
and that is what we did
and the consultation and collaboration
with the premiers will continue
until the situation is resolved
like i said on monday
the scope of the emergencies act is time
limited
and targeted as well as reasonable
and proportionate
it strengthens and supports law
enforcement agencies so they have more
tools to restore order and protect
critical infrastructure
these
illegal blockades are being heavily
supported by individuals in the united
states and from elsewhere around the
world
we see that roughly half of the flat
funding that is flowing to the
barricaders here
is coming from the united states
the goal of all measures
including financial measures in the
emergencies act is to deal with the
current threat only
and to get the situation fully under
control
mr speaker i want to reassure canadians
that when the emergencies act is invoked
the canadian charter of rights and
freedoms continues to protect their
individual rights
we're not using the emergencies act to
call in the military we're not limiting
people's freedom of expression we're not
limiting freedom of peaceful assembly
we're not preventing people from
exercising their right to protest
legally
we are in fact reinforcing
the principles values and institutions
that keep
all canadians free
the blockades
and occupations are illegal
they're a threat to our economy
and relationship with trading partners
they're a threat to supply chains and
the availability of essential goods like
food and medicine
they're a threat
to public safety
and targeted
mr speaker
mr speaker
we understand
that everyone is tired of this pandemic
we understand that canadians are
frustrated with covid
some protesters came to ottawa to
express their frustration and fatigue
with public health measures
and that's their right
like i said
it's a right
that we'll defend
in this free and democratic country
but
illegal blockades and occupations are
not peaceful protests
they have to stop
uh
this week
based on advice from public health
experts
health minister jiklo announced that
will students soon start easing border
measures for travelers
our government
the health minister
if i can interrupt the pres if i if i
can interrupt the prime minister for a
second we need we need we need to make
sure we're not using proper names in
here so we want to stick to the writing
the writing names the honorable right
honorable prime minister
this week based on advice from public
health experts the health minister
announced that we'll soon start easing
border measures for travelers
our government will continue to follow
the best scientific advice to keep
canadians safe
and support health care workers
people are making sacrifices and have
been for two years
it's
never time to hurt our communities or
our fellow canadians with illegal
blockades but especially not now that
we're reopening beginning to get back to
the things we love
that's why mr speaker it is so important
for us to be having this debate today
and in the days to come
and for parliament to play its role in
this process
today
i ask all members of this house to take
action against illegal blockades that
are harmful to canadians i ask all
members of this house to stand up for
families and workers
to stand up for jobs and our economy
and to stand up for the freedom of
canadians and for public safety
[Applause]
and we'll try our best to get all
parties represented during this time the
honourable member for surgeon river
parkland
mr speaker the prime minister the
minister of public safety and the
minister for emergency preparedness have
repeatedly stated that there is evidence
of foreign extremist financing behind
this convoy
last week at public safety committee
deputy director of intelligence for
fintrac
barry mckillip stated that there is no
evidence that this funding in ottawa is
tied to ideologically motivated
extremism under further questioning he
stated that there has been no spike in
suspicious transactions
under what basis is this government
freezing the bank accounts of canadians
in violation of section 8 of the charter
against unreasonable search and seizure
[Applause]
speaker i think it is going to be
extremely important that uh in this
house over the coming days there will be
uh
important and robust debate on many such
issues but i can highlight once again mr
speaker that the charter of rights and
freedoms continues to apply uh the
emergencies act is subject to the
charter of rights and freedoms and the
measures that we've brought forward are
proportional
measured and responsible
and
designed to get canadians their lives
back their communities back and restore
their freedoms
uh
mr speaker
yes
is
oh
such as quebec who do not want to be
subjected
[Applause]
is
foreign
questions and comments questions
the honorable member for burnaby south
thank you mr speaker
for weeks this occupation was allowed to
continue people lost their wages
citizens were harassed the potential for
violence
grew
and the federal government instead of
acting
argued over jurisdiction
so what responsibility does the prime
minister take for the inaction
that made the emergencies act necessary
the right honourable prime minister mr
speaker i appreciate the opportunity to
reiterate that from day one
of these barricades and blockages and
occupations the federal government has
been
supplying resources and working closely
with
local police of jurisdictions to ensure
that they have the tools that they
needed obviously this situation has
evolved the situation has escalated but
every step of the way the federal
government has been there to support uh
the law enforcement of jurisdiction here
in ottawa that means the ottawa police
services and the opp and we will
continue uh to be there with the rcmp as
necessary
time for about a 15 second question and
answer the honourable member for ottawa
center thank you very much uh speakers
uh you very much aware that my riding
includes parliament hill which has been
under siege for over three weeks now
speaker my community has been held
hostage and i can assure you that these
protests have not been peaceful or
lawful my question to the prime minister
is how is this emergency is going to
help my constituents in ottawa center
the honourable right honourable prime
minister mr speaker uh canadians
continue to have the right to free
expression the right to protest
peacefully but occupying the downtown uh
of of our major cities uh protesting and
blocking uh border crossings is
unacceptable that is why we have given
more tools in a proportional way to
police officers
representable continuing debate the
honorable minister of public safety um
thank you very much mr speaker and i'd
like to begin by thanking the prime
minister for
commencing this important debate on the
invocation of the emergencies act for
the first time
and i want to begin with
a number of expressions of gratitude
both to my colleagues
[Applause]
to my colleagues on this side of this
house i'd also like to uh begin by
expressing my gratitude to the
opposition uh for uh the informed debate
which we're about to have
and finally mr speaker i'd like to thank
canadians
because i know that this has been a very
difficult time a period of great
frustration and anxiety and uncertainty
and it is not lost on me and i hope not
on all members of the chamber
that the confluence of events of the
pandemic and now these illegal blockades
does create for an emotionally charged
atmosphere and sometimes we let that get
the better of us here in this chamber
but my sincere hope is that we'll be
able to have a principal debate about
why it is the government has chosen to
invoke the emergencies act the paramount
reason being the health and safety of
all canadians
now you've heard the prime minister set
out what the test for the invocation
of the emergencies act is and i know
that my colleague the minister of
justice and the attorney general and
other members will
elaborate on that but i want to focus my
comments on what i believe are
the perceived and real risks to public
safety that we have seen over the last
number of weeks
which emanated from the so-called
freedom convoy
now this convoy has been
taken to the streets right across the
country and at other critical uh
infrastructure including our borders our
national symbols our communities our
neighborhoods and it has had a profound
impact and i would submit to you mr
speaker and to members of this chamber a
very negative and detriment detrimental
impact to public safety
i want to touch on a number of the ports
of entry which have been
interrupted significantly as a result of
the participation of those in the
illegal blockades including at coots in
alberta emerson in manitoba surrey
british columbia
windsor ontario sarnia ontario fort erie
ontario
as well as here in ottawa
i hope that all members would recognize
that
the kind of conduct that we have seen at
our borders puts into question into
serious question
the integrity and the security of this
country
the impact at coots for example
has cost the economy approximately 48
million dollars per day in emerson 73
million dollars a day and in windsor
where we conduct nearly um or roughly a
quarter of all of our daily trade with
our most important trading partner in
the united states
roughly 390 million dollars now those
are just numeric figures but i think
about the translation of those dollar
figures into the impact on canadians
jobs
on families on those who are just trying
to get by right now
and whatever the motivation of some
individuals who
have have co-mingled with with those
organizers and agitators of this illegal
blockade
whatever their
concerns are with regards to the
government's
strategy to get out of the pandemic
which of course
is to get vaccinated um
it has become something much much more
concerning
um
now mr speaker i do want to say that
um we have made some progress at these
ports of entry and that is in large part
thanks to the very important work
that has been undertaken by um the
members of our law enforcement mercy uh
the rcmp for their efforts and energy
yeah all police forces
are doing good work on the ground
there's a lot of progress being made
at the left here most of our borders
it is very important that we continue to
guarantee
the progress that we have made
i want to speak for a moment about the
situation here in ottawa and i know that
many of my colleagues in the ncr caucus
have
spoken very articulately and very
passionately
about the damage that has been caused in
our communities in our neighborhoods mr
speaker i've heard some members uh on
the opposition side uh try to
somehow
cast a minimization
some some kind of effort to
generalize what is going on outside of
this chamber
as being legitimate it is not mr speaker
it's illegal and it causes great harm
we've seen people intimidated harassed
been threatened we've seen apartment
buildings that have been chained up
we've seen fires set in the corridors
residents are terrorized and it is
absolutely gut-wrenching
to see the sense of abandonment and
helplessness that they have felt now for
weeks
and i want to assure them that since day
one that the federal government has done
everything that it could to provide
additional resources the rcmp has sent
three uh three sets of reinforcements to
the ottawa police service and we'll
continue to do whatever we can to help
but it is also important i think for
members of this chamber to recognize
that we here we write the laws we set
the policies but we trust our police our
law enforcement to enforce them
and that is why it is so important that
we
use every tool in our box especially now
where we find ourselves in a predicament
in a dilemma in a situation that has uh
perhaps never been seen before
now i ask myself mr speaker and i hope
others are reflecting as well what's
this all about and trying to step back
and looking at you know what it is that
that that's occurring
um and
i'm concerned i i've heard some people
say and still say that this is a a
protest about vaccines it's not or that
it's a protest about mandates it is not
i've heard some people say still that
this is a protest about freedom mr
speaker what is going on outside in the
streets of canada at our borders is most
certainly not about
a very small
organized and targeted group of
individuals who are trying to strip away
the very freedoms that we here have
sworn to uphold exactly that are
the generations of those who uh preceded
us have sworn to uphold mr speaker now
i've seen many striking similarities in
the way that these blockades have
manifested across the country the
tactics that they are using the timing
in which they are occurring
the targets of whether they are national
symbols um like this uh like like the
parliament here or provincial
legislatures like the war monument
outside where we hear members speak
passionately about their
forbearers who went and made the
sacrifices for the freedoms that we now
enjoy
the individuals outside are tearing down
the barriers to attack those monuments
now what does that say those are those
are those are those are those are going
i know members are heckling but i'm
encouraging them to to reflect
and also the rhetoric mr speaker and yes
the rhetoric and yes and yes mr speaker
mr speaker
notwithstanding the efforts of my
colleagues to try to show me down i'm
speaking here on behalf of constituents
and canadians mr speaker and yes
there is an ideologically motivated um
operation that that that we see in the
rhetoric here that is meant to incite
and that is indeed
one of the reasons why mr speaker that
we have chosen
that we've had to invoke the emergencies
act now
i want to assure members that these are
very targeted measures that they are
time limited that they are protected and
bound by the charter and for those who
want to ask questions as to how those
powers are going to be enforced part of
the debate is going to ensure that there
are the sufficient guard rails and
safeguards in place there will be
transparency on how those measures are
implemented there will also be an
inquiry to be uh to be to be sure so
that we can learn from these lessons and
make sure that this is a an instrument
that has been used responsibly and in a
manner that is consistent with the
charter to uphold the health and safety
of all canadians mr speaker
now
at the end of the day um
we're all here
i i would hope uh to do one thing and
that is to protect the health and safety
of canadians we find ourselves at a
crossroads with a pandemic but we've
made progress we've made progress with
the pandemic mr speaker and we are
making progress in restoring public
order but it is absolutely imperative
that we have these debates in a
principled in a reasonable manner that
is respectful of our constituents
respectful of canadians and that is
certainly something that i hope that we
will see over the next number of days
questions and comments the honourable
member for surgeon river parkland thank
you mr speaker
the minister today
and in a news conference yesterday has
repeatedly stated
that there is an ideologically motivated
violent extremist
there is a small group of extremists who
are willing to use violence he says that
there are ties between extremists that
were apprehended in couts and extremists
here in ottawa but when asked repeatedly
by the media to back up that assertion
with evidence
the minister
failed to provide any evidence
we are talking about invoking a once in
34-year emergencies act
parliamentarians deserve
real evidence not conjecture from this
minister before we can ever contemplate
suspending the rights of canadians and
what basis does this minister
make to claim that there are violent
extremists in ottawa
the honorable minister
i want to thank my colleague for the
question and i'm afraid he operates from
the false premise that the emergencies
act is any kind of suspension of of
charter rights it's not
as i've said throughout the course of
the of the debate and as the act itself
says that all of the powers that need to
be exercised in the emergency act must
be done
in accordance with the charter mr
speaker that means ensuring that section
8 is respected that means which protects
people from the right of
it it guarantees the right to be
protected from any unreasonable search
and seizure and same for section 7 as
well thank you
hey come on
[Music]
very
questions and comments the honourable
member for london fan shop
thank you mr speaker and um
while i was listening to the honourable
member's speech uh he spoke of the
people that are being impacted uh by the
blockades uh he spoke about the
harassment and the assaults and i know
i've spoken to a lot of workers in this
downtown about that as well it's truly
it's truly heartbreaking i think of the
workers and the businesses that have
been impacted negatively i think about
the people at the redo center i think
about people within my own region in
southwestern ontario and those
businesses who have been impacted but
what is this government's plan to help
those workers and those businesses after
this debate is done after we've we've
seen that the protesters have gone home
after everything we've been asking for
this government to come up with a plan
so what's the plan for those people
after
the honorable minister of public safety
thank my colleague for her question and
i share her concerns about public safety
and certainly the impact of these
illegal blockades across the country
has not only undermined public safety
but it has impacted
families abilities and individuals
abilities to provide for themselves
mr speaker i want to assure my colleague
that we will work with her and with all
members so that once we clean up these
illegal blockades and we have public
safety restored on the streets here in
ottawa that that the government of
canada will continue to be there to
support canadians as we have been
throughout the pandemic thank you mr
speaker
representative continuing to debate the
honorable leader of the opposition
and i will be splitting my time with the
member for me
today
speaker this week for the first time
since its passage the emergencies act
has been invoked by the prime minister
this is historic and it is extremely
disappointing the prime minister has
invoked the act he says to deal with the
protests that have gathered here in
downtown ottawa and blockades that were
happening at the coots border in alberta
the emerson border in manitoba the
ambassador bridge in windsor and the
border at surrey all of which by the way
are now open there are no more blockades
at any borders what's left are the
trucks parked outside here in ottawa the
need to move or be moved however
throughout the last three weeks the
prime minister has failed to take
meaningful action to de-escalate the
protests here or use any tools that he
may have available instead he has jumped
straight to the most extreme measure and
as he has invoked the act he has failed
to meet the high threshold set out by
the emergencies act to justify it
that being and i quote when a situation
seriously threatens the ability of the
government of canada to preserve the
sovereignty security and territorial
territorial integrity of canada and when
the situation cannot be effectively
dealt with under any other law of the
country
conservatives do not believe the
government has shown that threshold has
been met and thus we will be voting
against it
keep in mind
keep in mind mr speaker this act is
already invoked and is the new law of
the land our debate and the vote on
monday can only stop it
if the ndp vote with conservatives and
the bloc to stop it
supporting the use of the emergencies
act is one of the most serious decisions
a parliamentarian can make
i want to remind especially the ndp of
this
who are supporting the liberals in this
sledgehammer approach
history will not be kind to the leader
of the ndp or his members on this
particular question
the
[Applause]
the emergencies act predecessor the war
measures act was only used three times
world war one world war ii and the flq
crisis
colleagues we should keep these
precedents in mind the weight of those
events should caution us against making
this decision lightly
these protests have caused disruptions
for many canadians especially local
businesses and residents of ottawa as i
have said conservatives are the party of
law and order we believe the trucks
should move or be moved
[Applause]
mr speaker we want to lower the
temperature across the country the prime
minister clearly wants to raise it let's
be very clear how this all started the
prime minister decided to impose a
vaccine mandate on truckers with no
scientific evidence that it was the
right thing to do
many canadians opposed it but he went
ahead anyway truckers and millions of
canadians felt they had no recourse with
this prime minister and who can blame
them after all this was the prime
minister who called them racist and
misogynist he said their views were
unacceptable that they were on the
fringe
and when truckers and their supporters
arrived in ottawa what did the prime
minister do first he hid for a week and
then he continued his insults
calling them and anyone who supported
them or even talked with them things
like nazi supporters
we saw that name-calling and unfair and
mean-spirited characterization happened
just yesterday mr speaker by the prime
minister of canada in this house
that is all he has done
to rectify the problem call names and
insult
mr speaker many of the people that are
protesting many of the people who are
upset are our neighbors they are our
constituents they are canadians and they
want to be heard and given even just a
little respect by their prime minister
but the prime minister has decided that
because he does he disagrees with them
doesn't like their opinions he won't
hear them
at every turn the prime minister has
stigmatized wedged divided and
traumatized canadians and now without
even a single meeting with a trucker
without talking through one of their
concerns without apologizing for his
insults and listening to what people
have to say without using any other tool
at his disposable disposal he has used
this overreach this emergencies act and
it's wrong the prime minister's
leadership in this situation has frankly
been abysmal
he said this week and i quote invoking
the emergencies act is never the first
thing thing a government should do or
even the second the act has to be used
sparingly and as a last resort but his
actions have shown the opposite approach
the so-called measure of last resort has
come before taking any action to address
the frustrations at the root of the
protest how did the prime minister go
directly from ignoring the truckers to
turn the into this to the emergencies
act
why is the government
jump straight to this without doing
anything to lower the temperature first
conservatives put forward a reasonable
approach that could help bring the
temperature down and address the
concerns we asked the government to
commit publicly to a specific plan and
timeline to roll back federal mandates
and restrictions but the liberals and
ndp refused to support our plan and
instead the prime minister reached for
more power this comes as provincial
governments are announcing plans to end
covet 19 restrictions
the prime minister is an exception to
this trend and he refuses to come
forward with the plan
even the provinces are unhappy with the
prime minister for doing this alberta
saskatchewan manitoba quebec nova scotia
they're all opposed to the use of the
emergencies act this is not a good look
for the prime minister we all want the
trucks here in ottawa to move we want a
peaceful and quick end to the trucks
blocking the streets in ottawa our
message to those protesting is still
this conservatives have heard you we
will keep standing up for you but it's
time to move the trucks
at the same time
no government should resort to the kind
of extreme measures that we're seeing
unfortunately the prime minister has a
track record of serious disregard for
the law and that raises a lot of red
flags this is the prime minister who
interfered with an ongoing criminal
trial in the snc lavaland scandal this
is a prime minister who took the speaker
to court instead of fulfilling his legal
obligation to provide documents to this
parliament on two separate occasions
this is the prime minister who has been
found guilty by the ethics commissioner
this prime minister admired admitted his
basic admiration for basic dictatorships
red flag after red flag after red flag
he may not like it mr speaker but in
canada civil liberties must be defended
at every turn
section 2 guarantees our freedom of
association and assembly section 7
guarantees our right to life liberty and
security of the person section 8
guarantees our protection against
unreasonable search and seizure
canadians can't be expected to simply
take this prime minister at his word his
plans are not consistent with
fundamental freedoms the government
should not have the power to close the
bank accounts of canadians on a
[Applause]
the whim minister is doing this to save
his own political skin but mr speaker
this is not a game
it comes at the cost to canadians rights
and freedoms speaker parliament should
not allow the prime minister to avoid
responsibility in this way i urge all
members of this house
proceed with extreme caution
now is the time to stand up for your
constituents to show real leadership to
help heal our divisions to listen to
those we disagree with do not shut them
down
do not tell them that they are
irrelevant to not speak insults to them
that is the job of each one of us is
members of parliament no matter who we
represent we have to represent them with
integrity with hope with honor and what
the prime minister is doing mr speaker
he has for the last two years
disregarded these canadians called them
names and insulted them it is time to
show leadership for every one of us and
say no to this emergencies act
questions and comments
the honorable member for ottawa center
thank you thank you very much mr speaker
no i will speak on behalf of my
constituents which all of you are shown
to do
i just ask the members opposite
if this
kind of occupation was happening in
their neighborhoods in their writings
for
four
weeks in a row
for four
weeks in a
[Applause]
i just want to say the longer i get to
stand here
the less option that people have to
actually present their feelings and and
their represent their constituents later
on
are we good
the honourable member ottawa center four
weeks in a row speaker and the members
opposite talk about listening to the
protesters they won't even listen to a
and a member of this house to understand
speaker what my constituents the members
of my community is going and when did
the line cross between being a lawful
protest which we welcome actually
speaker in this writing and we happens
all the time to an illegal protest
members opposite were out there taking
photos and encouraging those protesters
to keep honking in the middle of the
night what the member now denies those
actions
the honourable leader of the opposition
that's a very good question for his
leader the prime minister
the first thing is what this prime
minister did was call these people names
he insulted them i don't think anyone in
that member's constituency thinks that
the answer for a prime minister to to
the response for prime minister to do is
to hide and then hurl
huge insults not just saying he
disagrees with them calling the
misogynist racist their fringe view they
should not be tolerated so very good
question he should ask his own prime
minister why didn't he take action why
didn't he show leadership why didn't he
he take the high road and try to at
least
[Applause]
without the emergency sector in quebec
there were demonstrations it was
resolved without the emergencies
in the prime minister's backyard
there is an occupation what did the
prime minister do
is
[Applause]
i sent a letter very early on to the
prime minister asking that he meet with
the opposition leaders to talk about
solutions like the ones that he just
spoke about it's clear that the borders
were cleared by police action and that's
a good thing we believe that these
protesters here in ottawa these
blockades could have been moved quickly
had the prime minister shown some
leadership said hey i'm hearing you i
disagree with you but i hear your
concerns we're going to look at removing
these mandates we're going to do it
because it's actually scientific to
remove them i guarantee you mr speaker
that these folks would have moved on had
the prime minister decided he wanted to
actually listen and what i promise you
is we would not be here today invoking
an emergencies act which is a
sledgehammer on all canadians
questions and comments the honorable
member for burnaby south
it's no secret that the convoy
stated their mission which was to
overthrow the government
it sounds ludicrous
but they brazenly posted that on their
website
and they reiterated it
order order
i can't hear the question and i'm sure
the leader of the opposition can hear
the question the honorable member for to
be south
it's no secret
that the goal of this convoy posted
brazenly on their website
reiterated as recently as earlier this
week in a press conference was to
overthrow a democratically elected
government that was their goal yeah so
the leader the interim leader of the
conservative party says we have heard
you we will keep standing up for you do
you regret endorsing a convoy that is
attacking the fundamental democracy of
our country do you regret endorsing and
supporting an occupation that is
harassed citizens do you regret
endorsing a movement which is
i mean i i know the questions have to
come through the chair and then i i i
can't speak on behalf the leader of the
opposition but i'll let the leader of
the opposition answer answer the
question thanks mr speaker and obviously
nobody in this house uh believes that a
government should be overthrown although
i have seen that members colleagues at a
number of pro
communist marches and so i'm not sure
[Applause]
what i know is when history looks back
on this conservatives will have stood up
with canadians millions of canadians
vaccinated canadians canadians who are
blue collar workers canadians who are
white-collar workers canadians who have
had enough of a prime minister who has
divided wedged stigmatized and
traumatized them and the party that will
have stood with that prime minister is
that member and his ndp colleagues and
it's shameful
[Applause]
debate the honourable member for
megantic
[Applause]
situations
mr
uh
and
without resorting to the emergencies act
the government
significant measures
exactly
to justify its invocation
mr speaker the conservative is going to
be putting against this decision
to the emergency site is
foreign
of a situation
and peacefully
mr speaker we have to calm things down
not only in ottawa but across the
country
unfortunately
[Music]
uh
that's what happens
he says
[Applause]
and they should be here
all
just
he decided
miserable
and as a last resort mr speaker that's
what he said
the prime minister used any kind of
first or second or third option
[Music]
[Music]
everyone said that he had all the tools
at his disposal even the prisoners the
premiers didn't want him to use the
can look after emergencies
that's what they said
that's what you're doing that's what
they talked about
ministers and his is are not telling us
the crisis
created by the leadership
obligatory vaccination and the lifting
of health restrictions
and that's not unreasonable of all the
are doing it right now across the
country
unfortunately this prime minister
chose
to put his hand down
to not listen to the experts
and continues to refuse to give us a
plan
mr speaker
shut down
[Applause]
questions and comments
the leadership
foreign
to send additional police forces
his own prime minister
[Applause]
is
on our territory
[Applause]
what
and comments uh the honorable member for
saanich gulf islands mr speaker and to
the honorable member for megan take care
of i'm actually
raising a point that i've heard his
leader the official leader of the
opposition the leader of the opposition
party raised something as a hypothetical
and i want to address it now and that is
this notion that the prime minister hid
i think we forget the prime minister and
i'm not going to defend all the prime
minister's actions by any means but at
the moment this convoy started the prime
minister had been diagnosed with
positive for covet
had he gone in to meet with people
who were unvaccinated and had any of
them been sickened and died he could
have been charged with manslaughter does
that not occur to people on the other
side as a quarter order and i i i would
really like i really like to hear the
i'm just looking over the minister the
member of the member completed her
question
right there
okay good i just want to make sure
everybody listens to the question so
that we can get a good answer on it the
honourable member for percentage golf
island
speaker i know this is a difficult time
for everyone but i think that
hypothetical and the use of the word hid
is again inflaming divisions in this
place we shouldn't have if someone tests
positive for covid they should not be
meeting with anyone and they certainly
shouldn't be threatening the health and
safety of people who have chosen not to
get vaccinated
mr speaker
from the beginning
this little platform
means not answering questions
is
[Applause]
mr speaker
[Music]
inflation effects either structural
pandemic
that's true in terms of
[Music]
mismanaged
is
though are not
vaccinated
and the
prime minister has failed this test of
leadership and the testimony
why because of this ideology
and he's continuing on where
yes
is
is
and it flirts
and
ironically
foreign
the national assembly of quebec doesn't
want this is it emergencies actually
um
health
vaccination improve vaccination the
faster we can health
mr speaker
[Applause]
[Music]
economics economic damages
appreciate the idea
of provincial discretion
right now is the block again
and proportional measure for that
province
[Music]
to give you to your own
organ foreign
[Music]
is
[Applause]
between
removing all these tractor trailers
immobilized
since
the honorable member
with
which excluded
over the past few years we've
is
well then i have to look at what the
text say says
does it say it says it's
applicable everywhere in canada
[Applause]
tree
we still can't hear you
thomas
[Music]
uh the honorable member
[Music]
in canada
[Music]
is
[Music]
to show some sensitivity
they almost laughed at
not with the humanitarian role of the
army yes
this concerns us we have experienced
this in the past so please provide some
understanding
[Music]
of
[Music]
accused of lacking sensitivity
doesn't seem
or against it
resuming debate
the honourable member for burnaby south
thank you mr speaker
this is a critical moment in our history
in a few weeks we will enter the third
year of this pandemic
canadians are tired
tired of a pandemic that has created so
much loss
and such sacrifice for so many
canadians are frustrated
frustrated that so many have found
themselves worse off
while those at the very top
have only increased their wealth and
power
and many are
afraid afraid of the next wave
of the next variant
but also afraid of the other crises we
face
of fires
and floods caused by the climate change
destroying their homes and their
livelihoods
of losing those they love to a toxic
drug supply
of not being able to get the care they
need or that their loved ones need when
they need it
but neither fear
frustration
or fatigue
have won over canadians fundamental
desire to take care of one another
we are here today at this moment
because of a result
of of a failure of leadership
people were abandoned by government
that argued over jurisdiction rather
than helping people
people were abandoned because
governments
didn't take this convoy
and its impact on people seriously
and they were abandoned by the police
some of whom stood with the occupiers
and the occupation
it should never have come to this
it should have never come to a point in
time where
[Music]
thousands of workers lost their wages
because of blockades at bridges
thousands of of workers lost wages
because of blockades of one of the
busiest shopping centers in ottawa
retail workers people who are already
precariously employed
it should never come to the point where
residents
families
children were harassed
intimidated
terrorized by the convoy
it should have never come to this
many people right now are rightly
concerned
about the impact of the emergencies act
that it might crack down on protests in
the future
what we're dealing with is not a protest
it is not
peaceful
the organizers of this illegal
occupation have been clear from the
beginning they haven't shied away from
this
they have been brazen about it
they came here to overthrow a
democratically elected government
it is a movement funded by foreign
influence
and it is fed
on disinformation
its goal
is to disrupt our democracy
we share the concern of many canadians
that the government may
misuse the powers in the emergency act
so i want to be very clear
we will be watching
we will withdraw our support
if at any point we feel these powers are
being misused
i've been at many protests
and strikes
and i've witnessed the full
and brutal power of the police
being used against peaceful protesters
so i want to make this clear as well
indigenous land defenders
climate change activists
workers fighting for fairness
and any canadian
using their voice to peacefully demand
justice
should never
be subject to the emergencies act
new democrats will never support that
[Applause]
what has become very clear in this
crisis
is that there needs to be as well a
serious
examination
of policing in canada
occupiers
get hugs from the police
while indigenous and racialized
protesters are met with the barrel of a
gun
[Applause]
there are several
accounts very troubling accounts
of current and former
law enforcement
and military members involved in these
occupations
one of the requirements of the
emergencies act
is that after its invocation there is a
public inquiry into its use
this must include a full public inquiry
into the role of law enforcement
in these occupations both
in their support for the occupiers
and in many cases the refusal to enforce
the law
um
which occurred in 1970
of the under the charter
emergency measures will only
we're not giving the government a blank
check
and we will keep our eyes on the
government to avoid any
abuse or misuse the last few weeks we've
heard a lot about divisions in our
country
that division sadly
has been fed and amplified by members in
this house
that has to end
using a pandemic
as a political wedge
to score points off your appointed
opponents to try to win a leadership
or an election
is wrong
and frankly dangerous
this virus doesn't care who you voted
for
wearing a mask
isn't a partisan
activity
vaccines save lives
and the vast majority of canadians
and members of parliament
know this
and have supported vaccination efforts
we cannot let canadians trust in science
and public health be eroded
by political opportunism
the pandemic is changing and our
response has to change as well
restrictions are being lifted
we need a plan to get out of the
pandemic to get to the end of the
pandemic
a plan
based on science
and our fundamental responsibility to
take care of one another
canadians who have done everything asked
of them
now want to know what to do next
canadians have followed the rules
but they need to believe that
restrictions are fair
and make sense
we know that things can change quickly
new variants may appear
the evidence may change
but without a clear plan
confusion
disinformation and resentment grows
we believe that a plan to get to the end
of the pandemic to get us out of this
pandemic has to include the urgent
repair
of our health care system
so that people can get the care when
they need it
it has to include finishing the job of
vaccination especially of our children
and we have to make sure there's global
access to vaccines so we avoid future
variants
and waves of infection
and we need to move forward on solving
the problems that this pandemic has only
made worse
the reality is working people
have paid the price of this pandemic
big companies
took government money
and gave out shareholder
dividends and ceo bonuses
frontline workers got sick
because they had to work without sick
leave
parents struggled
to keep their kids at home
while schools were closed
and big box stores stayed
open you are right to be angry that life
has only gotten harder over these past
two years
that it is almost impossible to buy a
home to keep a roof over your head or to
rent a decent place to live because
wealthy speculators are driving up the
cost of housing
you are right to be angry that the cost
of groceries go up to feed the profits
of wealthy corporate grocery stores
your right to be angry that you work
hard
and pay your taxes but the super wealthy
and big businesses don't pay their fair
share
and you are right to be angry
that your life has become harder while
the super wealthy and powerful have only
added to their wealth and power
i'm angry too
and when i get angry i fight
but i learned long ago
that my anger
and my fight is not with the powerless
your anger
your fight is not with canadians
it's with those at the very top
the powerful who have built a system
rigged against working people
we can change this
we can change this but only if we come
together to fight for a canada
that doesn't leave people behind while
others profit
the story of this pandemic is not one of
division
it's one of
solidarity
it's a story of frontline healthcare
workers showing up
day after day in impossible situations
it is a story of grocery workers
and farmers
and truckers keeping us fed
of teachers doing their best
to connect with children through screens
our story is one of neighbors
helping each other get vaccinated
helping each other when they're in need
we will not let
the last few weeks define this pandemic
for us
canadians have sacrificed too much
lost too many loved ones
missed out on too many moments
to allow our country to become divided
by hate and violence
don't let your anger turn into hatred we
know that hatred is like a fire
when it's allowed to grow it will
consume everything
as i hold my daughter i often think
about the world i want for her
i want her to walk
through the world without fear
i want her to always feel like she
belongs
i don't want her to face the same
struggles that i have
i believe this is what we all want for
our children
this is my hope
that our decisions in the coming days
are guided by this desire
to build a better and safer
more just world
where all of our children believe that
they belong
thank you
[Applause]
questions and comments questions
the honorable members
let's we're going to pay close attention
to the to this implementation of the
emergency measures act and we are
prepared to withdraw our support at any
moment that it becomes clear that
there's an abuse of power we have the
power to do so there are a number of
tools at our disposal and we'll be very
pain we'll be paying very close
attention to the way this emergency act
is used and we want to make sure it's
used only for the goal of dealing with
this convoy and this national crisis so
that canadians can have restored
confidence in the ability of this
country to be able to function properly
to protect them to keep them safe
so you know a come onto our questions
and comments the honourable member for
winnipeg north
thank you uh mr speaker and i want to uh
go back to the leader of the mdp's
comments about the real story over the
last couple of years there have been so
many heroic moments that we have
witnessed where people
from all regions of the country have
stepped up and that's really needs to be
acknowledged right up front
um you know it's an unfortunate
situation that we find ourselves in you
know it wasn't that long ago a week ago
where we had literally a half billion
dollars worth of trade between canada
and us being held hostage to convoy
blockades having a very negative impact
on issues like jobs and so forth we've
had
some opposition parties be inconsistent
with their messaging which is also cause
some issues and i'm wondering if my
friend could provide his thoughts in
terms of how important it is yes we
recognize how canadians have contributed
but at this point in juncture time that
we have to do the things to protect our
families businesses and that and trade
lines economic lines
the honorable member for burnaby south
thank you for the question and it gives
an opportunity to talk about the
incredible sacrifice of so many people i
think of all the frontline workers
all those frontline workers that kept
us going in the most difficult parts of
this pandemic
the retail workers logistic workers the
truck drivers the frontline healthcare
workers
and how it's been so difficult for these
frontline workers and in a lot of ways
these frontline healthcare workers and
frontline workers were abandoned as well
they were the most important workers in
some cases that were paid the least
and so we fought to make sure that they
were recognized not just with their hard
work and sacrifice but with fair
compensation and that has to continue
the healthcare workers right now are
struggling
they are at their brink
nurses have told us about the crisis in
health care so we have to make sure
we're supporting them with real
investments
and we are in a real crisis the fact
that one of the busiest borders in north
america could be shut down causing
thousands and thousands of workers to
lose their wages is unacceptable it is
wrong we need to make sure workers are
protected and that's why we reluctantly
support this measure to make sure this
convoy is ended and that workers are
protected that people are protected the
residents of ottawa are supported we'll
stand with them
for a quick short one uh the honorable
member for kamloops thompson caribou
thank you mr speaker always a pleasure
to rise on behalf of the people of
kamloops thompson caribou it's
interesting that the honorable leader of
the ndp has spoken about the division of
the government and yet he has
consistently propped up this government
that has chosen to divide now in his
speech he spoke about the fact that the
emergencies act should not touch on
quebec and yet he is supporting
legislation which theoretically could
freeze bank accounts in quebec so will
he support that aspect of the act
because it cannot be separated from the
remainder yes or no
the honourable member for burnaby south
in 30 seconds uh we want to make sure
that this act is used in a way that
stops a convoy and it's not used where
it's not necessary
but i want to be very clear about
division i certainly have said that in
this house divisions have been flamed
and the story of this pandemic is one of
solidarity but i want to be clear
conservatives have purposely tried to
use this convoy as an opportunity to
score points and cause problems for the
liberals
the liberals have also looked at this as
an opportunity to divide and wedge and
i'm saying that it is wrong to do that
we cannot be wedging people on a on a
thing that is not partisan this is a
crisis that we have to come together on
the pandemic is one where we all have to
tackle together and it should not be
something to score points on
praise to dubai continuing debate the
honorable minister of justice and
attorney general
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i will
be splitting my time uh with the
president of the queen's privy council
for canada and the minister of emergency
preparedness and i see that it's now
madam speaker madam speaker i'm i'm
pleased
and honored
but also
do this with a deep sense of obligation
uh to rise today to speak to the
invocation of the emergencies act by our
government and to the motion in this
house to affirm the government's
decision
canada is a rule of law country
by declaring a public order emergency
under the emergencies act we follow the
law
and we are acting within it
there are clear conditions set out in
the emergencies act in order for public
order emergency to be declared our
government believes those conditions
have been met
and that
and that those same conditions required
the government of canada to act
exists
replaced
yeah
i want to reiterate this point
the preamble to the emergencies act
states
and whereas the governor and council in
taking such special temporary measures
would be subject to the canadian charter
of rights and freedoms and the canadian
bill of rights and must have regard to
the international covenant on civil and
political rights particularly with
respect to those fundamental rights that
are not to be limited or abridged even
in a national emergency
madam speaker any and all of our
government
action
will be subject to the charter and it is
my job as attorney general to ensure
this i take that responsibility
incredibly seriously
there is a therefore a further check in
the parliamentary oversight process as
well
the emergencies act can only be invoked
in specific
serious circumstances that amount to a
national emergency
in order to meet the thresholds for a
national emergency three conditions must
be met
first
we must be in a safe situation that
either seriously endangers the lives
health or safety of canadians and
exceeds the capacity or authority of a
province to deal with it or
seriously threatens the ability of the
government of canada to preserve the
sovereignty security and territorial
integrity of canada
second the provinces and territories
capacity to handle the situation must be
considered insufficient or show gaps
and third we must conclude that the
situation cannot be handled adequately
under any other canadian law including
provincial or territorial laws
our government believes these conditions
were met and yesterday we tabled an
explanation of the reasons for issuing
the declaration as required by the act
we also tabled yesterday as required a
report on any consultation with the
provinces with respect to the
declaration
i would especially like to highlight the
support of british columbia ontario and
newfoundland and labrador as noted in
the document of invoking the act to
respond to this national emergency
declaring
canadians
as you have seen our government was
introduced
our government has introduced targeted
orders under the act
while the act technically applies to all
of canada we have been very careful to
tailor orders to be as focused as
possible and only in those places
affected by blockades and illegal
occupations will we see any change at
all
we have introduced the following
measures to bring the situation under
control
temporary regulation and prohibition of
public assemblies that lead to a breach
of the peace and go beyond lawful
protest
the situation in ottawa and blockades at
certain border crossings have gone far
beyond lawful protest
temporarily designating and securing
places where blockades are to be
prohibited
these this could include borders
approaches to borders critical
infrastructure hospitals and democratic
institutions
temporarily directing persons to render
essential services to relieve impacts of
blockades on canada's economy
this could include tow trucks and their
drivers for compensation of course
temporarily authorizing or directing
financial institutions to render
essential services to relieve the impact
of blockades including regulating and
prohibiting the use of property to fund
or support the blockades
temporary temporarily enabling the rcmp
to enforce municipal bylaws and
provincial and provincial offenses were
required
and finally temporary imposition of
fines or imprisonment for contravention
of any order or regulation made under
section 19 of the emergencies act
i want to repeat what i previously
stated is my responsibility and
commitment as attorney general of canada
to ensure that all steps are taken by
our government
to ensure that all steps taken by our
government are consistent with the
charter as required by the act
the emergencies act madam speaker also
contains a number of significant limits
checks and safeguards
as required by the act on several
occasions over the past week the prime
minister and members of cabinet
consulted with the premiers and members
of their respective governments
having now declared a public order
emergency we tabled the declaration in
parliament as required within seven days
and in fact we did so as quickly as
possible well before the seven days
tabling yesterday for discussion today
so that parliament could perform its
important oversight role
in the coming days a parliamentary
committee will be struck to provide
oversight while the emergency is in
effect
this declaration only lasts for 30 days
unless renewed however we can and we
sincerely hope to revoke the emergency
much sooner
the parliament
is the power
within two days for review of
parliamentarians as was done yesterday
parliament has the power to amend or
revoke any order made under the act
in closing i want to address two
critiques of the official opposition
they say this declaration is unnecessary
the illegal blockades and occupations
are ending
i say look outside they are not
i say look at the streets of winnipeg
the ones that have ended did so after
the prime minister announced we were
moving to declare a public order
emergency
we are achieving what we intended to
achieve with these measures and we're
doing it in a most measured and
responsible way
we have seen further how fluid the
situation is
since we declared this emergency we have
seen other potential blockades stopped
we want law enforcement to have the
necessary tools for a limited time to
ensure we do not have a repeat of any of
the blockades
the official opposition is talking about
rights
on this side of the house we take rights
seriously
so did the progressive conservative
government that introduced the
emergencies act and ensured it was
charter compliant that was the right
thing to do
we are invoking this act to end illegal
blockades and occupations
we are invoking it to restore the rights
of those who cannot walk safely on the
streets of downtown ottawa
we are invoking it to protect the rights
of workers to earn a living of
businesses to serve the public for
people to move freely across
international borders
let's not confuse illegal blockades and
occupations with lawful protest we know
what a lawful protest looks like it does
not look like what is happening on
wellington street or what transpired in
kutz or and emerson
so we have declared a public order
emergency to help law enforcement deal
with these issues quickly and to protect
us from them happening again
our goal madam speaker is to see order
restored and for this emergency
declaration to be lifted as soon as
possible thank you
questions and comments the honorable
member for calgary knows hill
thank you madam speaker the act
expressly prohibits violation of charter
rights
the declaration put forward by the
government assumes power to regulate or
prohibit private transfers of funds to
protesters including the ability to
mandate the reporting of such transfers
and freezing of accounts without
judicial oversight how is this measure
compliant with section 8 charter rights
to be free from unreasonable search and
seizure
will minister of justice and attorney
general of canada i thank the honorable
member for the question madam speaker
indeed
this act is compliant with section 8 of
the charter against unreasonable search
and seizure it is an extension of
procedures and practices that already
exist with respect to anti-terrorism
financing and money laundering madam
speaker so we are we are extending this
these these practices and procedures
that already exist that are already
charter compliant and
to this this other situation i.e funding
illegal blockades and protests um and we
are going to do it in a reasonable
manner it will be charter compliant
madam speaker
commanders
emergency
uh
is
is
supervise their situations
thank you madam speaker i've been here
for much of the last three weeks and
what i've seen in ottawa is a complete
failure of civic
officials and a complete failure of the
police this should never have been
allowed to spiral we saw in quebec city
and toronto the police did their job we
saw the ambassador bridge the ridiculous
situation that our bridge could be shut
down for eight days without action so
now we're having to take these measures
and i want to ask the the minister
because he's talking about
anti-terrorism measures
is the government able to tell this
house that they have that they have
evidence that there is terrorism and
extremism that they can justify this or
are we just having to clean up the mess
for the failure of what happened here in
ottawa
the honorable minister of justice
madam speaker i thank the honorable
member for his question delivered with
his with his usual passion in this
important circumstance uh madam speaker
what we are what we are i have not
i i mentioned terrorism as as part of
the financing this isn't this isn't a
terrorism act we took measures that had
been applied to terrorism we've applied
it to to other uh illegal activity uh
but i'm not i'm not equating this to
terrorism what we have done is declare a
public order emergency
based on the reasons we gave in the
declaration that we have made they
include the the very deleterious
economic impact to the kinds of workers
that the honorable member has tried to
protect throughout his whole career
think of think of auto workers in
southwestern ontario or or or niagara i
think of of beef farmers think of of
pork farmers out west who whose supply
chains were blocked and trading with our
largest trading partner madam speaker we
have declared a public order emergency
based on those very serious grounds we
needed to act we had been there from the
beginning we saw gaps we filled them now
we've given better tools to the police
debate the honorable minister for
emergency preparedness and president of
the queen's privy
council well thank you very much madam
speaker and
it is a privilege to have the
opportunity to rise today as the
minister of emergency preparedness to
speak to the importance and necessity of
the motion before the house um but mr
madam speaker let me also acknowledge
that the that that the fact that we are
all in this house that elected
representatives from across canada have
come to debate this important measure is
evidence of the strength and resiliency
of our democratic institutions madam
speaker and and although the the the
subject of today's debate is a solemn
one i think it is also evidence that
give that should give us strength
resolve and hope madam speaker let me
begin my remarks by acknowledging the
impact
that these blockades and demonstrations
have had on canadian citizens
particularly for the people of ottawa
who have been subject to intimidation
and threats disruption of the course of
their lives that frankly madam speaker
is unacceptable among the most important
freedoms that we covered and protect in
this country is the freedom of opinion
freedom of expression and freedom of
assembly lawful peaceful protest
but madam speaker it's also been said
your freedom to swing your fist ends at
the end of my nose and what we have seen
unfortunately over the past
three weeks
is is those rights
have been exceeded and abused to the
point that it's put canadians in harm's
way
mr speaker i also want to speak briefly
about the impact
of the blockades that were taking place
at vital trade corridors in this country
our international borders
madam speaker
when the protesters decided to go to our
borders
we need to recognize and acknowledge
they were going for the throat
they were going to cut off
the supply of goods and services that
our country relies on
when they stopped when they stopped
parts from coming across that border at
the ambassador bridge they shuttered
factories
they idled workers
they they damaged the reputation of
canada as a safe and stable place to
invest
they hurt canadians it was clearly their
intent
it is clearly what they were doing
and madam speaker it had to stop and we
saw the same targeted approach
to hurt canadian interests to harm their
fellow citizens includes alberta and
society british columbia in emerson
certainly at the ambassador bridge a
number of faints and other porter points
this was not by accident they didn't
just wander into those spaces they went
for the throat of this country and madam
speaker they created an emergency an
emergency that we had to respond to
and madam speaker
for the first time we have come
to the difficult decision to invoke the
authorities of the emergency act
and i want to assure this house from the
very outset our government recognized
the significance of this decision the
heavy responsibility that would come
with pursuing it not just the
responsibility of this government but of
this house
we approached the process with caution
and with care
it was essential that we explore all
options available to us madam speaker we
looked at everything very closely we
looked at our existing legislation we
looked at the regulations that support
the department of justice officials with
our with the support of our department
of justice officials to see what
additional federal supports
would be required
we examined the existing municipal
provincial and federal authorities madam
speaker i think it's rather evident the
threat of parking tickets did not deter
those trucks
in in ottawa the threat of the
enforcement of the ontario highway
traffic act did not deter those
commercial carriers from coming down our
highways and using their vehicles which
are licensed under that legislation to
cause harm to canadians and it has also
become clear of the limitations of even
the authorities and enshrined within
federal law and the criminal code that
our law enforcement officials were
struggling
one of the things that became evident
i'll give you two examples that i hope
would be helpful to this this
to the parliament in consideration of
the necessity
for these measures
one of the challenges that our law
enforcement officials had and not just
our law enforcement officials but but
those who are tasked with gathering and
analyzing financial intelligence through
ventrac
unfortunately the funding associated to
these actions these actions which in
many cases have been clearly criminal
and harmful to canadians was opaque
and it became very clear when our
officials came to us said they did not
have the tools
that they needed
to provide the the necessary and
appropriate scrutiny
of the of the source of that funding
and they did not have the tools to bring
the accountability
and even the consequences that were
required
to do their jobs we listened madam
speaker we listened to what they needed
we looked at the important ontario for
example declared an emergency and
brought forth really important and
useful regulations
but they couldn't do that because it was
our responsibility
and so we considered that we listened
another example madam speaker and this
may sound trivial but it was significant
jurisdictions right across the country i
heard from my counterpart and colleague
the minister responsible in alberta who
for weeks has been asking for help to
get tow trucks down to kutz alberta to
haul those trucks away
and yet the tow truck industry in
alberta like in ontario like right
across the country as a result of
threats and intimidation they were
afraid
to do their job we needed that equipment
we needed those drivers we needed their
ability to remove those vehicles but
madam speaker they were intimidated and
afraid
and so we brought forward in these
measures
an authority to to not to compel them
but to really authorize them to do what
we all needed them to be done
and madam speaker i just might submit to
you all
these measures work
people who knew
the gaps
in our laws the gaps in in law
enforcement's response
they were exploiting it and when we
closed that gaps they went to school
and we saw evidence of it in kutz now i
don't want to minimize the importance of
the rcmp investigation
and by the way i'm not going to comment
on any aspect of their investigation or
the prosecution that will follow totally
inappropriate for minister to do so
but i want to thank them for doing their
job and i want to thank god
that they were able to do it safely
that eliminated part of the threat at
kutz
but when we announced on monday
that we were coming for the source of
their funding that there were going to
be real consequences financial
consequences for their actions
they scurried away
and and and that's exactly what we
needed to do they did exactly the same
thing in emerson manitoba
and and even though they've we've seen
us yesterday in windsor some of them
were going back because this is the way
they can most effectively attack this
country
they were stopped they were stopped by
effective law enforcement and so madam
speaker we have brought forward these
measures but let me also assure all my
colleagues in this house
these measures must always be charter
compliant
our expectation is that our law
enforcement officials will do their job
the job we all need them to do
but they will always do it mindful of
their responsibility to uphold the rule
of law to affect their lawful purpose
with a minimum amount of force to do the
work right
and i also want to assure this house
meadow speaker we'll be there to support
them we'll be there to support them when
they say we need tools we'll give them
the tools to do the job when they say we
need resources we'll provide those
resources to do the job madam speaker
every order of government and every
person in this house
has a responsibility
to stand up with resolve and
determination
and do what is necessary to protect
canada's interests thank you very much
madam speaker
the honourable member for sturgeon river
parkway thank you madam speaker i would
note that the deputy director of
intelligence for fintrac barry mckillip
would disagree with the minister's
suggestion that there is extremist
financing of the convoy but i'll move on
to my question back in january through
march 2020 as the minister said these
people came for the throat what happened
to the throat of our country when our
railways were being blockaded when our
pipelines were being broken we couldn't
even get propane to quebec in the middle
of the winter risking the lives of so
many seniors the port of metro vancouver
was blockaded and now this government
said we needed to initiate dialogue we
needed to work with these people to come
to a peaceful resolution what is any
different with this current situation
that we're facing why is the emergencies
act needed
the honorable minister
thank you very much madam speaker let me
speak to the members first point because
i heard him ask the question before and
perhaps he hasn't been satisfied with
the answer i understand i also speak to
ventrac often and i've worked with them
for decades they didn't have the
evidence because they didn't have the
tools to collect the evidence we
listened to them they said it's opaque
we don't
we don't have the tools to examine
cryptocurrency walls for example and we
said we hear you
you don't have the evidence we'll give
you the tools to go collect the evidence
because it's necessary to protect
canadians so madam speaker the the
members argument against these measures
is clearly a little bit shallow and he
needs to recognize he's right we didn't
have that information now we're getting
that information it's what our law
enforcement officials need to protect
the country
[Applause]
foreign
i want to assure the member not only am
i proud it is the honor of my life to be
a member of this government serving
canadians
but madam speaker i also want to be very
clear we have been seized from the very
first moment in in supporting law
enforcement's efforts but not also the
efforts of our municipal and provincial
partners we've been working closely with
with provincial governments right across
the country including in quebec and
madam speaker i want to also take this
opportunity if i may
to acknowledge that we respect very much
the jurisdiction of provinces and
territories over policing in their
jurisdiction as i'm sure they recognize
and respect our responsibility to
maintain the integrity and security of
our borders madam speaker all orders of
government have a responsibility to
protect canadians and we'll all work
together to do it
madam speaker i understand and share the
concerns that people have about the
potential long-term impacts of the use
of emergency measures legislation and in
particular as it relates to the
expansion of the institution of policing
given their past abuses and overreach
against legitimate political actions by
indigenous racial and climate justice
activists and workers and yet with the
capital and country in crisis canadians
are feeling abandoned by their local
police services who have repeatedly been
caught on video compromised and at times
seem to be working in collusion with the
insurrectionist occupation madam speaker
the last royal commission on policing
was in 1962.
will the minister of public safety
commit to establishing a national
commission on policing that would review
the duties assigned to the police and
their correspondent budgets and will the
minister commit to a secretariat or some
other office to report on the
radicalization and use of public
resources in security forces for
undemocratic ends
minister
well i thank my colleagues for the
question and i think one of the things
that has become quite apparent and i've
heard concern across the country as well
an overwhelming desire that the police
in this country do their job
and and that they do it right madam
speaker that they do it in a way which
is compliant with all of our laws with
our charter of rights and freedoms that
they their response is measured
thoughtful proportional and effective
madam speaker and we're working hard to
make sure they have the tools and the
support that they need but i will also i
spent 40 years in policing
policing must be always accountable to
the people they serve because the the
most important tool that the police have
is the trust and confidence of the
people they serve and madam speaker will
always work to maintain that trust and
confidence
the honorable member for kitchener
center
thank you madam speaker and thank you to
the minister of emergency preparedness
for his comments this morning my
question is with respect to what i'm
hearing i appreciated his sharing the
care and caution
that this is being applied with the
prime uh the prime minister shared a
more targeted approach but i need to
also reconcile that with what i'm
reading in the regulations we've been
provided with mention of critical
infrastructure quite broadly i share the
concerns of the member from burnaby
south for example with respect to how
this could be applied in future to
indigenous land defenders to climate
activists could he clarify
the difference between the more targeted
approach we're hearing than the words
we're seeing
we're seeing here
will minister in 30 seconds or less i
want to thank the member for the
question and i understand the concern i
want to provide him with reassurance
these measures are time limited they are
subject to parliamentary and judicial
scrutiny and we will only use these
measures as long as they are required we
recognize their extraordinary nature
they are they have to be subject to the
scrutiny of this house it's in the law
and and we will only use them as long as
they are required and we will always
ensure that they are compliant with the
charter rights and freedoms resuming
debate uh the honorable member for
sturgeon river parkland well thank you
madam speaker
unlike
the prime minister ministers across it
actually gives me no pleasure to rise to
speak on the matter at hand
the invocation of the emergencies act
earlier this week for the first time in
canadian history
is a significant moment and it's not a
moment to be pleased about it's a solemn
moment
it's a moment where we have to ask
ourselves
how do we get to the situation
we're here in the first place and when
we examine
the evidence of how we got to this
situation i don't think there's much for
this government to be proud of
now the conservatives thoughtfully
considered the justifications
written in law and given by this
government
for the enacting of the emergencies act
this government has based
their justification on one provision
that a public order emergency exists
throughout canada
this claim is not supported by the
evidence
yes we have seen border blockades in
at least four provinces
and we have seen a persistent and now
declared illegal protest in ottawa
before the emergencies act was invoked
the blockades at the borders and across
canada were lifted or were well into
the process of being lifted
so the government trying to claim credit
after the fact
is completely absurd
the emergencies act
is now being used solely for the purpose
of addressing the situation in ottawa
not throughout canada as defined by the
act
now a key part of the threshold for
enacting these measures
is that existing laws and capabilities
have proven insufficient for dealing
with the problem
madam speaker
existing laws
are well
well equipped to deal with these
situations they were well equipped to
deal with the situation at cootz emerson
at the ambassador bridge and i submit
that they are well equipped to be used
here in ottawa the minister of justice
said earlier and the minister of
emergency preparedness that they were
required to pass this so they could
requisition essential services like tow
trucks but it has been noted
in uh but by many that under the
criminal code police already have the
authority to requisition
such services
under pain of criminal sanction that was
before the emergencies act was brought
in so this argument that the emergencies
act was necessary
is completely absurd
i also want to note that i will be
splitting my time with my honorable
colleague from regina cabell
now the police already had the power to
compel many of these services the police
already had the power to be coordinated
with the rcmp with the opp and the
various police forces and national
security forces throughout canada they
have
measures existing under the criminal
code mischief intimidation
to be used against illegal protesters
and blockades
now the government
has used an argument where they're
citing potential acts and threats of
violence against canadians and critical
infrastructure and this is not just any
violence they're saying this is violence
intended for the furtherance of an
ideological and political objective
i'm very concerned with the language
that this government is beginning to use
because that language is very similar to
the language used under terrorism laws
the definition of terrorism is the use
of violence to advance a political or
ideological agenda
this government is using
terrorism legislation against canadian
protesters
there is very little evidence
that there was a serious threat to
persons and critical infrastructure from
these protests there was a short-term
risk it was dealt with by law
enforcement
i am very concerned i'll address the
member's question there ms heckle i am
very concerned about the situation that
occurred around coots alberta
where a small group of militants
were arrested with firearms
and with the intent to do harm
i am so thankful for law enforcement for
their efforts in taking down this very
real threat
and i am so confident in our law
enforcement because i know they have
been planning this operation for weeks
they have likely infiltrated this group
they had a plan in place and they had
the appropriate tools and expertise to
deal with this dangerous situation
and defuse it before it became a very
real and dangerous situation and the
fact is madam speaker that they did this
before the imposition of the emergencies
act clearly they had the tools this
undermines the government's complete
argument
that they are justified because there
were tools
that were insufficient to deal with the
problems the tools have been
insufficient the threshold has not been
met
i want to address some comments that
have been made by this government the
minister of public safety at a press
conference
stated very clearly and definitively
that there is a connection between that
militant faction at cootes
and protesters here in ottawa
he declined to provide any evidence to
back up that assertion
we was asked repeatedly by media
to back up that assertion and he failed
to back up that claim
his only evidence
was citing social media posts and a
general tone
that was has been seen in protests
across canada
now this government has been very quick
to label protesters and anyone who would
oppose their political agenda even
before the protests began the prime
minister called people who opposed
mandatory vaccinations which the prime
minister did earlier in 2021 he has
called them racists misogynist among
other epithets
now since the beginning of the protests
the government has sought to brand and
label all protesters as fringe
extremists with quote unacceptable views
despite this unrelenting scrutiny and
rhetoric
there has still been no evidence
that there are violent extremists in
ottawa in fact if there were i don't
know how the government could be
responsible in allowing us all to be
here today and walk the streets of
ottawa it undermines their whole claim
there is no evidence that there is a
plot to violently overthrow the canadian
government despite constant repetition
and saying so i remember there was a
quote from a previous liberal minister
that says if you tell a lie big enough
and loudly enough people will totally
believe it this government is constantly
saying something that they do not have
the evidence to back up and i'd like to
see that evidence if they have it we
deserve to see that evidence this act
was not designed and not intended to
crack down on peaceful protesters even
if they are protesting illegally we have
other laws for dealing with this the
government is citing a so-called
terrorist threat but protesters in
ottawa it's very inconvenient
it's terrible for the people of downtown
ottawa but honking your horns does not
meet the threshold of a terrorist
organization and the government knows
that
without further evidence of a violent
threat i cannot in good conscience
support the invocation of this emergency
act
but even if i were to accept that the
government has met the threshold for
calling the emergency powers
i would still
have serious reservations about the
powers that the government says
they need to deal with this situation
if they believed there was a threat to
critical infrastructure in persons which
they say they believe i could support if
they showed evidence i could support
declaring parliament hill in certain
sensitive areas to be a no-go zone i
could accept that we need better
coordination between the rcmp and local
police
but what i cannot accept is the
necessity of the government undermining
section 8 of the charter of rights and
freedoms which guarantees canadians
rights from un reasonable search and
seizure to have their bank accounts
frozen the minister of justice on a
panel last night said
if you are part of a so-called pro-trump
organization you should be worried i
think all canadians should be worried
when a minister of justice
threatens people because of their
political views that is not the canada
that any of us want to see and it's
unacceptable madam speaker
madam speaker
throughout this debate which we are
going to be having over the next number
of days canadians will know that their
official opposition is alive and well we
are prepared to stand up for canadians
rights we are prepared to hold this
government accountable we're going to
keep fighting we're not going to stop
standing up for canadians rights and
freedoms thank you madam speaker
columbus the honorable parliamentary
secretary of the minister of justice
to the administrative yep to the
honorable
previous parliament madam speaker
secretary to the minister of
international trade and i listened to uh
the member's speech as i was actually
walking over here on cpac and
i'll respectfully and i do want to try
and reduce the tone of this debate and
point out a couple of things
one is that what happened in kuts
alberta is extremely concerning for any
canadian and i presume all
prominentarians that are concerned about
violence
secondly that people including outside
of this very building have openly called
for the overthrow of a duly elected
government including some an entity
calling itself canadian unity i think
that is direct evidence of an
ideological imperative or agenda that is
being pursued
but the last point that i would
generally point out to the member
opposite is that i appreciated his
emissions and i mean that with all
sincerity but all that is being extended
here with respect to
laws that are already compliant with
section 8 of the charter that relate to
unreasonable search and seizure and
fintrac is ensuring that fintrac can be
applied to cryptocurrency and to
crowdfunding sources is that not a
necessary initiative given the foreign
funding that is streaming into this
country right now it's america our first
sturgeon river park at parkland i want
to thank the honorable member for that
very good question because i was at
public safety committee when deputy
director of intelligence barry mckillip
answered a question from one of his
colleagues who said why aren't we
covering these crowdfunding sources
that's obviously a big loophole and the
deputy director stated that the payment
processors that move the money from
individuals to the crowdsourcing pages
report to fintrac and the canadian banks
that receive the money from the
crowdsourcing efforts report to the
canadian government he stated there are
no such thing as anonymous donations
because everyone must provide their name
and their credit card there are no
anonymous donations fintrack knows
exactly who's donating exactly where the
money's going they have the tools that
they need we do not need this further
infringement on canadians rights and
freedoms
[Applause]
um
demonstrations
[Music]
uh
for public safety
i'd like to have his comments on that
thank you member for sturgeon river
parkland i want to thank the honorable
member for that question and and you
could go on twitter right now and find
some of the most outrageous offensive
and criminal
statements across canada
but what we do not in this country is
base
the passage of laws and the invocation
of emergency acts based upon the
possibility of a threat we must base it
on a real threat we must base it on
evidence that there is a threat to
canadians and the fact that we are
allowed to walk freely through this
parliamentary precinct with protesters
uh less than a hundred meters from us
right now belies the fact that there is
it undermines the claim that there is a
serious threat to canadian democracy
thank you
member for london fan show
thank you madam speaker
uh the honorable colleague across the
way
uh he's he i find it very difficult he
he he's talking about that people were
just honking their horns and that he
seemed to try and and allude that this
this convoy was just a simple annoyance
for the people in ottawa however i've
spoken to uh quite a few who are working
in the downtown i had a lovely young
woman who who served me lunch at a
restaurant and i asked her how she was
doing and she talked about the
harassment she talked about specific
assaults she talked about the assaults
to a friends of hers that were working
in them in the market
that is what we need to address here so
i wonder if he could explain madam
speaker why he seems to think that this
is just a simple annoyance and why he
would want to take away from the
safeties of the people who are working
and living in this downtown
virgin river parkland well thank you
madam speaker the member is putting
words in my mouth i'm not saying that
this is a simple uh inconvenience for
the people of downtown ottawa i'm not
downplaying uh the experiences that
she's telling i believe they are true
experiences they're unacceptable
experiences and they are experiences
that can be dealt with through existing
laws harassment is a crime intimidation
is a crime it's up to police to enforce
these measures we do not need emergency
powers to enforce existing laws thank
you madam speaker
thank you very much madam speaker i'd
like to thank my colleague for agreeing
to share his time with me i think it's
very important for canadians to
understand that this is in no way that
the government's reaction the
government's proposal to invoke the
emergency measures act is in no way
connected to
public safety to restoring order or to
upholding the rule of law we know this
because we know what they've done with
previous protests and blockades when the
prime minister agrees with the aims of
protesters he does nothing
in fact actually it would be unfair to
say he does nothing he does nothing to
end the blockades he actually will send
negotiators he'll actually send
government delegations to meet with
protesters and even propose settlements
and compromises when he agrees with the
political aims of those protesting we
know this because in 2020
anti-energy protesters anti-oil and gas
worker
protesters held up vital transportation
links for
weeks madam speaker at the time the
prime minister had a much different tone
let's take a look at what he said when
vital transportation links when rail
lines were blockaded crippling the
canadian economy for weeks and weeks at
a time
he said and i quote
therefore we are creating a space for
peaceful
honest dialogue with willing partners
compare that to the rhetoric and
inflammatory language that he has used
over the past several weeks here in
2022. make no mistake madam speaker the
protests that are happening in ottawa
that have taken place across the country
are a direct result of the prime
minister's actions
and his rhetoric
the demonization
of people who are fighting to get their
rights back after two years of
incredible hardship
two years of politicians and government
agencies telling people
that they weren't allowed to have
family members visit them inside their
own home
after two years of governments telling
business owners that they had to keep
their doors shut
and their employees laid off after years
of people not able to use the various
support systems that they've had in
their life relying on friends and family
gyms closed
activities for children's cancelled
after two years of this just as there is
hope on the horizon as other
jurisdictions around the world and even
here in canada were lifting restrictions
and easing mandates the prime minister
added a new one
he added a new restriction after two
years of telling truck drivers that they
were essential services that they were
be allowed to travel across the border
to bring vital goods
into our markets
after two years of deeming them that
essential service just as there was hope
and reasons to lift restrictions and
mandates the prime minister added a new
one without any
data to back it up without any evidence
to back it up
then when people started objecting to
this finally saying enough is enough we
want our freedoms back madam speaker
it's time for the government to retreat
back to the normal boundaries of
government interference in our lives
when people started doing that started
to to gather together to peacefully
protest against government overreach
what did the prime minister do
he called them names
tried to smear them with broad brushes
he called them racists and misogynists
he asked the question the rhetorical
question madam speaker about whether or
not we should tolerate these people
madam speaker i'd like to ask the prime
minister a question what does not
tolerating these people look like
because what he's done over the past few
weeks has just been shameful this prime
minister has
has lowered the office
in which he serves to unprecedented
deaths in my 17 years of being a member
of parliament i've never seen a prime
minister for that matter any other
politician
so debased the office that they hold
hurling insults at people
referring to a
jewish member of this house as standing
with people waving swastikas just
outrageous madam speaker
and i have to find i have to tell my
honorable colleagues in the liberal
benches who have often admonished
their political opponents for in any way
you know even sharing the same
postal code as someone who may be
holding an an offensive flag or a
placard with unacceptable language on it
and when conservatives denounce that
that's not good enough for members of
the liberal party they say you know you
you're you're supposed to paint the
entire
group protesting with that broad brush
but
madam speaker they don't hold themselves
to that same standard
i see many honorable members across the
way some of which some of whom i've
served with i know them to be honorable
people i don't assume that they are all
racists
just because their leader has performed
racist acts
by putting on blackface so often in his
life that he can't remember how many
times he's done it we don't paint every
single liberal member of parliament with
that brush
they have no problem being photographed
with the prime minister despite his
history of racist acts
so neither should members of parliament
hold
or paint the entire group of people who
are protesting for their freedoms back
with that same broad brush
the lengths at which this government
and indeed not just the government but
many of their friends in the corporate
media to paint every single person who's
protesting who's who's demanding an end
to the restrictions and then to mandates
with that
broad brush madam speaker you look at
the lengths that they go to to to uh to
discredit and to uh and to dehumanize
those people who are just fighting for
their traditional
civil liberties
i asked the amount of speaker who
if we kind of
look at this into two different groups
on the one hand you've got people who
are saying after two years of hardship
two years of sacrifice two years of
being forced to comply with
unprecedented government intrusion in
our lives unprecedented the you know
government's telling you where you can
go
who you can have in your house that that
is a new level of government
interference in our life that we have
not seen
in recent canadian history after two
years of that there's a group of people
who are saying
i just don't believe i should be fired
for making a health care decision
then on the other hand you've got a
group of people who are saying that
anybody who holds that view
is a racist a misogynist an
insurrectionist madam speaker
you've got a group of people who are
saying that government should have the
ability to tell you who you can have in
your house whether or not your business
is allowed to stay open
which group seems more unreasonable
madam speaker i would say after two
years those who are fighting against
this government intrusion in their lives
have a legitimate case to be made
whether or not we agree with them or not
we must respect their right
to advocate for their views the prime
minister has not provided any
legitimate justification for bringing in
the emergency emergency measures out he
asks us to trust him
he says don't worry we're going to make
sure everything's fine with the courts
we're going to make sure everything's
compliant with the charter this is the
same guy who fired his attorney general
because she wouldn't go along with his
plans to interfere in a criminal court
case madam speaker so you will pardon
you will pardon the members of the
conservative party if we're not going to
take the prime minister's word that he's
not going to abuse the power that he's
granting himself
[Applause]
he points to specific incidences
specific incidences that conservatives
also denounced we denounced the rail
blockades in 2020 and we denounced the
border blockades in 2022. because madam
speaker we do not believe that the right
to peacefully protest
should mean that you get to infringe on
the freedom and rights of other people
but when we raised that point in 2020
calling on the government to do
something about the rail blockades when
it was the anti-energy workers who by
the way there are a lot of radical
left-wing protests across the country
where you see all kinds of placards
anti-semitic placards you see banners
advocating violence committed against
police officers you don't see the
government rushing to crack down on that
they're talking about foreign funding
madam speaker
how about the foreign funding that's
poured into canada by the mill hundreds
of millions
to
help groups fight against energy
projects and natural resource resource
projects across the country didn't seem
to bother the government then madam
speaker but now all of a sudden they say
that they've got to do something about
it it's a little bit like that scene in
casablanca when the inspector comes to
to rick and says sorry i have to close
the the place down uh there's illegal
gambling going on and then the croupier
comes over and puts his winnings in his
pocket that's what this government is
doing for years they've relied on
foreign funding coming to help their
allies in the political spectrum fight
for their goals and fight against
canadians
and their interests so madam speaker i'm
just going to close on this this is the
exact same playbook that we've seen
dictatorial governments across the
country they dehumanize their opponents
they have uh
they invoke threats of foreign influence
remember the berlin wall was built to
keep others out ostensibly governments
always talk about their good intentions
when they take away rights and liberties
but i'm asking canadians not to be
fooled by this and i'm asking members of
the liberal party who actually believe
in civil liberties who actually do
believe in the natural limits of
government to do the
questions and comments
uh the honourable fellow major secretary
to the minister of sport
i had to just rush back into the house i
was sitting in the lobby and listening
to that speech and i just couldn't
believe how
willing the member from regina cappell
was to just justify justify all these
behaviors we're seeing i saw a video of
him crossing the road this morning
giving a thumbs up and shaking hands
with people who've been occupying uh
this this this capital city for for the
last three weeks and i my direct
question to the member is if this was
happening in regina if his you know
neighbors were being occupied and
harassed downtown and were afraid to
leave their homes would your position be
exactly the same as it is here would you
be giving them a thumbs up every single
day
speak to the chair if you don't the
honourable member of the honorable
member for regina cappell this member
comes from a caucus whose leader sent a
delegation to protesters he's saying
that i shouldn't wave back to people who
wave to me that your gov his government
actually sent a minister with a mandate
to negotiate
madam speaker i'm canadian i'll wave at
people when they wave to me i'll say
hello to people who say hello to me when
i have constituents who have left their
homes to come and fight for their
freedoms i will listen to them i will be
civil because if the government hadn't
started off this whole thing with that
type of attitude we might not even be
having this debate today madam speaker
against
um
[Music]
is
uh first of all i will start off my
remarks by uh thanking the members of
the black cabbage because we agree we
disagree on many things philosophically
but it's nice to know that even if we
disagree on policy that there's still
some common ground on the principles
about using the sledgehammer that the
government's brought in but the member
is invoking a a
series of events that happened in 2012
the conservative party didn't bring in
the emergency measures act in 2012 it's
legitimate there are going to be
protests across this across the country
across time where various parties are
going to agree with the aims of the
protests or disagree and we can all
express our opinion about whether or not
those protests are should be happening
but the government should not be
bringing in this massive sledgehammer to
crack down on dissent when there are
existing laws the prime minister talked
about coots
the prime minister talked about the kutz
border crossing it was resolved with
existing laws with existing tools that
law enforcement have there's no need for
this action
thank you madam speaker the honorable
member for regina cappell
i found his speech disturbing at many
levels there were more dog whistles to a
rabid base of trump supporters in one
sort speech that i've heard enough ever
in this place but i'd like to correct
the record and ask the honorable member
to consider
that when the government of canada
sent a delegation it was because that
would suit and hereditary chiefs have
supreme court of canada on their side
that they have a continuity of
leadership territorial responsibility
that goes back to our constitution
supreme court of canada that would suit
and hereditary chiefs required that both
british colombia and the government of
canada in the honor of the crown sent
representatives to discuss the situation
with them they were not protesters they
were chiefs
for regina cappell well madam speaker i
believe
the honourable member may be the only
member of this house who's actually
arrested for participating in an illegal
protest so for her to now somehow
justify the emergency measures act would
she have appreciated while she was
breaking laws and getting arrested if
the government had the power to freeze
her bank account madam speaker would she
have appreciated anybody who made a
donation to the green party at that time
having their bank accounts frozen for
supporting her illegal activities madam
speaker i
doubt it
resuming debate the honorable member for
king's heads
madam speaker i'll be sharing my time
with my honorable colleague from utramal
uh this afternoon
today i realized to deliver what be what
may be the most important speech i've
given since having the privilege to
serve the people of king's hands in the
house
today we as parliamentarians are
debating whether the government's
decision to invoke the emergencies act
on monday was justified
i submit to my colleagues in this house
and indeed all canadians watching that
the threshold required to trigger the
emergency act has been objectively met
and perhaps exceeded
as the prime minister has said in this
house a decision of this nature is not
taken lightly
however the situation we have seen
across the country is serious and
warrants a response that is
proportionate to the impact we have seen
on all canadians
let me be very clear i've i am in full
support of legal protests in this
country it is a constitutionally
protected right and indeed i have spoken
to some of my own constituents who in
their own way have demonstrated their
displeasure with the government's
protocols to date
however we have to delineate between
lawful protest and individuals who
refuse to abide by the rule of law
who have occupied ottawa and who have
blockaded our key border crossings
i believe it's incumbent on all of us to
look at the facts and to try to be
objective
we've seen a group of individuals in
ottawa who have occupied the city for
now three weeks
this despite orders from law authorities
to disperse and to go home
the key organizers of the ottawa
occupation have openly exposed their
goal of overthrowing the government of
meeting with the governor general to
form a coalition
we've had blockades across the country
at keyboarding crossings which have
targeted the country's trade
relationship including at windsor
coots and emerson
at cootes the rcmp have found weapons
and body armor
how can one conclude that this was
simply a peaceful protest
the minister of public safety outlined
to this house this morning what the
impact was having across the country
economically
hundreds of millions of dollars a day in
economic harm
blocking critical infrastructure
critical trade routes that hurts
everyday canadians it impacts our food
security and our supply chain
there has been a targeted impact of the
ottawa international airport and the
organizers of the freedom convoy have
expressed their desire to re-establish
blockades and occupations elsewhere even
if they were taken down by police
we also know that these activities are
being financed by international sources
i ask members of these hosts
do we as parliamentarians have a
responsibility to take action on
internationally financed activities
to organizers of activity that is not
only illegal
but indeed represents a threat to
canadian security and the rule of law
i for one believe we do
i want to be crystal clear
this is being done to target activities
that are illegal
and threatening the economic health of
the country and the rule of law and
order
for those whose intent is to raise
issues about government policy i have no
issue
for those who continue to be a part of
illegal blockades here in ottawa
or elsewhere you do not have the ability
to do so and these measures are being
implemented because of your
unwillingness to abide by the law
so what is the public emergency order
being invoked under the mergers under
the emergencies act
what does it actually mean
the conservatives would have you believe
this government is limiting all freedoms
these measures do not take away freedoms
the block would suggest that this is
akin to the war measures act
and are seeking to drum up memories of
the flq crisis
this is not the war measures act it is
not taking away the rights of the
charter of rights and freedoms and it is
not calling in the army
this is a specific measure to give
additional powers to police and
provincial authorities to maintain law
and order
monitor the financing including from
foreign sources that is being used to
block and undermine critical
infrastructure and to ultimately remove
the blockades and occupations that exist
across the country
let's examine the actual measures in the
order
the regulation and prohibition of public
assemblies that lead to a breach of the
peace and go beyond
lawful protest
i want to be clear lawful protests can
continue
designated and securing places where
blockades are to be prohibited
directing persons to render essential
services to relieve impacts of blockades
on canada's economy so this could
include things like tow trucks madam
speaker that could be requisitioned of
course for compensation by government
authorities to help remove with
removing trucks and vehicles that are
blockading key infrastructure
authorizing or directing financial
institutions to render essential
services that relieve the impact of
blockades including regulating and
prohibiting the use of property to fund
and support the blockades that are
undermining economic security in the
country
measures enabling the rcmp to enforce
municipal bylaw and provincial offenses
where required and the imposition of
fines under section section 19 of the
emergencies act
i submit to this host that these
measures are suspect
specific they are time limited and
geographically focused the measures will
be overseen by a joint parliamentary
committee and of course must be
supported by a majority in this house to
remain in force
i have previously mentioned that
policing is in the domain of
municipalities and the provincial
government madam speaker since day one
our government was and continues to work
directly with municipal and provincial
authorities
and their law enforcement we've answered
calls for additional resources we helped
create integrated operations
and additional rcmp officers to try and
deal with blockades
leading into monday's decision it was
clear that the provincial municipal
authorities were being unable to address
the situation
ironically members of this house were
calling us to show federal leadership
some conservatives after openly
encouraging illegal activity to continue
and we're asking the government to stop
the blockades well these measures are
designed to do exactly
that
my question to members in this house who
are criticizing the government for
making available
time limited tools
under the emergencies act to support law
enforcement
what intermediate step would you suggest
the government should have undertaken
beyond asking the prime minister to meet
with individuals who fly flags that say
[ __ ] trudeau
and want to overthrow a democrat
democratically elected government and
have stated that they will not leave
until their demands are met
what security measures would you have
suggested this government should have
undertaken that is the key question
as my constituents madam speaker have
rightfully pointed out it is easy to be
an armchair critic
but i have yet to hear much constructive
measures on the other side of the house
on how to deal with the current
situation
madam speaker i support the government's
measures they are reasonable
they are balanced
and they are proportionate to the
circumstances we have seen
they are focused on giving tools to
police
in jurisdictions across the country to
resolve illegal blockades that are
hurting everyday canadians and i think
it's extremely important for all of us
to remember that these are tools that
are available
this order is in effect for 30 days
this is to make sure that we have the
ability to address the circumstances
that we've seen i would hope that all
members of this house believe that this
is an important measure
so that we can make sure that the
blockades the economic harm and frankly
the lack of rule and order that we've
seen in certain elements of this country
do not continue thank you madam speaker
i look forward to taking questions from
my honorable colleagues
questions and comments the honorable
member for edmonton west
my name is speaker i'd like to thank my
colleague for his uh
um
his speech today earlier we heard from
one of his colleagues that
the government says they know what a
lawful protest looks like i'm wondering
why the government then
did not act when we had protesters
blockading
via rail
cn rail blocking the port of vancouver
crippling our economy and crippling
pipelines and oil and gas trends to the
point that alberta companies are
offering to truck propane to quebec
why is that considered a lawful protest
not to be uh subject to such extreme
draconian acts that the government is
bringing in now compared to what's going
on right now
member for king's hands thank you madam
speaker i anticipated the question
because i've noticed on this side of the
house on the opposite side that the
members are trying to create that
narrative in fact i i find they've been
inconsistent in their own way in the
fact that they were very quick to call
on government action back in 2020 and
were silent for nearly two weeks on what
we've seen in ottawa and elsewhere in
the country the difference for me madam
speaker of why this rises to the level
of the emergency act is the fact that
there has been an open
stated goal of those that have been
involved in the protest to actually
overthrow government and to cause
disruption and harm to canadians i will
go on record and say it is absolutely
unacceptable regardless of the motions
or the the notion and desire of
protesters to block critical
infrastructure i support measures that
that do that including in this way here
today
[Music]
unlike
[Music]
safety management
instead of
letting
you know
in front of the honourable member
madam speaker in the absence of federal
government leadership ordinary people
brave as they may be put themselves in
harm's way because of this government
protecting the people is the cornerstone
of the contract between citizens and the
government does the government
understand the consequences of its lack
of leadership that was from the critic
from the black quebecois four days ago
what do they expect federal government
leadership to look like do they suggest
that it looks like what the
conservatives are calling for that the
government just simply does as those
outside wellington are asking for and
just eliminate any public health measure
related to covid
what we are doing is very simple we are
giving tools to local law authorities
including in quebec to use at their
discretion to avoid what we've seen
across the country with the met with the
member opposite think that it is a good
idea to have those tools available such
that if there was a blockade at le call
that that is not something that we can
do to be able to address that situation
and it's ironic because they say why
didn't this happen at the time
at the reality is it has to work its way
to a federal level which it has over the
past three weeks have we intervened at
the first time they would have been the
same party to say that it was an
overstep and to respect provincial
jurisdiction it is hypocrisy
before timmins james bay
speaker having been in ottawa for most
of this blockade what i've seen is a
complete lack of willingness of the
police to do their job this should never
have spiraled uh this was allowed to
metastasize
and create as crisis at our borders
cutting off um hundreds of millions of
dollars of trade i remember when the
conservatives were saying that if you
know ten unvaccinated truckers didn't
get to cross the border uh we'd have all
our supply lines and our stores shut
down when that didn't happen their
supporters actually shut the border but
i'd like to ask the honorable member now
that we're at this point
it does speak to the absolute failure of
this government to have shown leadership
throughout we should never be in a
situation where we're using the
emergency act against people who are
setting up hot tubs on wellington street
because of the lack of rule of law
for king's hands in 15 seconds or less
i'm trying to be very quick the member
talks about leadership what type of
leadership would he like to see would
you like to see a federal government
overreach in the first few days of
imposing federal powers would the
members suggest that leadership looks
like acquiescing to what the
conservatives have said no what we've
done is we've waited until the situation
warranted a federal response here we are
we're putting tools in place to be able
to address the situation uh
it's a bit of a nothing question in my
mind thank you resuming debate uh the
honorable parliamentary secretary to the
minister of tourism assistant minister
of finance
uh
and for good reason
[Music]
and
we cannot and we will not let canada's
reputation on the international stage be
tarnished that's why
we are taking action
the emergency economic measures order
will allow the government to take
concrete steps concrete action to stop
the financing of the illegal blockades
the main objective of these measures is
to limit the flow of money that is used
to finance this unlawful activity and to
prevent additional financial support
as the deputy prime minister and
minister finance has said before
this is about following the money
two broad categories of financial
measures are being enacted first
those aimed at crowdfunding platforms
and payment service providers and second
those applicable to canadian financial
service providers
let's look at the first one funding
platforms and some payment service
providers are not currently subject to
the anti-money laundering
and anti-terrorist financing laws that
we have in this country it therefore
stands to reason that they could be used
to finance unlawful activities such as
the blockades that we are seeing
to address this the order extends the
scope of canada's anti-money laundering
and anti-terrorist financing rules to
cover crowdfunding platforms and the
payment processors that they use
specifically the entities that are in
possession of any funds associated with
the illegal blockades are now required
to register with fintrac the financial
transactions and reports analysis center
of canada and to report suspicious and
large value transactions of persons
involved in the blockades
this will mitigate the risks that these
platforms could be used to receive funds
from illicit sources or to finance
illicit activity
second with respect to our financial
service providers
the order directs them to intervene when
they suspect that an account belongs to
someone participating in the illegal
blockades this means that banks
insurance companies and other financial
service providers must now temporarily
cease providing financial services
including freezing their accounts when
they believe an account holder or client
is engaged in illegal blockades
the order applies to all funds held in a
deposit in a checking or in a savings
account and to any other type of
property this also includes digital
assets such as cryptocurrencies
as a result canadian financial service
providers are now able to immediately
freeze or suspend an account of an
individual or business
affiliated with these illegal blockades
and to do so without a court order madam
speaker
financial service providers are also
protected against civil liability for
the actions that they take to comply
with the order
of course these service providers are
required to unfreeze accounts when the
account holder stops assisting or
participating in the illegal blockades
or in missouri emergency economic
measures
the government is also ordering
canadian financial institutions to
review
institutions
[Music]
individuals
activities
[Music]
came from
[Music]
madam speaker the message is clear
from the finance perspective if people
are funding blockades that harm the
canadian economy their bank account will
be frozen if people
that fund blockades think that they can
get around the law by using
cryptocurrencies
that won't work
if a company's truck is used in illegal
activity the vehicle's insurance will be
suspended and the company's bank
accounts will be frozen
semi-trailers they should be on our
roads madam speaker not parked for weeks
on end in front of parliament they
should be delivering the goods and the
services and that will grow our economy
not holding up traffic at border
crossings or paralyzing our city centers
so let's see
optimistic
economy
entrepreneurship
economic deficit
before we go to questions and comments i
believe the honourable member for regina
cappell has a point of order thank you
madam speaker i just want to clarify the
record i misspoke during my questions
and comments in response to the member
for sandwich golf islands i indicated
that she was the only member of this
house to have been arrested for
protesting illegally i of course
completely forgot the image of the
minister of the environment in his
orange jumpsuit he too was arrested for
illegal protest
the honorable member for sanex school
funds
to the honorable member for regina
capella i would like to retain the honor
of being the only member of parliament
currently serving as a member of
parliament when i faced arrest
non-violently surrendering immediately
and accepting the consequences unlike
our friends outside
questions and comments the honourable
member for yorkton melville
she's been waiting thank you madam time
thank you matt
uh the individual who just spoke
indicated that one of the problems here
is that canada's reputation is being
tarnished by this and i would ask her
whose reputation is truly being
tarnished canadians reputations are this
government's repute reputation the
stands of everyday canadians
that have been taken have gained
international support and have drawn
disdain directly towards the liberal
government and especially the language
and actions of this prime minister
the honorable parliamentary secretary
i'm sure it will come as no surprise
madam speaker that i entirely disagree i
think that there are many people
that have
fallen to um
how can i say canadians have lost
confidence in many different
institutions as a result of what has
been happening over the course of the
last three weeks top of mind is the
police i believe that many canadians
right across the country questioned
whether law enforcement was there and
this emergency measures act provides
more tools to our police force in order
to maintain confidence in law and order
in this country
is
does she agree with uh
[Music]
emergencies
thank you madam speakers
what
parliamentarians will have the powers to
guarantee
uh
entirely with my colleagues
emergencies
and powers for all parliamentarians to
end the application of this act thank
you the honorable parliamentary
secretary to the government health
leader
thank you very much madam speaker madam
speaker i noticed today some very
interesting public opinion polling
coming out of quebec as a matter of fact
it says that 72
of quebecers support the use of the
emergency measures act more importantly
abacus data that's act that's been
released recently say that
63
of block members block supporters in the
last election would never vote for an mp
that supports the occupation going on
outside yet the block seems to be
showing their support for the occupation
i'm wondering if the member the
parliamentary secretary can provide some
insight into that
the honorable parliamentary secretary
uh the honorable parliamentary secretary
madam speaker um i think i will address
uh this question uh in french uh with
the provision of my colleague
uh
as i said earlier
the vast majority of quebecers are in
favor
that we have to be very cautious
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you madam speaker and i will be
splitting my time
for remarks with the honorable member
from south surrey white rock
uh miss madam speaker
it's an honor to rise on behalf of the
citizens of kamloops thompson caribou
not only uh in this house generally but
in such important times and sometimes we
do forget what a what a tremendous honor
it is
i'm sad though to be here discussing
emergency measures here today
this has been a time with respect where
the prime minister has inflamed
has incited
and has divided
the prime minister took that same
inflammatory approach yesterday when he
spoke in response to a question
from the member
from thornhill
i was dismayed that he would not
apologize or did not apologize for that
today
instead he come came into this house
this morning
and doubled down on years of division
so let's recap
the predecessor legislation was invoked
three times world war one
world war ii
and the flq crisis
the prime minister invites and likes for
canadians to think that he's the common
person so i i'm not sure if he has
walked through downtown ottawa of late
but i did yesterday and today
and i saw trucks and streets
there were a few streets that were
plugged and those trucks need to go
period
the question then becomes how should
that be done
now i took an oath when i was sworn in
and it was the greatest days of my life
to take that oath on behalf of all
canadians and particularly on behalf of
the
residents of kamloops thompson caribou
and i took my oath to do my job to the
best of my ability
i have to be satisfied as a legislator
that the preconditions for this act have
been met
that is my job that is the oath i took
and that is something that i take
very seriously
so i read the act
and i considered it
i actually had to read it twice
i've practiced law for 14 years madam
speaker i previously taught at a law
school for a number of years
so when it came to my analysis of the
act i did
what i taught my students to do i went
back to first legal principles first
statutory principles and we apply legal
principles and statutory principles not
because it is popular
not because we want the trucks to be
cleared at um in any way possible but
because
we here 338 of us must apply
the law
after all the prime minister has made
the same remark about the remarks about
the rule of law
he wouldn't strip canadians of
citizenship just because it was popular
just because people may like it
but instead we must accede to
the rule of law so let's apply the rule
of law madam speaker let's apply
the legislation here
this legislation
is clear
it says that its application
must
be the last resort
members of this house have repeatedly
asked
what
was step one
crickets
what
was
step two
crickets
the police weren't even stopping people
carrying jerry cans in
what was step three more crickets
word salad
the official leader of the opposition
asked the prime minister to attend a
meeting with all party leaders with a
view
to bringing this matter to an end and by
my count that was about 10 days ago
crickets
even without the emergencies act
application which is alive right now
madam speaker
protesters could be arrested under the
current regime there are laws about
causing a disturbance mischief and
participation in these sorts of illegal
activities the criminal code is very
clear on that and i'm not even touching
on the ontario highways traffic act the
trucks could be seized incidental to
arrest as evidence they could be seized
with a warrant
all things that the police have at their
disposal right here right now to address
the very situation that the emergencies
act
says it will deal with as a last resort
these first resorts have not been
addressed
so let's next look madam speaker at what
was resolved without the use of the
emergencies act kutz
the ambassador bridge
windsor
why because the police had the powers to
do so and used those powers my point
madam speaker is this
the legislation says that we do not
resort to its use unless it is
absolutely necessary and what we have
seen in these three instances i just
mentioned is that it is not absolutely
necessary and as a legislator i need to
be convinced that the threshold has been
met or i will not vote for such
legislation
i wish we could simply invoke
legislation
to make our problems go away
that's just not the case madam speaker
it can't be done as a measure of
convenience let's not forget
this wasn't done during 9 11
this wasn't done during covet this
wasn't done during railway blockades
that had a crippling impact on our
economy and economic consequences
this wasn't done throughout many
protests throughout the country
this wasn't done
when bc highways and rail were washed
out
due to recent flooding
i recently received an inquiry from a
constituent in the north thompson area
near blue river in my riding
there have been protests in that area
for years and blue river is a small
community
violence threats blockades
and i told that constituent what i am
telling this house
the legislation is a last resort to be
used in extraordinary circumstances of
national emergency when nothing else
will do
as a member
for as one of the members for ottawa
here said earlier today this has been
going on for four weeks and i echo that
sentiment i understand that it's been
going on for four weeks and those
committing illegal activity need to stop
it has been going on for much longer in
my riding and those people are asking
the same questions
now in closing madam speaker
i will say this i do agree with the
prime minister on one point and he did
say that he is trying to save jobs
unfortunately i would eliminate the
plural he's trying to save one job his
own
and that is not right thank you madam
speaker questions and comments the
honorable parliamentary secretary to the
minister of international trade thank
you madam speaker i welcome that member
to the house as a new member but also as
a fellow member of the bar i'll politely
point out that
uh public uh an emergency was not um i
asked that the people who are outside of
the chamber please
uh stop speaking so loudly we can barely
hear ourselves here
thank you the honorable parliamentary
secretary so i welcome the new member
also welcomes him as a fellow member of
the bar he indicated he's read the
statute he knows full well that in terms
of kovid enacting a public welfare
emergency requires the provinces to
initiate such a request no request is
forthcoming secondly he asked for what
steps had been taken the first step was
actually the city of the ottawa
declaring an emergency which didn't
render the results the second step was
the city the province of ontario
declaring an emergency which hasn't
rendered results the last step the final
step is this very important debate that
we're having today i'm going to put to
him an issue about the capability of the
province under its authorities to deal
with it which i think is squarely an
issue because the provincial order that
has been made by premier ford fails in
two important respects it does not
compel essential workers like tow trucks
to actually tow vehicles away and
secondly it cannot compel vehicle
licenses to be suspended where that
vehicle originates in another province
such as one of the western provinces are
those not instances of a lack of
provincial authority which necessitates
the usage of the emergencies act in this
case
the member for kamloops thompson caribou
uh well the criminal code actually deals
with all of those issues and when when
the honorable member speaks about uh the
the invocation of a state of emergency i
didn't see a single thing change he's
right i didn't see a single thing change
i didn't see any enforcement change what
was step one what was step two we can't
simply do this because we don't like how
something is being enforced it should be
a matter of last resort and those steps
are available in the criminal code
whether it comes to seizure to search or
to seizure and arrest with warrants so
with respect i i disagree
come out there
the honorable member for
the u.n security council the honorable
member for kamloops thompson caribou i
would uh thank the honorable minister
for his remarks i look forward to
someday hopefully being a pardon me
oh i'm sorry did i say minister
honorable member i i misspoke i thank
the honourable member for uh for his
remarks
um
the prime minister declared canada is
back
when he was first elected
the problem is this
you can say anything you want to say but
at the end of the day it's actions that
people will judge and when people look
at actions they look at integrity and we
have a prime minister that with respect
has not displayed a great deal of
integrity whether it comes to ethical
breaches or it comes to a deliberate
desire to divide both in this house but
also with respect to canadians thank you
susan gomez the honorable member for
hamilton center
madam speaker we're seeing growing
escalations this situation is clearly
out of control due to the lack of
leadership from all levels of government
in addition to the firearms and arrests
for conspiracy to commit murder and
coots an attempted arson of a
residential building in the occupation
area convoy members have been deputizing
themselves and now claim they have the
lawful authority to detain and arrest
others
madam speaker i don't recall the
honorable member mentioning the
seriousness of the violent terror cell
apprehended at coots on conspiracy to
commit murder no one wants to see
someone get hurt here yet this is a
recipe for disaster
does the honourable member and the
conservatives not view this situation as
an emergency
for kamloops thompson caribou
i'm very clear here
when we talk about the legislation has
the threshold been met
simply saying do you do you review it
this way colloquially isn't the question
that is before this house the question
madam speaker that's before this house
is has the threshold been met and with
respect i don't believe it has been
because i don't view this as the act of
last resort thank you madam speaker you
mean debate the honorable member for
south surrey white rock
well thank you thank you very much madam
speaker it is
a somber time
in this house to be speaking it is
a seminal time in canadian history in my
view
it is apparent to me that we seem to be
living in two canadas
there is the canada fear and division
promoted by the current prime minister
and the leader of the ndp
confirmed by their caucuses but there's
another canada
out there a united and proud nation that
has sacrificed and done without and
suffered economically physically and in
their mental health condition this is a
canada that is a bit worn out plainly
speaking but still firmly patriotic and
ready to take on whatever the future
brings they are canadians who do not
share this pm's post national narrative
and embrace the essence of canada that
they see themselves as a part of as the
true north strong and free
in our national anthem we call out to
god and we pray that he keep our land
glorious and free
the truth is that canada can only be
glorious if it is free
meaning its people are free free from
tyranny free from government abusing its
awesome powers
mindful of the responsibility and trust
given to it in a representative
democracy because this prime minister
wants to dwell in the extreme infringe
and false narratives of what is
happening during peaceful protests i am
choosing to address those other
canadians
i remember the historical term the two
solitudes mr speaker in reference to
impasses between anglophone and
francophone people in canada its meaning
was meant to refer to a perceived lack
of communication and moreover a lack of
will to communicate here today we see
history repeating itself madam speaker a
lack of communication but more
significantly a lack of will to
communicate between the present federal
government and anglophone and
francophone citizens alike the emergency
act is extraordinary legislation
extraordinary means remarkable
exceptional unusual and uncommon
the measures in this act are to be
entered into reservedly advisedly and
with extreme caution
through all the trials and tribulations
of a newly created and burgeoning nation
trying to unite coast to coast to coast
through other public health emergencies
through other civil unrest our federal
government saw fit to invoke the
emergency act and its precursor the war
measures act only four times in our
history
these
extraordinary measures were used in
world war one
world war ii
prime minister trudeau won and prime
minister trudeau too
excuse me
world war one
world war ii
a previous prime minister in the 1970s
and the current prime minister
it was not invoked madam speaker during
the fears and protests around the
spanish flu it was not involved during
the workers strikes in the nineteen
thirties not invoked during the crises
in oklahoma or caledonia during the
aftermath of 9 11.
during crippling national strikes
affecting our supply chains
during the rail blockades or pipeline
protests also negatively affecting the
canadian economy the list is long madam
speaker the point is where other methods
and authorities exist to deal with
serious disagreement
government should use those methods and
authorities
government should not subjugate free
people to abusive wide-ranging freedom
altering overreach of government
a liberal member asking a question
earlier in this debate said to the
leader of the opposition well what if
this happened in your neighborhood in
your riding
well it did help happen in my
neighborhood madam speaker and in my
riding
it happened at one of the border
crossings in south surrey white rock i
received many reports on the ground
about the activities there i did have
three complaints through national media
calling the people involved the same
outrageous inflammatory names
that the liberal party and the prime
minister have been using
there were no complaints to my office
on the other side i have had
overwhelming outpourings of support from
my constituents because the supporting
protests were meaningful to those in
attendance and even joyful in hope for
change what kind of change not
necessarily a change in government
although that might happen in the next
federal election
but most definitely a change in federal
government approach
on two previous weekends vehicle after
vehicle in support of the right to
protest this government's policies
actions and inactions
drove in a rolling loop around those
border crossings and highways in south
surrey with thousands not hundreds
thousands of canadians cheering them on
from the sides of the roads and on
highway overpasses those involved were
vocal but peaceful holding high canadian
flags singing the national anthem saying
prayers and greeting others cheerfully
including the police the result madam
speaker is that the border has been
cleared goods are flowing and the police
using tools already at their disposal
were able to show both respect for the
protesters and clear any impasses
why is the emergencies act needed now in
my riding it isn't
the only distress being expressed right
now from my riding is that the prime
minister and his cabinet are showing
disdain having inflamed the situation
are not even attempting to engage in
dialogue and saw the only tool in their
toolbox
to be taught taking more power unto
themselves
i have heard from many civil enforcement
officers civil liberties scholars and
lawyers on this subject madam speaker
collectively they want me to remind the
house that a public order event is not
necessarily an emergency we are down to
a protest in a few blocks of downtown
ottawa that's all with some proper
policing the situation in ottawa can be
brought to a conclusion as it has been
elsewhere unlike some of the other
events
down
in downtown ottawa our nation's capital
were not at a u.s border so it does not
affect imports and exports
i'm not sure who the leader of the ndp
was referring to when he said don't let
your anger turn into hatred the prime
minister has turned his back literally
on a large segment of canadian citizens
showing them nothing but derision and
disdain this only escalates never
de-escalates tension and disagreement
i had occasion madam speaker early in my
career to attend advanced negotiation
classes at harvard law school under the
supervision of professor roger fisher
the author of the acclaimed book titled
getting to yes
there are necessary steps that should be
taken in any conflict resolution some
form of engagement de-escalating
de-escalation respectful dialogue
looking to best alternatives to resolve
the conflict short of the only one the
pm has employed which has been described
as the nuclear option
i agree that we should never have been
at this moment looking like a failed
nation state we are looking this way due
to weak and ineffective leadership it is
that simple
why invoke this act now when it was not
invoked all those times before the
federal government should be talking to
and engaging with citizens to resolve
this conflict by introducing a plan to
get back to normal instead we have seen
the federal government demonize and
insult our fellow canadians
prime minister they are all canadians
out there on wellington street and a
canadian is a canadian is a canadian i'm
pretty sure i heard that somewhere
before
instead of creating a plan engaging in
dialogue and looking for a peaceful
solution the prime minister is looking
to
invoke and stoke more fear and division
countries around the world and canadians
themselves at home are looking at this
and wondering is this my canada is this
the canada
i have
believed in patriotically firmly and
with a full heart for so long
the truth is that the prime minister and
the government initiated these protests
by canadians by calling them down
in the first place and then not dealing
with it as it unfolded
i think back to a former leader of the
progressive conservative party that went
along with the former prime ministers
uh who invoked the war measures act
and then for the third time in chris in
canadian history and not during wartime
madam speaker
he voted for that war measures act
his name was robert stansfield he later
said it was the greatest regret of his
life that he voted with the government
that day edmund burke has often quoted
the only thing necessary for the triumph
of evil is that good men do nothing well
i stand against this measure with every
fiber of my being i will vote no this is
a free
country
and its people should be free
free to protest free to exercise they're
given
human rights
and we need to respect
and engage them thank you
questions and comments the honorable
parliamentary secretary
secretary to the minister of
international trade
thank you very much madam speaker and i
respect the member opposite a great deal
and served on the justice committee in
the last parliament or just simply put
it to her because i've heard this
narrative throughout the debate thus far
that the tools are no longer necessary
for example vis-a-vis blockades at
borders because the blockades have been
cleared and i put to her a few simple
facts just simply one
lawyer to another that we know that
there was an attempted resurrection of a
blockade at windsor just yesterday and
the windsor police used the tools under
the emergencies act to their benefit to
prevent and thwart that quickly we also
know the protesters who have threatened
to take up arms have openly declared
that they will be returning to quebec
city on february 19th in front of the
assembly national and we know the type
of arms that were seized at kutz does
not these threats and ongoing threats
merit the necessity of using a federal
power including the emergencies act to
deal with what is an ongoing current and
future situation in this country
the honorable member for south surrey
white rock thank you madam speaker and i
thank my my friend offset i also uh have
great respect for his intellect and
abilities and yes i apologize to all
canadians we are both lawyers
but having said that we are now members
of parliament and as well and
with great respect
i do not think it should have ever come
to this i believe the prime minister and
the government should have engaged in
respectful dialogue should have at least
signaled out
an understanding that we can have
differences of opinion in a free country
and those differences are being listened
to and if the government had acted on
our opposition motion to table a plan of
action
all of this would have calmed down
immeasurably
uh questions and comments the honorable
member for timmins james bay
thank you madam speaker i certainly
agree this should never have come to
this uh the fact that a protest was
allowed to become an occupation speaks
to failures at every single level but
the problem i really have with my
honorable colleague and what her party's
saying is you know if the prime minister
just gone out and talked to the nice
protesters everything would have been
settled
when pat king
an organizer for them the spokesperson
said this is going to be settled with
bullets a line is crushed and i know the
fact that he's talking about shooting
the prime minister uh may not seem like
a problem but it should be a problem it
should be a problem to every
parliamentarian i will not negotiate
with anyone who talks about shooting a
prime minister of this country they need
to start addressing these issues
for so terry white rock
well i thank my colleague for the
question and with all due respect
the police and law enforcement
authorities in this country deal with
threats deal with violence every single
day they deal with it effectively they
deal with it forcefully and they deal
with it definitively our crown
prosecutors make sure that those people
come to justice i am not
i have you there the expression that's
coming to my mind madam speaker is oh ye
of little faith why do you have such
little faith in the people who are
tasked with keeping us safe you don't
need
these extraordinary measures
questions and comments questions
is
literally on social media
thank you my colleague for the question
it would be
really refreshing to actually have real
evidence connecting these dots the
minister for emergency preparedness at a
press conference in the last couple of
days
asserted that what happened at cootes
the arrested coots were directly related
to the leadership here in ottawa and
under questioning by the media backed
down back down further back down further
again and basically said well i'm just
sort of figuring that out myself that is
not real evidence that is not a real
connection and that is not a national
security threat
declaration
statements by members the honorable
member for kitchener center
madam speaker i'm pleased to rise in the
house today to recognize a better tent
city an innovative and successful
housing solution
serving previously unsheltered neighbors
of mine in waterloo region consisting of
42 insulated cabins and an indoor
warming space kitchen showers and
laundry a better tent city is a safe and
caring place born from the leadership of
the late ron doyle jeff wilmer and
nadine greene among others
the dean the site coordinator and whose
compassion brings calm in the time in
times of crisis feels particularly
fitting to celebrate during black
history month as her leadership is one
example of black excellence in waterloo
region
a better tent study is supported by so
many including the volunteers staff and
board at st mary's church and the social
development center in light of this
incredible grassroots work a better tent
city recently received our community's
highest honor the barn raiser award for
showing us what's possible when a group
of people rallied
honorable member for that dartmouth my
dartmouth cole harbor
thank you very much madam speaker
and speaker throughout this pandemic the
people of dartmouth coal harbor have
shown the very best that canada has to
offer
from embracing public health measures
like staying the blazes home
to mourning incredible tragedies
together
we've been there for each other
while keeping six feet apart
and like all canadians this pandemic has
worn us down we are so tired
but just as public health measures are
easing those who seek to harm our
country and our democracy through
conspiracy theories and misinformation
are using this opportunity to sow
discord i always see the best in people
but the rise in hate is so high
folks in our community our neighbors our
friends
are finding themselves caught up in this
and i know that this hate and this
hostility is not at the heart of who we
are madam speaker i ask that all
canadians
be there for each other by speaking out
against misinformation and standing up
against hate thank you very much man
honorable member for niagara west
thank you very much madam speaker i
think i speak for most canadians when i
say the last two years have been
extremely difficult at times like this
one would think that the leader of our
country the prime minister would be
there to unite canadians unfortunately
that has not been the case he's done it
the opposite don't take my word for it
his own liberal mps have said so the
prime minister chose to divide canadians
as a political strategy to win an
election he pitted one canadian against
the other for his own political gain he
called canadians tired of mandates and
restrictions a fringe minority with
unacceptable views he said they're
extremists misogynist racist and asked
if these canadians should be tolerated
this prime minister has fanned the
flames of division to a point of a
national crisis and his solution is to
divide canadians further to implement
unprecedented and extreme government
measures through the emergencies act
this is a crisis that he himself created
madam speaker
where does this prime minister's
recklessness stop
the honorable member for aurora oak
ridge's richmond hill
thank you madam speaker
um i rise today to speak about black
history month and i know i'm not the
only one to do that this month
but it should be spoken about often
which is why this year's theme is
february and forever celebrating black
history today and every day
we need to remember black history is
canadian history which at times has been
for the worst but over the years has
become significantly for the better
our communities are enriched by our
black neighbors and friends who take on
many important roles
the honorable gene augustine proposed
the motion we recognize that we
recognize february as black history
month was the first black woman elected
to this house
her election showed that this house
could truly be a house for all canadians
i want to take this time to recognize
and thank a community leader in aurora
fiona durant came to canada as a young
woman and established a small successful
local business
she also founded the aurora black
community association
this is a dynamic change-making group
focused on uniting all the very
community
the
deputy the longest
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
despite the difficulties of the last few
years
in the difference
[Music]
retention member for niagara falls thank
you mr speaker february is black history
month and i wanted to take this
opportunity to recognize the work being
undertaken by the niagara military
museum which is located in my riding in
partnership with the canadian war museum
the volunteers of the niagara military
museum worked to develop an incredible
black military history collection which
was publicly unveiled in niagara last
february the canadian war museum is now
showcasing these educational panels here
in ottawa so more canadians can learn
about the important contributions black
canadians made to the defense of canada
and our freedoms entitled a community at
war the military service of black
canadians of the niagara region the
exhibition highlights the experiences of
22 black men and women from the niagara
region and from southwestern ontario who
serve their country in uniform from the
american revolution to present day
their experiences offer insight into the
broader experiences of black canadians
and this country's military history and
i invite all canadians to visit the war
museum to see this marvelous exhibit
thank you mr speaker
the honorable member for coquitlam port
coquitlam
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i recently had the pleasure
of meeting with family doctors from the
fraser northwest division of family
practice society who won the 100 000
grand prize for canada's vaccine
community innovation challenge
their physician on a mission campaign
amplified the voices of family doctors
in coquitlam poor coquitlam and beyond
as trusted community members to
encourage vaccinations using physicians
personal stories and expertise
videos were produced in english
cantonese korean farsi and arabic with
family doctors addressing common
questions about covet 19 vaccines from
helping new mothers to reminding us to
get our second shot
this initiative has empowered canadians
to make informed decisions about their
health and to protect each other
congratulations to dr yoon in the fraser
northwest division of family practice
society and thank you for your
innovative and impactful work in keeping
our communities healthy
mr speaker one year ago the gurdwara
guru nanaktibar opened its doors for the
first time in the historic and beautiful
town of hudson and since doing so it has
served as a sacred place of worship for
those of the sikh faith in my community
of odoi sulange but it's also served as
so much more in keeping with the guiding
principles of kindness generosity and
community it has also served as a place
for those in need of all faiths to enjoy
a free warm and healthy meal prepared by
dedicated volunteers
it is also a rallying point for business
owners and families to come together to
help one another by donating truckloads
of foods and supplies to neighboring
churches and community groups during
this incredibly difficult time for this
and so much more i rise in this house on
behalf of my entire community to
congratulate harjeet singh bajwa deep
singh bhatt luke patrai singh dinza
garinder singh jo hal and the entire
team at the guara guru nanak dabara
hudson for their hard work and
generosity over the last year maybe
years and decades ahead continue to
bring peace joy and fulfillment
the honorable member for cypress hills
grassland
mr speaker i rise in the house and what
else but to address this government's
egregious overstep in invoking of the
emergencies act
i know that hundreds of constituents
contact me sincerely alarmed with the
implications of this prime minister's
draconian overstep
because this is the same prime minister
who stated that he admired china's
dictatorship but even chinese state
media stated that while hong kong
invoked this national security law
against violent petrol bomb throwing
mobs they're shocked to see how the
canadian prime minister has crackdown on
peaceful pro-freedom protesters
mr speaker the world is watching this
critical moment in our nation's capital
and they are rightly alarmed to see the
leader of a g7 country a country that
has long been a beacon of freedom come
down on peaceful protesters with a
sledgehammer
it is absolutely shameful and i'm
calling on the prime minister to lay
aside his pride listen to the very real
concerns of the canadian people follow
the science and drop the mandates that
is the clearest path forward to
resolving these tensions and healing our
divided and wounded nations
[Applause]
is
the government and society
we must focus on their systems
mr speaker the illegal blockades must
come to an end and law enforcement has
the resources it needs to do that
without the government invoking the
emergencies act the prime minister
himself has said that this act should
not be the first
second
or third response but he has been unable
to tell us what his first second and
third responses were
mr speaker after taking no action
the prime minister is now moving to the
most extreme action and we have seen
crisis in this country
before many times in many different
situations where the emergencies act in
its current form was not utilized mr
speaker this is an unprecedented
overreach
and it is a result of a failure in
leadership on the part of the prime
minister parliament must reverse this
decision immediately
[Music]
[Applause]
is
is
is
[Applause]
here
is
mr speaker for three weeks the city of
ottawa and border crossings across the
country have been under siege by
blockades and occupations people in
ottawa have been criminally harassed
assaulted and are afraid to leave their
homes the declaration of a public order
emergency is a result of the failure of
all levels of government failing to keep
the public safe canadians are rightly
concerned about these unprecedented
measures being enacted and about the
precedent it will set im2 it will be
critical over the course of the debate
over these next few days for the
government to clearly explain why they
believe the conditions to enact this
emergency order have been met there is
no time for talking points spin or
partisan attacks canadians deserve
honest answers accurate information and
clear reasoning conversely the
opposition has an important role to hold
the government to account to ask serious
questions and refrain from overheating
rhetoric mr speaker today marks an
important moment in our history and
there will be much work to do in these
weeks months and years to come we must
work to rebuild trust in our
institutions and that work must begin
now
the honourable member
[Applause]
magnificent
together
[Applause]
mr speaker we are debating an emergency
act because of the political crisis of
the prime minister's own making a
political crisis here in ottawa because
of his failure to act sooner
but there is another crisis building
across our country that he and his
government have failed to act on
canadians are seeing the rising cost of
living impacting them in their homes in
their backyards in my riding of north
okanagan shoe swap and across the
country groceries will cost families one
thousand dollars more this year energy
prices have reached record levels and
rent rates are skyrocketing constituents
have contacted me concerned about house
prices going up 35 to 45 percent
concerned that young families can't
afford their own homes seniors on fixed
incomes cannot keep up with the
inflation now pegged at 5.1 percent the
highest rate in 30 years
the prime minister and his government
have failed to act on the cost of living
crisis and have now created another
crisis as a diversion
this is shameful
canadians deserve better right
[Applause]
the honorable member for ottawa center
thank you speaker uh i rise in the house
to honor my late friend richard patton
who dutifully served our community of
ottawa center as the member of
provincial parliament from 1987 to 1990
and from 1995 to 2007. during this time
he also served as minister of government
services and minister of correctional
services in ontario speaker after he
retired from politics and as i succeeded
him as the mpp richard gave me a note
which read remember all of this belongs
to the people
this sentiment captures the essence of
richard's brand of public service he was
your neighbor who was also your elected
representative whether it was helping to
save aurova's aberdeen pavilion
successfully fighting to keep children
hospital of eastern ontario's heart
surgery unit in ottawa or championing
legislation to help people with severe
mental illness richard patton's legacy
in ottawa center will be felt forever
speaker as richard bravely fought cancer
he never missed a day at the legislature
or stepped for away from many of his
community building activities he died on
december 30th of last year thank you to
his wife penny for sharing richard with
our community richard ottawa center will
forever be a better place because of you
thank you
oral questions
[Applause]
is
in the circumstances
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
needs to see canada as a safe place to
invest and do business
390 million dollars a day
[Applause]
transactions
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker
our
[Music]
this decision
[Applause]
[Applause]
illegal blockades and occupations
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
and the emergency last week deputy
director of intelligence for fintrac
barry mckillip
stated that there is no evidence to back
up these claims in fact he stated quote
there has not been a spike in suspicious
transactions related to the protest end
quote
why is the prime minister offside with
canada's national security experts
honorable deputy prime minister
[Music]
mr speaker i spoke yesterday with the
head of fintrac and we are in close
touch with that very important
organization
the reality her deputy the reality mr
speaker is
that fintrac
lacked the necessary authorities to
oversee the new world of cryptocurrency
and crowd sourcing and payment platforms
with these measures mr speaker we have
enhanced the authorities of ventrac and
that is allowing us to stop the illegal
funding of these illegal blockades
remember south shuri white rock
mr speaker this morning the prime
minister contradicted two of his
ministers who had stated that the
application of the emergency measures
act would be geographically located the
pm said it would apply to all of canada
all the border crossings in bc alberta
manitoba and ontario have been cleared
the majority of premiers clearly say
this government overreach
is interfering in their jurisdictions
when will the prime minister revoke this
reckless decision and begin rebuilding
the trust of canadians
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know mr speaker once upon a time the
conservative party was a responsible
party
that believed in defending the national
economic interest i know one
conservative minister who served in such
a government
parent beede who created the emergencies
act
mr beatty said today said this week that
when he brought in the emergencies act
he knew that there would inevitably be
future crises i spoke to mr beatty today
and i told him about the work our
government is doing to defend the
canadian economy
[Applause]
is
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
business
[Music]
foreign
the situation would be less dangerous
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker
we did take responsibility
[Music]
on behalf of the canadians
and take that responsibility for
democracy
thank you mr speaker
the story of this pandemic has been a
story of solidarity of canadians taking
care of one another
but canadians are now wondering what the
plan is to get out of this pandemic
we know that the plan to get out of this
pandemic has to include
a science-based approach
and it has to include an approach to
invest in our health care system so will
the prime minister commit to making sure
health care system is never again
in the fear of collapsing and that we
have an evidence-based plan for us to
move past this pandemic
here here the honorable deputy prime
minister
mr speaker
our country is moving past this pandemic
thanks to the hard work
thanks to the common sense of canadians
thanks to the fact that 90 of canadians
are vaccinated thanks to the heroism of
our health care workers and our
essential workers for that reason mr
speaker canada has one of the best
outcomes in the western world when it
comes to mortality rates had we had the
u.s level of mortality mr speaker an
additional 66 000 canadians would have
died we are getting past the pandemic
thanks to canadians
[Music]
people are frustrated
obviously municipalities with
municipalities
and provinces
to get a strong recovery from the
recession
is
and we will do that together
his lack of leadership
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
without consulting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
emergencies
[Applause]
and the leaders
all the resources
foreign
[Music]
right
[Applause]
is
thank you very much mr speaker and the
lack of this action from this government
has resulted in the reactive to ending
the protests and blockades and invoking
the measures of the emergency message
act is the most reactive step taken to
date mr speaker canadians are looking
for hope and for a plan this government
decided to vote against having a plan
what proactive steps did the prime
minister actually take prior to putting
in these into these restrictions
the honorable government house leader
speaker and of course we've been clear
of being there every step of the way to
support law enforcement as this
situation continued but i think it's
important to reflect on the steps the
conservative party took during this
process starting with the interim leader
who said that i don't think that we
should ask these people to go home
inferring that they should take this as
a political opportunity the member for
carleton who's a leadership aspirant
saying that i stand with the illegal
activity that's occurring outside saying
that he should keep the momentum going
and of course this continues with the
member for yorkton melville saskatoon
grassland cyprus hills grassland again
and again and again they encourage that
the honorable member for elgin middlesex
london and thank you very much and
perhaps the house leader didn't
understand what i'm looking for is an
answer to the plans and what this prime
minister has actually done
step one he stigmatized he traumatized
and he divided canadians just as this
house leader is doing today step two he
hid in the cottage he did not react when
things were going on there we did not
hear from the prime minister step three
he whipped his caucus where every single
member with the exception one voted
against a plan mr speaker this
leadership has failed period failed what
actions did the prime minister actually
take prior to putting in these
restrictions
[Applause]
the honorable government house leader
every one of us walks through what is
going on outside every day we see uh the
residents of
ottawa be terrorized by this illegal
occupation that's occurring and i want
to ask the members opposite will they
stand today clearly every single one of
them and say it's time to go home will
they stand every single one of them to
stop tweeting stop encouraging stop
saying things like keep the momentum
going and instead ask for those folks
who are outside to go home to make sure
that this illegal activity is not
something that a party that's supposed
to be standing for law and order uh
stands within
[Music]
is
and vaccination centers
[Applause]
consistent with the charter thank you
very much
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
to guarantee the sovereignty security
and territorial integrity of
canada
according to the law you have to be in a
national emergency that's not the case
here
temporary measures that may not be
justifiable
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's temporary
well earlier this week i asked the
finance minister what she was doing to
control the skyrocketing cost of living
all she did was shift blame and she
avoided the question yesterday we
received the news that we were all
dreading stats canada says the consumer
price index rose 5.1 in january the
worst it's been in over 30 years mr
speaker paychecks no longer go as far as
they used to and canadians are getting
left far behind so i will ask again what
specifically is the minister doing to
get inflation under control
the honorable deputy prime minister
mr speaker
unlike the conservatives canadians
understand that inflation is a global
phenomenon
and here are some numbers to back that
up
the latest inflation number in canada
was 5.1
in the u.s it was 7.5
in the uk it is 5.5
our inflation is lower than the g7
average which is 5.5 the g20 average
which is 6.1 and this oecd average of
6.5
canadians understand mr speaker it's
time for the conservatives to understand
well for months now this liberal
minister has been claiming that
inflation was transitory nothing to see
here folks and this week stats canada
proved the minister wrong inflation is
up again at 5.1 percent the highest it's
been over 30 years prices for fish up 8
for beef up 12
bacon 19
how does this minister expect canadians
to put food on the table when is this
government going to realize that it has
lost complete control over inflation
the honorable deputy prime
mr minister i think it was actually the
chairman of the federal reserve who used
the term transitory to characterize
inflation
but let me just point out yet again that
the conservatives continue to push a
false narrative frankly about everything
that is happening in canada and very
much including the economy the fact is
the canadian recovery is strong
our gdp grew by 5.4 percent in the third
quarter that beat the us japan the uk
and australia and i also want to point
out
that s p and moody's both reaffirmed our
aaa credit rating this fall
[Applause]
[Music]
seniors
mr speaker canada is one of the biggest
funders of oil and gas in the g20 a new
study showed that last year alone the
government through export development
canada handed out 4.4 billion dollars
earning canada the worst possible
climate score that's despite repeated
liberal promises to phase out fossil
fuel subsidies we are in a climate
emergency and edc is fueling the crisis
so why
not anybody
edc clean up its act stop
[Applause]
order order i'm sorry that was uh that
was a technical error where somebody had
their microphone on i'm going to ask the
honourable member for victoria to start
from the top so that we can hear her
full question the honorable member for
victoria mr speaker canada is one of the
biggest funders of oil and gas in the
g20 a new study showed that last year
alone the government through export
development canada handed out 4.4
billion dollars earning canada the worst
possible climate score that's despite
repeated liberal promises to phase out
fossil fuel subsidies we are in a
climate emergency and edc is fueling the
crisis so why won't the government make
edc clean up its act stop giving
billions to big oil and gas and start
standing up for canadians
[Music]
thank you mr speaker and i thank my
honorable colleague for her question
in fact g20 countries i've committed to
eliminate fossil fuel subsidies by 2025.
we in canada have committed to doing
that by 2023 two years earlier than our
g20 colleagues mr speaker and on top of
that edc has reduced its fossil fuel
subsidies by more than three billion
dollars per year since 2018. thank you
mr speaker the honourable member for
timmins james bay
earlier this week i made an accusation
against the environment minister that
his government had held 370 backroom
meetings with big oil in just two years
mr speaker i withdraw those comments
because it turns out they've actually
rolled out the red carpet for 1
24 meetings with big oil that my friends
is the definition of carbon captured so
it's no wonder that under this prime
minister canada has fallen to the bottom
of the g7 in terms of climate action so
to the environment minister when's he
going to stop acting as the head butler
for the oil lobby and start standing up
for canadians
the honorable
minister of the environment thank you mr
speaker and i thank my honourable
colleague for his question
one of the highest carbon price in the
world here in canada
regulations on methane pollution 40
reduction by 2025 a cap on oil and gas
emissions these are all things our
government has done to fight climate
change and ensuring we create good jobs
and a prosperous future for all
canadians thank you mr speaker
honourable member for northwest
territories
[Music]
mr speaker this tuesday 54 potential
unmarked graves were found at casey
koozie first nation three weeks ago
williams lake first nation announced
that the survey had identified 93
potential unmarked graves on the site of
the former saint joseph mission
residential school nearly a year ago
canada was rocked by the discovery of
200 probable unmarked waves on the
grounds of the former cameron which is
indian residential school
despite all this evidence some still
deny the actual legacy of residential
schools and claim the number of unmarked
graves is exaggerated mr speaker i find
this very troubling and unacceptable
could the minister of crown indigenous
relations comment on what our government
is doing to support the survivors of
these residential schools
and i just want to say that there is
accommodation that takes place in the
chamber sometimes technically it doesn't
always work i believe we had everything
tested that worked out fairly well i
believe the translation took place
[Music]
a little bit of compassion so that we
can all work together in the house
the honorable minister
last summer in light of the devastating
findings in kamloops and calluses our
government announced an additional 329
million dollars to support indigenous
communities in their search for loved
ones rob at such a young age in their
efforts to memorialize their loss and
their quest for closure
residential schools were a reality in
this country for well over 150 years and
the effects are still felt painfully
today to the survivors who are speaking
out including my friend and member who
spoke as well as those who continue
to
suffer in silence
we believe you canada believes you
the honorable
[Applause]
mr speaker the prime minister is out of
step with canadians canadians want and
deserve open dialogue after two years of
uncertainty
this should be about science not
political science yet this prime
minister would rather divide and
stigmatize instead of giving people the
certainty and hope they need when will
the prime minister stop doubling down on
divisive rhetoric and commit publicly to
a specific plan and timeline to end
federal mandates and restrictions
the honorable parliamentary secretary
thank you mr speaker since day one of
this pandemic our government's focus has
been the health and safety of our of our
neighbors by following the latest
science the most recent data indicates
that the omicron wave is past its peak
in canada which allows us to move
towards a more long-term approach to
managing covid19 we intend to follow the
science and we're working closely with
experts like dr tam and other public
health officials to ensure that we
continue to get through this pandemic
together
as best we possibly can and that has
been through vaccinations thank you mr
speaker the honourable member for a
renfrew nipissing pembroke mr speaker
the prime minister's petulance led to
the firing of ottawa's first black
police chief during black history month
it's yet another example of the
divisiveness fostered by this government
the prime minister's own finance
minister stood on the maidan during
ukraine's revolution
canadians want foreign interference from
the prime minister's jet-setting
resetters to stop
when will the prime minister
listen to the majority of freedom-loving
canadians and end the mandates
the honorable government house leader
mr speaker i've had and i'm sure all
members have had the opportunity to talk
to people who come from countries that
aren't free that know what it means to
have their freedoms restricted in ways
that are not able to live or to share
their thoughts or to protest in peaceful
ways but i'm sure and i would hope that
the member opposite would agree that
what we're seeing outside the
terrorizing of residents the harassing
of homeless shelters the inability for
ottawa citizens to continue their life
has gone way too
far
please stop supporting these illegal
activities and join with us so that our
lives can begin to return to normal
the honorable member
mr speaker the science has changed
canada's top officials including dr tam
have recommended review of covet
policies we're seeing countries around
the world with lower vaccination rates
and canada dropping their restrictions
we're seeing provinces our own country
dropping its restrictions is the
government going to stick toward and
follow the science when will
the mandates for canadian travelers who
are fully vaccinated
and when will the mandates be totally
dropped
for the testing for canadian travelers
to return
the honourable parliamentary secretary
[Applause]
speaker this transition including this
week's announcement is possible because
of a number number of factors which
includes our high vaccination rates and
the increasing availability of rapid
tests and treatments as we've said all
along canada's border measures will
remain flexible and adaptable guided by
science and prudence i have a quote from
my uh my colleague opposite and that is
it starts here everyone entering canada
by land as well as by air irrespective
of their vaccination status will be
required to take a rapid test or
possibly a pcr test where's that from
that's from page 19 of the conservatives
election platform remember this magazine
that one thanks mr speaker
the honourable member for new brunswick
southwest
well mr speaker
life moves on and the government needs
to move on with it in december the
liberals again impose rigid coven 19
testings on canadians living in border
communities who travel to the united
states and return home often within a
day or within a few hours
the liberals announced
they would replace 72-hour pcr testing
with a 24-hour rapid test
this doesn't help our border communities
24-hour testing will continue to
separate families and people in canada's
border towns
when will the liberals allow canadians
to drive to the united states and come
home in a single day without testing
thank you mr speaker the honorable
parliamentary secretary to the minister
of health thank you mr speaker i'd
remind the member again that you
campaigned on testing as well just like
we did well we're in a better position
today than we were previously this
pandemic's not over yet we all want this
pandemic to be over but it's not over
yet the government of canada will
continue to assess the evolving
situation here at home and globally and
while the members opposite continue to
shout me down it doesn't change the the
reality that this pandemic is not yet
over thank you membership
[Applause]
uh
um
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
is
mr speaker 23 liberal mps requests to
help afghan refugees were ignored
liberal ministers were briefed months
before gobble fell these warnings were
ignored my letters to the prime minister
and the ministers continue to be ignored
afghan refugees write to this government
every day pleading for help they
continue to be ignored the afghan crisis
is another pattern of inaction and
failures in leadership by this liberal
government why was an action why was an
election plan and abandoning those that
served canada more important than the
pleas of afghan refugees
the honorable minister of immigration
mr speaker when that member first asked
me a question about the success of our
resettlements and uh efforts in
afghanistan there was three thousand
eight hundred afghan refugees in canada
today there are more than seven thousand
seven hundred in the past few weeks mr
speaker we have seen more than 460
arrive on 20 commercial flights there
are more flights arriving every week we
have made one of the most substantial
commitments of any country in the world
not just on a per capita basis but in
terms of the raw number of human beings
that we are going to welcome to give a
second lease on life canadians should be
proud of the effort that we're making
and we will not waver until we are
successful in resettling all 40 000
afghan refugees who will call canada
home
[Applause]
event
[Applause]
during the evacuation there was an
emergency situation we responded as
quickly as it's humanly possible one of
the reasons mr speaker that i think the
honourable member will appreciate is
that we no longer had a military
presence with the logistics capability
of moving thousands and thousands of
people on our own because we hadn't had
a military prisons there since 2014. mr
speaker we worked with international
partners to rescue thousands of people
in the moments of the evacuation i want
to say thank you to my predecessor now
the minister of public safety for his
efforts to resell thousands of afghan
refugees and i'm going to finish the job
[Applause]
mr speaker here's some of the damning
testimony this week from retired
generals about the liberal government's
failure during the fall of kabul and the
government's continued lack of
leadership quote we were the first
embassy to depart that was very
embarrassing
quote when this crisis was unfolding
right in front of our eyes we had then
as we do now urge the government to
create an interdepartmental task force
with one leader mr speaker i'll ask the
same question i asked last week will the
prime minister assign one lead minister
to solve this ongoing humanitarian aid
crisis
[Applause]
[Music]
minister of immigration i am the
minister who's been appointed by the
prime minister to lead this effort we
will collaborate with other ministers
including the minister of global affairs
to help ensure that we are successful in
partnering with the global community to
see this mission succeed i heard the
members opposite tackling about the
timing of the election when it came to
the afghan refugee resettlement effort
and i would point out how important that
election was because we campaigned on a
commitment to increase our level of
ambition from twenty thousand to forty
thousand their commitment on the other
side while they heckle me was to welcome
precisely zero afghan refugees more than
that mr speaker they campaigned to end
the government assisted refugees program
altogether which has been responsible
for saving thousands of lives
[Music]
a
[Applause]
mr speaker the liberals made in canada
housing crisis has gotten out of control
it's the same situation across the
country including my community at york
simcoe working canadians have been
priced out of the housing market with no
hope in sight now home builders are
stopping the construction of new homes
liberal inflation has caused prices for
material to skyrocket
there are too many ways for builders
there's no way for builders to know the
fair market value of the home that won't
be ready for at least two years why is
this liberal government making it even
harder for canadians to own a home great
question
[Applause]
conservatives are not really serious
about housing affordability because
every single time we've brought a
measure here to enable canadians to be
able to afford a home they voted against
it the first time home buyer is centered
all the measures that we've brought they
even voted against imposing a vacancy
tax on foreign owned non-resident
properties so they're not serious
they're full of rhetoric and canadians
see through them we will take additional
measures to improve the first time home
buy incentive and and turn more canadian
renters into home owners let's see if
they voted against that
the honorable member for yellow head mr
speaker 400 billion newly created cash
has driven up consumer prices and
constituents in my riding especially
seniors can't afford their basic
necessities in addition to rising
consumer prices electricity and heating
bills are increasing due to the carbon
tax which is to increase again on april
1st
mr speaker when will this liberal
government finally quit making false
promises and create a real economic plan
for all canadians especially those who
struggling to meet their basic needs
[Applause]
mr speaker
the conservative mp began his question
talking about government spending which
he seems to deem excessive so i'd like
to remind him that he
together with every single conservative
there
actually ran on an election platform
proposing
higher spending in 21 22 than the
liberals did they proposed 168 billion
deficit we proposed
156 billion deficit so could the party
of flip-flops tell canadians what they
stand for today
the honourable member for brantford
brandt mr speaker with more than 1.3
million unemployed canadians 200 000
jobs were lost in january alone at the
same time our businesses are struggling
to fill almost one million jobs
canada's economic recovery is in
jeopardy canada has the fifth worst job
recovery in the g7
hardworking people at brantford-brant
are asking when will the prime minister
stop putting his ideological agenda
above prudent economic decisions
you know mr speaker it is a bit rich to
hear the conservatives talk about their
support for canadian workers and
canadian jobs and let me just point out
one moment of abject conservative
failure and that was before christmas
when we knew we knew omicron was coming
we knew canadian workers and businesses
needed support but you know what the
conservatives voted against that measure
and when it comes to jobs canada has
recovered 101 of the jobs lost to covet
u.s just 87 mr speaker
for london west mr speaker some working
low-income seniors in this country have
had a challenging time making ends meet
during this pandemic which is why they
turn to what most canadians did the crb
and other pandemic benefits while we're
going to be supporting people who
suffered drops in their gis and
allowance through compensation payments
the minister of seniors mandate letter
also called us to look to look forward
it called us to assure seniors that we'd
have their backs even more can the
minister tell this house how she's done
that
honorable minister for seniors
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i'd like
to thank the member for london west for
her question and for her advocacy for
seniors in her riding she's right we
committed to ensuring seniors
eligibility for the gis and alliance
will not be impacted by receiving
pandemic benefits and this house
yesterday mr speaker unanimously passed
bill c12 and i want to take an
opportunity to thank every member in
this house and making that happen i'll
look forward to seeing it make its way
through the other place mr speaker it's
clear for seniors with the greatest
needs that we will always have their
backs
the honorable member for edmonton
strathcona
mr speaker 1.5 million ukrainians have
been displaced from their homes since
russia invaded in 2014. now as russia
amasses troops and armaments and
threatens further invasion the ukrainian
people need canada more than ever there
is a looming humanitarian disaster in
ukraine and thousands of ukrainians are
seeking refuge in canada we saw this
government fail to protect afghans we
can't let this happen again will the
minister uphold canada's responsibility
to ukrainians will the minister ensure
humanitarian aid and better support for
those ukrainians who are fleeing
violence
minister or the armed parliamentary
secretary thank you mr speaker
there is no situation that is we are
more seized with right now than ukraine
and our solidarity for the ukrainian
government and the people of ukraine we
have also been very clear
that we are standing with canadian
citizens who are in ukraine and any
possible humanitarian crisis that could
extend following a possible incursion
right now however our mission is to
de-escalate russia's uh
total disrespect for the territorial
integrity of ukraine we will stand with
the people of ukraine whether it's
militarily whether it is through
humanitarian assistance and by helping
uh every ukrainian who is in trouble
the honorable member for spadina for
york thank you mr speaker i recently met
with representatives from the
undergraduates of canadian research
intensive universities they represent
over a quarter million students from u15
universities that annually conduct eight
and a half billion dollars of research
and contribute more than 36 billion
dollars to our economy like most
students i meet with in spadina fort
york there's a shared concern crippling
student debt the average lifetime
interest on a canadian student loan is
three thousand dollars due to the
pandemic the government waived the
interest for two years mr speaker more
must be done can the parliamentary
secretary to the minister of employment
workforce development and disability
inclusion inform this house when will
the government permanently eliminate
interest on canada student loans
the honorable
parliamentary secretary
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
honorable colleague for his question
young canadians and students must be at
the center of our recovery and we're
proud that our response during the
pandemic was one of the largest youth
support packages in the world during the
pandemic our government waived the
interest on canada student loans and
canada apprentice loans for two years
because we knew young people were
amongst the hardest hit by job losses
that's why we are committed to
permanently eliminating the federal
interest on csl and canada apprentice
loans supporting over 1 million students
we're also committed to increasing the
repayment assistance threshold to 50 000
for canada student loan borrowers we
will continue to be there mr speaker to
help canadians transition into the
workforce thank you
i'm afraid that's all the ques the all
the only time we have for today and
i just want to say thank you to everyone
i know this week has been very very
difficult very emotional very heated and
i just want to say thank you for today
because it was very nice
to see everyone
respecting
[Music]
[Music]
uh
is
to ensure they have the correct
equipment
[Applause]
we do not have unanimous consent
and now we have uh the
thing that we have we all look forward
to every thursday the thursday question
the honorable opposition house leader
well thank you uh mr speaker and um
i will uh i will say uh i i know that my
honorable colleague from the ndp rose on
the point of order we're certainly uh
sympathetic to the member from yukon uh
the easiest way that we can resolve the
situation with interpreters mr speaker
is to get back to normal parliament so
that we're all here
so mr speaker
the debate we're having in this place
whether we agree
or not with the invocation of the
emergencies act is probably and arguably
one of the most important debates that
we are going to have in a generation at
least my generation
and
as the eyes of the nation are upon us mr
speaker i ask the government house
leader what the business of the house
will be thank you the honorable
government house leader
thank you very much mr speaker i just
will start by saying that uh tuesday
march 1st will be an allotted day and to
my honorable colleague uh the house
leader for the conservatives i'll say
through you mr speaker uh that i
completely agree with him this is an
exceptionally important debate that all
house leaders from all parties have had
an incredibly productive discussion i
want to thank them for their
collaboration for working together to
get onto the same page because again
while we may disagree in the final vote
it's essential i think that we agree in
the process that we utilize and it's
essential that parliament have a fulsome
debate it's uh why mr speaker i'm
pleased that we have reached an
agreement uh for this debate to occur
over the next five days mr speaker
with that debate continuing today until
midnight and i'll move a motion uh move
in order to put this into action in a
moment uh with unanimous consent but it
would see us again going tonight to
midnight
friday from 7 a.m to midnight saturday
sunday 7 a.m to midnight and we would uh
see us on monday 7 00 a.m to 7 30 p.m
with a vote at 8 00 pm and mr speaker if
i could i would now seek unanimous
consent to adopt the following motion mr
speaker that notwithstanding any
standing order special order or usual
practice of the house that a on thursday
february 17 2022
orders of the day shall be extended
beyond the ordinary hour of daily
adjournment for the purpose of
considering the motion for confirmation
of the declaration of emergency standing
on the order paper in the name of the
minister of public safety and when no
member rises to speak uh or at 11 59 pm
which is ever earlier the house shall
stand adjourned until the next day be mr
speaker that on friday february 18th
2022 the house shall proceed with the
ordinary daily program provided that it
meet at 7 a.m and sit beyond the
ordinary hour of daily adjournment for
the purpose of considering the
aforementioned motion and when no member
rises to speak or at 11 59 pm whichever
is earlier it shall stand adjourned
until the next day further mr speaker
see on sunday february 19th uh 2022 and
sunday excuse me saturday february 19th
2022 and sunday february 20th 2022 the
house shall convene at 7 00 a.m for the
sole purpose of considering the
aforementioned motion and when no member
rises to speak or at 11 59 pm whichever
is earlier it shall stand adjourned
until the following day
d mr speaker that on monday february
21st 2022
one the house shall proceed with the
ordinary daily program provided that it
meet at 7 00 am and it and that it sit
beyond the ordinary hour of daily
adjournment for the purposes of
considering the aforementioned motion
two
if no member rises to speak on the
motion at any time before statements by
members all questions necessary to
dispose of the motion be put and if a
recorded division is requested it be
deferred to 7 30 pm that day
and that the setting be suspended until
the time provided for statements by
members and be suspended again after
routine proceedings until 7 30 pm number
three mr speaker that if no member rises
to speak on the motion at any time after
routine proceedings all questions
necessary to dispose of the motion be
put and if a recorded division is
requested it'd be deferred until 7 30 pm
that day and that the sitting be
suspended until 7 30 pm
number four mr speaker at 7 30 pm if not
previously previously disposed of all
questions necessary to dispose of the
motion be put and if a recorded division
is requested it shall not be deferred
moving on to e mr speaker that if
during the sittings of february 18 19
and 20 the speaker receives notice from
the house leaders or whips or of all
recognized parties that they are
satisfied no further member wishes to
speak on the motion all necessary
all questions necessary to dispose of
the motion uh be put and if a recorded
division is requested it'd be deferred
to monday february 21st 2022 at 7 30 pm
and that the house stand adjourned until
this time
after mr speaker during the sittings of
february 17 18 19 20 and 21
that one the speaker shall not receive
any dilitary motions and she'll only
accept a request for unanimous consent
after receiving a notice from the house
leaders of or wips of all recognized
parties stating that they are in
agreement with such a request two that
the house may be adjourned before the
aforementioned time pursuant to a motion
to adjourn proposed by a minister of the
crown three the application of standing
orders 26 38 and 52 be suspended the
sittings of february 19 20 and 21
not be counted for the purposes of
standing orders 34 1 36 8 b
39 5 b
51 1
81 10
c
91 and 91.2
private members business shall not be
taken up and provided that any response
to petitions and questions on order
paper otherwise due on those days shall
be tabled at the sitting of the house on
february twenty eight twenty twenty two
four that no motion be allowed to be
moved during routine proceedings except
by unanimous consent
further mr speaker g notices laid on the
table or filed with the clerk for
publication between the hours of 6 30 pm
on thursday february 17 2022 and 6 p.m
on thursday february 24th 2022 only be
printed for the notice
a paper of monday february 28 2022 and
finally mr speaker that when proceedings
are completed on the motion for
confirmation of the declaration of
emergency the house stand adjourned
until monday february 28 uh 2022 at 11
a.m pursuant to standing order 28 2 and
24 1. thank you mr speaker before i ask
for unanimous consent i understand the
uh government the opposition the house
leader has a question or point of
clarification point of clarification mr
speaker thank you for the opportunity to
do this the honorable member mentioned
in
my second page
which is uh
paragraph three
he uh where it says 395b 511 81 10c 92
and 92.1 the honourable member said 91-2
i believe he meant to say i know there
was a lot of words there i believe he
meant to say 92 1.
correct
that is correct mr speaker i i apologize
for the error
all those all those opposed to the
honorable member moving the uh
sorry the honourable minister moving the
emotion will please say nay
orders of the day
resuming consideration of a motion for
the confirmation of the declaration of
emergency
resuming debate the honorable
parliamentary secretary
thank you very much mr speaker i'll be
sharing my time with the member from
surrey center now arise today mr speaker
with some humility
i rise to speak not on behalf of a
particular political party because i
firmly believe this issue cannot be
partisan today i rise not as a
representative of a particular community
because i don't think this is a regional
issue that we're discussing today i rise
today mr speaker in all sincerity as a
member of parliament as a member of this
chamber the house of commons committed
to serving the public to serving all
canadians in an effort a genuine effort
to do what is best for our country
at this stage
i firmly believe that the only way to
resolve the present threat that is
facing this country
is to declare a public order emergency
under the emergencies act
mr speaker i want to start by talking
about the charter
let me state at the outset that the
right to freedom of expression is
sacrosanct in this country it's
entrenched in section 2b of the charter
for a reason
because it is the hallmark of our
democracy indeed of any democracy
is the ability for citizens to voice
their discontent to challenge authority
and to seek change
i don't deny any of this to the contrary
i vigorously defended mr speaker i also
don't deny that the people gathered
outside this very chamber right now who
have been on the streets of ottawa for
it is now 21 days have legitimate
grievances criticisms of my government
of my party perhaps even of me
personally which they have every right
to air
but mr speaker in our democracy freedom
of expression while sacrosanct is not
absolute
this charter protection under section 2b
extends towards lawful peaceful protest
the charter does not protect illegal
violent blockades and it is the latter
unfortunately what this protest has
devolved into
mr speaker i want to reference ottawa
how do i substantiate this assertion
i've just made i substantiate it with
the evidence i've gathered with my own
eyes and from the accounts of other
parliamentarians that have been shared
with me
far from seeing people exercising their
constitutional rights to disagree
vigorously with the government we have
seen instead intimidation
threats and harassment
we've seen deliberate nuisances being
created by truck horn blowing at all
hours of the day and night rendering the
city effectively uninhabitable for local
residents we've seen open displays of
hatred such as swastikas and confederate
flags and acts of direct hatred where
windows are smashed on coffee shops that
dare to fly the pride flag we see the
desecration of national monuments
including our national war memorial
we've seen deliberate efforts to block
the movement of people and goods by
people intentionally disabling large
vehicles and trucks by things like
activating their air brakes or actually
removing the tires from their vehicle
we've seen death threats then follow
towards an ottawa tow trucking company
accused of being complicit with police
efforts to remove such disabled vehicles
we've seen the shuttering of businesses
in the entire downtown core impeding
residents ability to work which
parenthetically i would say is puzzling
mr speaker
to say the least from protesters who
claim to issue lockdowns having
themselves caused ottawa's downtown to
enter into a lockdown for a period of
now three weeks we've seen intimidation
and threats of the media again ironic
for those who would be more ardent
defenders of freedom of expression than
even me in terms of what i've already
articulated we've seen the active
sabotage of 911 emergency call lines and
even an attempted arson mr speaker the
protest was ostensibly started out about
vaccine mandates has morphed into what
resembles an occupation of the city by
people who have openly declared mr
speaker on the public record that they
are seeking to overthrow the government
that constitutes a complete breakdown of
public order in ottawa and despite
efforts from the ottawa police services
mr speaker law and order in the nation's
capital has been impossible to maintain
but the evidence that i'm outlining here
mr speaker extends beyond the nation's
capital you've heard reference to the
borders and i want to address this now
what commenced as a protest targeting
this city and this parliament has
emerged as a concerted effort to block
our national border crossings and
implied the flow of people and goods
foreign entities openly and publicly in
texas and florida and other parts of the
united states and indeed other nations
have openly declared their sympathy with
the blockades and admitted to sending
money and resources to help the
blockades continue today the
anti-defamation league showed a result
of their analysis of the gibson go
website and found 1100 people in the
united states who supported the january
sixth insurrection of last year right
actually donated money under gifts and
go to these blockade blockades mr
speaker just let that settle in for a
moment in terms of what the motivations
are for those such types of people the
blockades that have emerged around the
country are deliberately targeting
critical infrastructure we know about
what's happened at the ambassador bridge
in windsor detroit that multi-day siege
mr speaker now i'm wearing my hat as a
parliamentary secretary for
international trade on canada's busiest
border crossing alone resulted in the
suspension of nearly 400 million dollars
in daily trade between canada and the
united states the cancellation of shifts
and multiple auto plants in southern
ontario and an intervention by president
biden and the governor of michigan
showing that confidence in canada as a
safe place to invest do business and
trade with is starting to erode
blockades have occurred in surrey in
emerson at cootes alberta and what
should be startlingly alarming for every
person in this chamber and for every
canadian watching right now is that when
the rcmp went to clear the coots border
crossing they made 13 arrests including
laying charges for conspiracy to commit
murder wow now i'm just i'm going to say
that again mr speaker conspiracy to
commit murder and they found firearms
ammunition and body armor mr speaker
that bore out certainly my worst fears
but i think all of our worst fears mr
speaker that blockade protesters were
armed and preparing for violent
confrontation with law enforcement
mr speaker the violence is continuing to
ratchet up we've had bomb threats at a
vancouver hospital suspicious
packages and language about hanging
members of parliament being sent to
colleagues of mine from nova scotia why
am i laying this all out mr speaker in
such excruciating detail i'm laying it
out because there's a legal test that
must be met when you're doing something
that has not been done
ever under this under this legislation
or even in this country under antecedent
legislation in 52 years the test is high
as it should be when you're considering
a statute which permits temporarily for
the suspension of civil liberties what
is that test mr speaker the test is
entrenched in section 3 of the
emergencies act it says a national
emergency is an urgent and critical
situation of a temporary nature that
seriously endangers the lives health or
safety of canadians and is of such
proportions or nature as to exceed the
capacity or authority of a province to
deal with it or one that seriously
threatens the ability of the government
of canada to preserve the sovereignty
security and territorial integrity of
canada mr speaker it is my fundamental
belief that this high legal threshold
has been met in this case when you have
a blockade laying siege to an entire
city for 21 days and count and counting
intimidating harassing and threatening
locals rendering the city uninhabitable
you're endangering the safety of
canadians when those blockades limit the
ability of medical first responders to
respond quickly to emergencies you're
endangering the lives of those on the
other end of those 9-1-1 calls when
factions with armed with weapons and
ammunition are blockading borders you
are directly endangering the lives of
canadians when groups are deliberately
blocking trade corridors with our single
largest training partner grinding our
border traffic to a halt you're
threatening the ability of the federal
government to preserve our sovereignty
and our economic security mr speaker
these are important
in the last few minutes what i want to
do is address some of the general
objections we've been hearing not just
today but prior to this to those who say
there's an overreach here i say five
things five checks that are important
one everything done by a government
under the emergencies act must be done
in accordance with the charter that's
entrenched in the preamble all
declarations are time limited 30 days no
more in fact it may be less and
hopefully will be less in this context
third the very act of declaring an
emergency under the declaration must be
reviewed by a committee of all members
of parliament and senators from all
parties
fourth the exercise of powers under the
declaration must be reviewed by that
committee and fifth following the end of
an emergency a full inquiry must be held
what we are doing mr speaker is not a
power grab it is not the invocation of
the war measures act we are simply
giving the rcmp the power to enforce
local laws and work quickly with local
law enforcement we are not calling in
the armed forces we are not putting the
rcmp or any other police force under the
control of the government policing
operational decisions remain independent
as they must in any democracy mr speaker
i'm going to end with the right to to
protest because people have said what
about my children's right to protest and
i take this very seriously because i
myself have taken children of mine to
protest
this law talks about the right of lawful
protests it is entrenched in black and
white the measures that we are
contemplating are measures that would
address or prohibit public assembly that
is a threat
to a threat to leading to a breach of
the peace we are specifically carving
out the right of lawful advocacy protest
and dissent mr speaker for those that
say that the threats have been addressed
what i say to you is that windsor had an
attempted blockade yesterday and that we
know that protesters are returning to
the quebec national assembly on the 19th
i'm going to conclude with a sincere
undertaking to the members of this
chamber and to all canadians that i will
do everything in my power to ensure that
this act lasts for only as long as is
absolutely necessary i will do
everything in my power to ensure that
there is no over breath and then to
ensure that charter rights are always
fundamentally protected all members of
parliament should strive for nothing
less thank you very much mr speaker
questions and comments questions
so i remain unconvinced by the member's
argument and i recognize the fact that
he is a lawyer by profession before he
came to this place and i was not a
lawyer thankfully in my previous life
but the member during uh his uh his
speech said
that there must be a very high threshold
to suspend civil liberties i would say
let's not use american language it's
called charter liberties charter
freedoms it's canadianized it uh but
there should be an explicitly high
threshold before we suspend charter
liberties um but as the opposite of what
the prime minister said the prime
minister said that is actually not going
on and that's happened repeatedly
repeatedly now in the last 72 hours is
that cabinet ministers say one thing and
then they are contradicted by the prime
minister and people in my riding people
back in calgary just have very little
faith in the government's handling of
the situation and so i asked the member
can he clarify what he just said we are
not suspending charter liberties we are
not going after people uh without some
type of recourse to the law uh and is he
going to ensure the prime minister stays
on message and stops jacking up and
ratcheting up the rhetoric as they're
trying to clear protesters outside this
building
the honorable parliamentary secretary i
thank the member from calgary shepherd
for his comments and what i want to make
clear is that as he's read the material
and i hope everyone who's participated
in this debate has read the material
there talks it talks about certain
regulations certain powers and certain
prohibitions one of the prohibitions is
on assemblies that would lead to a
breach of the peace but what is
important what the prime minister said
what every cabinet minister said is that
everything that is undertaken under this
emergency declaration must be done in
compliance with the charter of rights
and freedoms and the charter rights and
freedoms talks about
charter liberties it also talks about
limitations on such liberties that are
saved under section one and that is the
important facet that all canadians must
recognize and that is the important
facet under which we will operate as a
government and that all parliamentarians
must operate under because that charter
and that those fundamental rights are
sacrosanct in our democracy
still only come out to our questions and
comments deputies uh
are
is it possible the situation would be
different
secretary elementary secretary
an emergency declared by the city of
ottawa
and the ontario government also declared
an emergency neither order of government
was able to address the situation here
elsewhere
questions and comments uh the honorable
member for new westminster burnaby uh
thank you very much mr speaker i thank
the member for parkdale high park for
his speech i think he was effective in
talking about the impacts on people's
lives of of what has happened over the
last few weeks
uh many many people thousands of
canadians losing their jobs at least
temporarily we've seen businesses closed
in ottawa they have been going through
hell there's no other way to put it mr
speaker as you know
the uh the impacts of the toxic fumes
the impacts of the loud extraordinarily
industrial levels of noise that have
caused permanent hearing loss and
the assaults and disrespect that so many
of the residents of ottawa have
experienced firsthand
so there's there's no doubt that there
is a
compelling reason
the reality is though mr speaker that we
could have well avoided all of this if
the government had acted more promptly
and i'd like to direct the member from
parkdale high park specifically to the
issues around the proceeds of crime and
terrorist financing regulations that
were put into place with huge loopholes
that the ndp for years have called upon
the government to fix
canada is known as the snow washing
capital of the world because of money
laundering and because of all the
problems why didn't the government move
years ago to fix those loopholes so this
financing of what transpired in ottawa
uh couldn't have occurred in the first
place
aaron rule parliamentary secretary to
the minister of international trade and
i thank the member from new zealand mr
burnaby for that contribution and that
question and i think
again what i'm trying to do is address
the situation that has really seized the
city and sees this nation and as opposed
to turning back the clock and engaging
in what ifs or hypotheticals about what
might have been done previously what
we've done quite directly in the in the
deputy prime minister mr finance
addressed this in question period is
address lacuna in financial tracking
legislation right now and that is one of
the economic measures that's contained
in this declaration that allows us to
address who is funding including foreign
sources that are funding this particular
illegal blockade
and making sure that it brings it to an
end let me see continuing representative
of the honourable member for surrey
center
thank you mr speaker
i'd like to say that i'm disheartened to
have to give these remarks today i'm
saddened by the events that continue
outside the doors of this building for
the last three weeks and the blockades
that close borders across the country
let's be clear this is no longer a
protest it's an occupation that
advocated to overthrow a democratically
elected government on monday the prime
minister deputy prime minister ministers
of justice minister of emergency
preparedness and minister of public
safety announced that our government was
invoking the emergency act
a decision that i support
this is a situation that i do not think
any of us wanted to get to however the
defiance of those who continue to occupy
the streets of ottawa and attempt to
block our border crossings need to end
and these individuals need to go home
there is a shocking amount of
misinformation and plain lies being
spread about the occupation
public health measures and the
emergencies act some of them supported
and echoed by members in this chamber
to begin i think we should start by
clarifying a few important points
let's be clear on what the emergency act
is for those on the other side of the
aisle provoking fear and spreading
misinformation and encouraging
conspiracy theories to legitimately
concerned canadians who want to
understand what is going on in their
country this is dangerous and harmful
i encourage any of you who have been
supportive of this movement to think
long and hard about the long-term
consequences of your actions and words
in support of the occupation
these are temporary proportionate and
targeted measures let me repeat that
temporary proportionate and targeted
the act was invoked to supplement
provincial and territorial authorities
to address the blockades in occupation
to ensure the safety of canadians
protect people's jobs and restore
confidence in our institutions
our government enacted this act after
local and provincial efforts were
unsuccessful in resolving the situation
the emergency act provided provides law
enforcement new authorities to prohibit
blockades ensure our essential quarters
remain open and regulate crowds
it allows the government to mobilize
essential services such as tow trucks
and it gives the rcmp the ability to act
quickly to enforce
local laws
this act will provide more power to stop
the flow of money the scope of canada's
anti-money laundering and terrorist
financing rules are being broadened they
will cover crowdfunding platforms and
their payment service providers as well
as those using digital assets such as
cryptocurrencies
in situations where there is suspicion
of an account being involved to further
the occupation or illegal blockades
canadian financial institutions now have
immediate authority to temporarily seize
providing financial services corporate
accounts can and will be frozen for
those participating in the blockades
they are also at risk of having their
vehicle insurance revoked i've seen a
significant amount of misinformation
about the
powers granted under the act let's
clarify a few things the emergency act
does not do
the emergency act is limited in scope
compared to the war measures act of the
past
the act does not involve the military
for the military to be involved the
national defense act would need to be
invoked this has not happened
i think we also need to make very clear
that no
individual charter rights are being
violated in fact the emergency act must
be compliant with the canadian charter
of rights and freedoms
the specific measures provided in this
act are limited parliament provides many
checks safeguards and transparency this
is the reason we are here today debating
we're going through this process of
checks and balances
i'd like to pivot now to the impact of
the occupation and blockades on the
lives of everyday canadians
for those taking part in this illegal
occupation in ottawa many seem to be
enjoying themselves pancake breakfasts
hot tubs dance parties in the streets
and bouncy castles
contrary to the narrative being driven
by supporters though this has not been a
peaceful experience for residents
businesses and employees in ottawa
honking continued most of the day
yesterday and early this morning despite
a 60-day extension of an injunction
requiring bylaw that it stopped
on top of that constant honking there
being drums beating loud fireworks music
at all hours of the night
the health consequences of this constant
bombardment of noise isn't exclusive to
residents occupiers are doing
considerable damage to their own health
and the health of their children who
they have brought with them whether it
is from the loud air horns or
constant cloud of diesel fuel lingering
on the streets from idling trucks
it has been a very frustrating time for
residents of ottawa especially those who
live and work in the affected areas
residents complain of being harassed for
wearing a mask being accosted
with racial and anti-semitic slurs
employees and businesses do not feel
it's safe to keep their businesses open
real people's lives are being impacted
by a loud minority and very real and
significant ways
the lack of empathy towards the
residents and businesses in ottawa shaw
is shocking and unacceptable
thousands of people have been out of
work in ottawa the rito center alone
employs 1500 individuals and has been
closed for weeks
a woman who lives in my building here in
ottawa works from home due to the
pandemic she told me that she had to
leave the city to go to her parents home
in toronto in order to work and get some
rest because she does not feel safe not
only has the constant noise disrupted
her sleep but also prevented her from
working during the day
vaccine clinics libraries and other
important community resources have been
shut down in the downtown core for weeks
due to safety concerns
these resources are relied upon by many
residents and many vulnerable residents
in downtown ottawa
the people of ottawa are no strangers to
protests however they know the right to
protest comes with limits those limits
stop when you're causing harm to people
around you
i've heard from staffers and employees
on the hill that they've been taunted
and yelled at for simply wearing a mask
many of the occupiers show disregard for
public measures by going into
restaurants at places of business
without masks thereby putting those that
work there at risk
this week at the airport on my way home
to bc i met a woman whose husband is a
truck driver he was not able to work for
days because he could not cross the
border due to blockades
she urged me to get the borders open so
her husband can continue to work and
provide food
for their families
the week before i received dozens of
calls from trucking companies and
families of drivers stuck on the other
side of the border goots
and couldn't get back
they're people who are making sure that
there is food on our table and supply
chains remain open
while the borders are back open again
now the blockades have taken a serious
economic toll on our communities
these individuals blocking critical
infrastructure and their supporters
claim to want to ensure that groceries
stay full that our trade routes stay
running smoothly however their actions
had
led to serious disruptions in our supply
chains
including putting people out of work in
the auto industry because of plant
closures they have caused the exact
thing that they claim to want to protect
our country against
this blockade has damaged trade
relations with our most important
trading partner the united states of
america
73 percent of our exports go to the
united states and billions of dollars of
imports come from our neighbors to the
south annually
truckers were stuck on the other side of
the coots border crossing for days and
were forced to drive for hours to get a
different crossing the blockade of the
coots border cut off a vital trade route
for agriculture and other goods and cost
our economy hundreds of millions of
dollars
jobs in manitoba were at stake as well
as the emerson manitoba crossing here
too traffic was forced to divert other
crossings increasing travel time
creating chaos for truckers and other
travelers
windsor also experienced days of
blockades of one of canada's most
important routes over the ambassador
bridge
this bridge alone is responsible for 30
percent of trade coming back and forth
between canada and the us that's 390
million dollars in trade a day
40 000 commuters truckers and others
cross that bridge daily in my own
community truckers and others trying to
cross the
surrey border crossing were harassed by
individuals blocking the border there
were reports of domestic demonstrations
driving on the wrong side of the road
dangerous and reckless behavior that
endangers the lives of others the surrey
crossing is home to hundreds of millions
of dollars of trade back and forth
organizations are speaking out like the
surrey board of trade the impact of
these blockades is choking us already
impacted supply chains businesses and
jobs this is unacceptable sabotage to
the economy to be clear everyone has a
right to peaceful protest but these type
of demonstrations are impacting
businesses and livelihood this is not a
movement for the people these are not
peaceful demonstrations those who remain
unlawful destructive and are looking to
defy the law and abuse their fellow
citizens it has done a great deal of
harm and it must end now the pandemic
has been a challenging time for everyone
and if you're still in ottawa i
encourage you to leave now and allow the
residents to get back to their lives
thank you mr speaker
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for kamloops
thompson caribou uh thank you mr speaker
always a pleasure to rise on behalf of
the people of kamloops thompson caribou
now the honorable member spoke at length
about the negative aspects of what is
occurring in ottawa now unfortunately
the act that we're debating today is not
based just on the negative aspects it
has a critical threshold so he talked
about what people have experienced
what businesses experienced okay we need
to put that all aside because what can
be done about this the vehicles can be
seized the vehicle people can be
arrested and the vehicles can be seized
without a warrant or incidental to
arrest
the question that i asked this member is
given that those tools exist
already in another act and this act says
it has to be
an act of last resort that cannot be
satisfied by any other legislation how
can his party support it when we can get
rid of those vehicles under existing
legislation and every negative impact he
said would disappear thank you
the honourable member for surrey center
thank you to the member parliament from
camps kamloops thompson caribou uh look
central infrastructure or parliament
buildings these were put at risk
ontario declared a state of emergency
and despite that we're not able to clear
these
occupiers from the streets of ottawa the
city was not able to do it on their own
the tow truck companies have said
they've received death threats that they
will not tow so that's why there is a
time and a place and a need for such
legislation
questions and comments questions
responses
is
ottawa already
[Music]
i want to thank
my honorable colleague
from the other side
look we've seen that without this
legislation there was chaos it was
actually in fact the the day that this
was invoked uh just before midnight that
that our surrey border border crossing
was cleared unfortunately this doesn't
take away so fortunately this doesn't
take away the powers and the laws that
are already set in place this
supplements it it gives extra powers and
extra tools on top of those that we have
already and this is territorial specific
so when we have an issue we can invoke
it we can use it on that area but it's
not universal to places that do not have
those disruptions
and comments questions
the honourable member for churchill
kuwantanukaski
thank you mr speaker we are here because
of a failure of leadership it's day 21
of the occupation of our nation's
capital local leadership has failed uh
police in action has been on full
display even police complicity uh
shockingly concern the conservative
leader and conservative mps have been
aiding and embedding uh
illegal occupation uh and then we have
the liberals who've sat by for going
into four weeks and haven't taken the
measures necessary to crack down on an
illegal occupation led by a number of
folks who are known uh
to be associated with white supremacy uh
why did the liberals once those first
clear signs were out there uh not crack
down particularly on the funding
including foreign funding of this
illegal occupation
the honourable member for survey center
i want to thank my colleague
it's good to see her here on the house
even though it's virtually uh
look she's absolutely correct when we
have some members of the parliament uh
from the other side particularly the
conservative sides that are aiding and
abetting as she says
promoting sometimes calling them to go
away sometimes saying say sometimes say
hey i'm for you and their leadership
aspirants saying we support this convoy
it becomes very difficult
i think the government has done an
impeccable job of being content being
controlled
complying by the laws allowing
injunctions to take place allowing the
police and the city to do what they have
to do but unfortunately has reached this
matter that we now have to invoke the
emergencies act and there's no choice
representable continuing debate the
honorable member for medicine had carson
warner thank you mr speaker and i'll be
sharing my time with the honorable
member from and my colleague from
chilliwack hope
mr speaker my phone has not stopped
bringing constituents and concerned
canadians or emailing on mass
i have had hundreds of phone calls and
literally thousands of emails since the
news of this government's plan to invoke
the emergencies act was trickled out on
friday
not one of those emails not one of those
phone calls has been in favor of this
enactment
what they did want was to ensure that
their voices were heard by this prime
minister and the misguided liberal and
ndp mps who plan to support this
overreach before i begin with my own
thoughts i thought it was important for
this house and specifically those
members opposite who may be tempted to
remain loyal to their party lines
despite a heavy heart and convicted
conscience while these emails were sent
to me specifically they are really
intended for those members
who across the way who still could
change their position
lanny writes it's deeply disturbing to
see prime minister
invoke the emergencies act under present
circumstances he failed to act with the
powers that he previously held and then
asks for open-ended powers with no real
motivation i do not support this he has
failed as a leader
lanny knows that the prime minister has
been disengaged has been unwilling to
meet are willing to listen and most
importantly that this is not what a
leader does
she's right
this is failed leadership this is a
failure to use negotiation to use the
authorities that already exist and is
simply a power grab by someone who is
beyond his depth
lanny's not the only one that feels this
way
here's an excerpt from an email from a
lady by the name of reina
i feel very strongly about the
emergencies act frankly it's overkill
and quite frightening for a citizen of
canada there's no reason to invoke this
it's giving far too much control over a
situation that can be negotiated
does that sound familiar mr speaker the
prime minister's inability to negotiate
frightening canadians fear tactics too
much control these are repeating themes
not today
not this week and not this year this has
been the tone of this prime minister's
office
his entire time and canadians are beyond
frustrated with it
my constituents are in no way the only
canadians concerned mr speaker
the canadian civil liberties association
says that it does not believe that the
high and clear threshold needed to
invoke the act has been met and note
specifically that the law states the
emergency act can only be used when a
situation cannot be dealt with
using any other law in the country
the executive director went on as far as
to say and to warn that normalizing
emergency declarations or legislation
threatens our democracy and our civil
liberties
why mr speaker why
this prime minister and his misguided
minister surely have had legal opinions
like the one provided by leah west a
former national security lawyer with the
federal department of justice
she is not convinced that ongoing
protests rise to the level of the public
order emergency she's even gone so far
as to state publicly and i quote as
someone who studies the law very
carefully i'm kind of shocked
to be honest that the government
actually believes this meets the
definition to even invoke the act and
the quote
miss west goes on to elaborate that
under the existing
provincial
emergency order ontario can already do
some of the things that the federal
government is now contemplating
it's not clear to her why you would need
the federal authorities to do that
the emergency act mr speaker as you know
is not required
we've heard from
we've heard that expressed by
constituents by canadians in legal
opinions and as we know the emergency
act powers become available immediately
and the government then has seven days
to table legislation in parliament
now now i don't want to put words in the
legislative drafters mouths on this but
surely they were thinking back in the
day that there would never be a prime
minister so brazen to as to utilize the
powers of this act without a clear and
evident emergency requiring them to do
so
in a situation that would properly
utilize the emergencies act the threat
would be so inherently grave
that invoking the powers within the act
would jointly call be called for by
parliamentarians across party lines
provincial leaders and unite all
canadians while protecting our country
and our freedoms our predecessors in
this house would be ashamed of the
audacity of this prime minister this
government and the ndp coalition
propping them up by allowing the
emergencies act to be used as a divisive
tool and not as the unifying
nation-building and life-saving tool it
was designed to be
this is not the case
and this is not the time
this government does not have my support
and this government does not have the
support of canadians
what is required but has been lacking
his leadership
the provinces
have been able to resolve their issues
with protesters just like they did in my
riding of at the coots border crossing
what did cootes have that ottawa doesn't
leadership
peaceful resolution was able to be
achieved via dialogue
open
frank
honest conversations between protest
organizers and elected officials alberta
mps
provincial leaders locally elected
officials and law enforcement all had
had a hand in the peaceful resolution by
showing true leadership
genuine concern and taking the time to
listen
and be heard
no one mr speaker not the prime minister
not one government minister and
certainly not the leader of the ndp
possess the leadership
to have one meeting with protesters
even when it was offered to them
was it their privileged perch from their
ivory tower offices that made them feel
superior to the working-class citizens
beneath them
was it their intolerance of opinions
they disagree with
or has this one single incident exposed
what the prime minister and the leader
of the opposition that sort of the
leader of the ndp are really all about
at election time we hear phrases from
the prime minister like we know that
canada has succeeded culturally
politically and economically because of
our diversity not in spite of it
but in situations like the one we find
ourselves in today
we know that the prime minister instead
thinks that our diversity is a national
emergency
and not something to be embraced
the leader of the ndp is no better when
he needs your vote he tweets
diversity is a strength not a weakness
we were meant to stand out not blend in
using the hashtag make it awkward
but when his convictions are truly
tested his voice is nowhere to be heard
his silence and lack of leadership
blends in well amongst the liberals and
the only one awkward here is him as he
continues to empower his prime minister
to treat hard-working canadians as
second-class citizens
mr speaker
what do oak what what do the occur
crisis
the conflict of caledonia
the west and rail blockades the bc
pipeline protests and 9 11 all have in
common in common
none of them awarded the use of
emergencies act
this is the first time we've had a prime
minister audacious enough to invoke the
emergencies act since it was created in
1988 and canadians know that he's doing
so as a power grab
mr speaker this is an example of
political gainsmanship not political
statesmanship constituents canadians and
legal practitioners all agree
that invoking the emergencies act is
unwarranted
and unwanted
do the liberal members opposite and
those in the ndp whose votes would be
required to pass this motion
have the courage
to do what canadians are demanding of
them and oppose this motion
i do mr speaker and i hope they find it
within themselves to rise above the
political fray and do the right thing
thank you very much
testing to come up there questions and
comments the honourable member for uh
saanich coal violence
thank you mr speaker and around my
friend from medicine carson warner uh
the the there are a number of things
which have constituted global
emergencies uh by the way i should say
to the honorable member because i don't
think i've put it on the record yet i'm
still trying to decide how to vote on
this uh there are pros and cons to its
use i think we had a collapse of police
domestic here in ottawa the chain of
command broke somewhere and we're in a
very different situation than if we had
acted based on the information that it
now appears they should have had about
the security threat that was uh implicit
in the convoy but the examples the
honorable member has used of when we
didn't use the emergencies act were ones
that were either exterior to canada i
mean goodness knows canadians and
particularly halifax and newfoundland
reacted so brilliantly and generously
when 9 11 happened in in taking care of
people who were
completely stranded but that doesn't
rise to an emergency encounter i don't
even think it's plausible what sueton
protests or the blockading of uh it
wasn't a blockade i i was arrested in a
non-violent civil disobedient protest
where uh on many similar occasions
uh kinder morgan never even called the
police so it's those are not emergencies
that would rise to the level that's
anything like this last time remember to
reflect on the differences in each of
the examples he put forward
the honourable member for medicine had
carson warner
uh thank you and and thank you to uh my
friend from the greens i um
my answer won't be as long as her
question
and but but i will say that um
i think in some of those circumstances
the situation there and previous times
were as serious or more serious than
what we faced today and so
um the emergencies act were not invoked
that was not invoked then and it should
not be invoked now
questions and comments questions
is
injuries and so on the honourable member
for medicine headquarters in warner uh
yes uh thank you mr speaker and thank
you to my friend from the block uh
absolutely unequivocally there is an
opportunity to um
prevent any sort of injury or property
damage or inju loss of life or any you
know any violence
and it starts by this government
actually saying you know what like what
like our leader said the other day
a novel branch meet with them i have met
with the organizers here in ottawa and
all that they wanted to do was meet with
a minister even via zoom to have them
feel listened to
they don't feel listened to they don't
feel heard they feel
know you know that they've been they've
been pushed aside by an ideology that
they don't idea they don't adhere to and
so they're second-class citizens and so
uh we can we still can avoid this issue
by this government so on their pride and
doing what should have been done right
away and meeting with somebody and and
listening to their concerns thank you
very much
questions and comments questions come on
tara the honorable member for edmonton
griezma
thank you very much mr speaker i want to
remind the honorable member that speaks
so highly of how peaceful it was here in
alberta and how peaceful what was
happening in kutz uh was we lost as
albertans almost 50 million dollars a
day
on february 14th the rcmp arrested 11
people who were charged with conspiracy
to commit murder and that was against
our own police if that's not
violence and if that's not urgent and if
that's not an emergency i don't know
what it is there was 14
firearms found there body armor machete
huge quantities of ammunition these are
serious issues that are in our country
in our province and we've lost huge
would the member explain
why he and members of even the province
would stand with these folks who were of
course
terrorizing many people across our
province and including the ones in
ottawa
member for
medicine hat carson warner thank you
very much mr speaker and i was hoping
someone would bring that up
let's let's clear the air here it's been
very very clear that a criminal
organization
days after or or weeks after the coots
border crossing uh protest began
joined the group they infiltrated the
group they weren't part of the group
they had ulterior motives they weren't
part of the protest they were tied to
organized organized criminal
organization from here
in in the nation's capital and across
this country
we should be very concerned that uh that
there's violence and does those
extremists exist in our society but they
existed and not because of this protest
they attach themselves to every sort of
movement what's important to realize
here is that the situation kutz was
resolved using the legislation that
already exists
that with with the authorities from from
the rcmp and the elected officials it
was resolved those those individuals who
were committing or planning to commit
criminal offences were dealt with
appropriately without enacting
emergencies act prime example that we
can do this and settle this without this
nonsense from this government
resuming debate the honorable member
from chilliwack hope
well thank you very much mr speaker and
we are here today
because the prime minister has already
invoked the emergencies act what we're
debating in this house is whether or not
we believe that his invocation of the
act should be endorsed or revoked in
order for this house to endorse the
invocation of the emergencies act two
very high thresholds need to be met
the government at the time that this
legislation was introduced set a very
high bar on purpose
because the emergencies act is like a
fire alarm that can only be activated
when the glass has been broken
and we should only allow the glass to be
broken when it is justified
the emergencies act is only to be used
when there are threats to the security
of canada that are so serious that they
constitute a national emergency and
cannot be addressed using any of the
laws or tools that are currently on the
books
this invocation fails on all counts
there are no threats to the security of
the country there is a noisy protest
happening around parliament hill
but it's not impeding the ability of
parliament to function as we can see
clearly today the house continues to sit
mps walk through the protests every day
the prime minister holds press
conferences mere steps from where the
truckers have set up their rigs and
their signs
this protest even isn't even a threat to
the continued security of the house of
commons let alone the security of canada
it's also not a national emergency
the protest stretches over a few city
blocks of downtown ottawa
has it been disruptive yes it has
should the trucks move on or be moved at
this time yes they should
does the emergencies act need to be
invoked to allow that to happen
absolutely not there are more than
enough powers granted to enforcement
agencies to allow them to manage the
situation and resolve it peacefully
we've seen this at the border in coots
at the ambassador bridge in surrey and
at emerson
all of those incidents were peacefully
resolved using existing police and
government powers
the predecessor to this act the war
measures act was only invoked during
world war one world war ii and during
the flq crisis these are seminal moments
in canadian history
what we're seeing right now in ottawa
does not even come close to the level
required to take this draconian response
conservatives will oppose this overreach
the block quebecois has indicated that
they will oppose this overreach
liberal mps will do what the prime
minister tells them to do as they always
have and always will
so it comes down to the votes of the ndp
to determine whether or not this house
will endorse using the emergencies act
to suspend the civil rights and civil
liberties of whomever this prime
minister deems to be a designated person
engaging in an illegal protest
in 1970 when pierre elliott trudeau used
the war measures act to send in the army
and suspend the civil liberties of
canadians the ndp stood in opposition to
it
the vote was 190 mps in favor and only
16 against
ndp leader tommy douglas who i am quite
sure i have never quoted before said
this is overkill on our on a gargantuan
scale
calling the emergency legislation an act
of panic
he went on to compare the invocation of
the war measures act to using a
sledgehammer to crack a walnut
the exact same quotes could and should
be used to describe this prime
minister's gross overreach by using the
emergencies act today
numerous former ndp mps have weighed in
in disbelief at what their party is
prepared to endorse
recognizing the dangerous precedent that
this will set for future governments to
crack down on their own citizens
protesting the direction of a future
government
but today's ndp is joining the liberals
and endorsing the use of legislation
that takes away the rights of canadians
who the government disagrees with
today's ndp is willing to sacrifice
their own principles to provide comfort
to a liberal prime minister who has none
the order attached to this invocation is
far-reaching
canadians who've been involved in
completely legal and legitimate protests
that have taken place over the last
weeks could be retroactively caught up
in this drag net
canadians who donated small amounts of
their own money or who gave home-cooked
meals to truckers on their way to ottawa
could be caught up in this overreach
and what does the prime minister say to
those who've raised those concerns
just trust me
give me the benefit of the doubt
well trust is earned and this prime
minister deserves none
the emergency order allows the
government to freeze and seize bank
accounts without legal recourse
the government is encouraging banks to
never do business again
with any of the protesters
it allows for the suspension of
insurance products and for the seizure
of private property it proposes up to
five years in jail for people who are
advocating for an end to government
restrictions think about that for a
minute
people fighting for the freedom using
their rights as free citizens to
criticize government policy could be
thrown in jail for up to five years
they could have their ability to provide
for their families taken away
they could have their mortgages revoked
they could lose their homes
this has nothing to do with public
safety and everything to do with
punishing those who have dared to speak
against government policies
we're sent here to protect the rights of
canadians not take them away on the
flimsiest of excuses or to punish those
who embarrass the prime minister
there are many who will say good
riddance to the protesters and many who
will cheer on their financial ruin
clearly while there are many supporting
the protests there are many other
canadians who are disgusted by them
indeed many liberal supporters are
cheering on the prime minister's strong
armed tactics against our fellow
canadians
they'll point to public opinion polls
showing that people agree with the
government's decision to put the boots
to those who are embarrassing them on
the streets of ottawa
to put the protesters back in their
rightful place
to serve as a warning to others that
there are consequences for daring to
question or push back against the
government
i will remind this house
that many of the darkest chapters in our
history
many of the things we look back on in
disbelief and shame upon
many of the suspensions of freedoms and
liberties that past governments have
brought down upon our own people
were cheered on by the majority of
canadians and the majority of mps and
were justified in these halls
that doesn't mean they were right
it doesn't mean they were just and
indeed i believe that if we allow this
to stand there will be a time when a
future prime minister rises in his place
and apologizes for the actions of the
current prime minister in this case
the prime minister's made a purposeful
political choice
to create the division we see in this
country today this has been confirmed by
the liberal mp for louis bear
instead of seeking understanding and
common ground the prime minister sought
political advantage through division
when his pollsters told them he could
turn vaccinated canadians against
unvaccinated canadians friend against
friend neighbor against neighbor and
family member against family member he
jumped at the chance
he spent the entire election pitting
canadian against canadian he called
those who disagreed with him racist
misogynist who should not be tolerated
he called them a fringe minority with
unacceptable views as if being a prime
minister or being a liberal gave him a
monopoly on what acceptable views are
he inflamed the situation in ottawa with
his rhetoric and then went into hiding
he continues to to divide for partisan
advantage
and now he wants this house to simply
roll over
and allow him to steamroll the rights of
canadians he disagrees with and use a
tool he has no justification to use
the use of the emergencies act and its
order in this case are unjustified
thresholds have not been met
its invocation will only serve to
further deepen the divisions that have
been purposely sown by this prime
minister
invoking the emergencies act will not
resolve a national crisis indeed it may
create one
it's time to stop using the powers of
government to punish those who have made
difficult unpopular decisions about
their own health
it's time to stop going down the prime
minister's path of division and instead
choose the path of healing and
reconciliation
and the first step on that path is the
rejection of the use of the emergencies
act against our fellow citizens
we must vote against this motion and we
must instead work together to lower the
temperature give canadians back their
rights and work together to heal the
divisions in our land
thank you very much mr speaker
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for nanaimo lady
smith
thank you mr speaker and thank you to
the member for his intervention as i was
listening to the members intervention uh
today i was reflecting on a joint
statement from canada's union on the
ottawa occupation from february 9 2022
it states canada's unions have fought
for generations for the right to protest
this is a cornerstone of our democratic
system but what we have witnessed on the
streets of canada's capital they go on
to say is something different altogether
instead today they refer to what is
happening outside this chamber as an
occupation by an angry mob trying to
disguise itself as a peaceful protest
this joint statement calls on the
federal government to quickly deliver
urgently needed supports to workers and
businesses affected can the member
please share how aligning himself with
an occupation that has shut down workers
and businesses is in the best interest
of
canadians well mr speaker who i've
aligned myself with with the canadian
people who have rights under our
constitution and who do not have those
rights uh they do not deserve to have
those rights trampled upon because there
are is a a protest taking place in a few
city blocks of ottawa this does not meet
the threshold
of the emergencies act and as much as
the liberals want to say it the only
emergency is a political emergency for
the prime minister who has utterly
failed this country who has utterly
failed to deliver the leadership that he
is supposed to give
so there is no need for the emergencies
act anything that has been described can
be dealt with under existing legislation
under existing tools
and the idea that we need to use this
draconian act that has only been used
its predecessor three times during world
wars during times when people were being
kidnapped and when explosions were
happening in the streets to compare that
to what's happening outside of
parliament is ridiculous and we need to
reject this emergency act provisions
immediately
casting our commonwealth questions and
comments honorable parliamentary
secretary to the government house leader
well the member is incorrect uh mr
speaker this piece of legislation has
never been enacted before he's trying to
suggest that the emergency measures act
is the same thing as a war measures act
and it couldn't be further from the
truth they're completely different and
call on different measures but what i
find most alarming mr speaker is that
this member wants to align himself with
a group outside whose first objective
objective number one in their calls to
action are that
if you can believe this the governor
general and the senate get together
overthrow a democratically elected
parliament and set up a citizen's
advisory committee of canadians that
will then govern the country that's what
this member is aligning himself with
when he supports the people outside
the honourable member for chilliwack
hope
well mr speaker i'm surprised that
remember being so terrified of what he
sees outside found his way into the
house of commons today it must have been
very difficult for him to walk past the
bouncy castles and the and the kids play
area to get in there this is a
ridiculous argument the idea that
somehow a manifesto by a few people on
the internet is a is a is a threat to
the national security of the country
it's a clear and present danger to the
national security of our country it is
absolutely ridiculous this is a protest
that has gone on uh we have said quite
clearly we think it's time for the
individuals there to move their trucks
uh to or to have them move but that can
all be done
that can all be done through existing
legislation so i know that this member
and his government likes to control
uh canadians they like to gather all of
the power they can we need to reject
this draconian overreach and do it today
question
of the deputy
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well yes thank you uh mr speaker and i
thank the colleague for her question of
course i said that it was the
predecessor to the emergencies act which
is demonstrably true
i think it is it is quite simply
ridiculous i heard another liberal
member to say
say just before that the government has
done an impeccable job of managing this
situation well i think canadians would
disagree it's been a it's been a
catastrophe
but the government's catastrophe the
failure of the prime minister does not
justify
the use of an emergencies act to punish
canadians for voicing views that are
outside of what the government finds
acceptable this is all can be managed
under current laws as it has been done
at the ambassador bridge coots emerson
surrey these have all been managed
without the draconian overreach of the
emergencies act and this house must
oppose this action
resuming debate representative
deputy de rosemont
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
government
and against democracy
from the interim
these are donald trump supporters who
are donating
to this country
on january 6th and they've openly said
that they want candidates
these are people who are walking around
they're clearly white supremacists
they're talking white supremacists
carrying the gospels
[Music]
often
is
the emergency
fundamental
a huge difference between this situation
and
the other parties are trying to say that
this is the same as the one measure
the time in which this act will apply
[Music]
all
we can put an end to this snap of our
fingers
are very
guaranteed
this is a great piece of legislation
for the benefits
emergencies
questionable comparisons
uh
[Music]
that's what happened in the 1970s
is
the demonstrators here
[Music]
well i'm very happy that i get to ask
this ndp member from quebec a question
because i'd love to hear his insight
into this mr speaker you know public
opinion polling is showing that 72
percent
of quebecers are in favor of the
emergency measures act being invoked but
even more astonishing mr speaker
according to abacus data
63 percent of people who voted for the
bloc quebecois in the last election say
they would never vote for an mp that
supports the protests outside and what
we're seeing here is the black quebecois
lining up with the conservatives saying
that they're supportive of what's going
on outside right now i'm wondering if
the member can provide his comments
being a a member of parliament from
quebec on why it is the bloc is taking
this approach
from
is
and comments uh
the honourable member for yorkton
melville
thank you speaker i'm concerned about
what i'm hearing today from this member
of the ndp party it's painting a picture
that is inflammatory with this inference
that the majority of those protesting
are racists rather than a few that show
their ignorance whenever an opportunity
arises
i personally have multiple examples i
have of indigenous black indian
muslim-seeking jewish participants
who have
taken part in this protest this peaceful
protest and are proudly talking about it
and they are either here to do that or
there are also others that have
shared their information
that are fact checking what they are
hearing from the mainstream member and
from members in this house so i would
ask him when did he personally interact
with these individuals who are behaving
in the way he's claiming they are
her questions
testimonies
[Music]
[Music]
distinguish between the two pieces of
legislation
[Music]
[Applause]
his own positions
thank you uh mr speaker i'm i'm rising
today with a heavy heart in support of
emergency measures to restore order in a
situation that has steadily been getting
out of hand
the convoy movement has clearly come to
mean many things to many different
people
but it matters i think that the stated
intention of the organizers has been to
disrupt and overthrow canada's
democratic institutions as outlined in
their published memorandum of
understanding and their discussions in
the media
a lack of leadership by the federal
government and local police in ottawa
have led us to a point of crisis
coupled with the discovery of weapon
caches allegations by authorities of
conspiracy to commit murder reports of
involvement by elite military members
and the prolonged harassment of people
in their homes and places of work there
can be no question that this has to stop
the status quo is unacceptable and can't
be allowed to continue
the failure of the ottawa police so far
to bring an end to the occupation and
the persistence of border blockades
until the declaration of emergency
measures
show that additional measures are
necessary to break the log jam
i'm glad that all the border crossings
have reopened in the last several days
and i look forward to the end of the
illegal
occupation of ottawa and then that i
hope comes swiftly and peacefully
there have been many protests in canada
over the last 34 years since the
emergency measures act was developed as
an alternative to the war measures act
none of them have resulted in a
prolonged weeks-long occupation of the
nation's capital city
none of them have been characterized as
this one is by the active and sustained
harassment of residents in their homes
on the street and in their places of
work
the fact that many canadians are feeling
legitimate fatigue because of the
pandemic challenges we have all had to
suffer
doesn't excuse this behavior
the fact that many canadians share a
desire with convoy organizers to lift
public health measures doesn't absolve
the organizers of responsibility for
their undemocratic objectives
the fact that most canadians fed up with
vaccine mandates and passports do not
support white supremacy or endorse
messages of hate
does not make the small number of
canadians who do
any less dangerous in this volatile time
i believe that there are many canadians
who are frustrated and tired of the
pandemic who have sympathy for the
convoy because they want to see an end
to certain public health measures and
that the overwhelming majority of them
do not support the extremist views and
objectives of the convoy organizers
it's very important that there be space
in our country for debate about the
issues of the day
in our day that includes the nature and
extent
of public health measures
for my part
i believe that the discussion should be
led by public health officials on the
basis of the best available information
i've been consistent in that position
since the outset of the pandemic and
i'll continue to be even as i respect
the right of others to disagree
there are many canadians who want to
have a discussion about public health
measures including vaccine mandates and
passport systems
there is room for this discussion in a
democracy
and the right to engage in those
conversations has to be protected
ending the illegal occupations and
stopping the extremists who have their
own undemocratic political agenda is
necessary to make space for that
legitimate debate and protest
it may also create space for dr tam to
undertake the review of public health
measures that she hinted at on february
4th and have largely been expected to
come after the omicron wave
even before the convoy left for ottawa
making changes to public health orders
while the occupation persists is not
advisable in my opinion
because it would encourage people to
think that public policy can be set by
intimidation and the threat of violence
capitulation doesn't work in winnipeg
where the manitoba conservatives
announced a sudden change to public
health orders in response to the convoy
demonstrators are still set up downtown
even though the province has said all
public health measures will be lifted
within the next several weeks
in my day i've been part of many
different political demonstrations and
supported many different causes
i've seen police clear out
demonstrations of people
protesting against free trade agreements
against racism and in defense of
indigenous rights far more quickly and
far more brutally
despite there being truly peaceful
demonstrations
i recall not that long ago in winnipeg
in 2020 in the aftermath of george
floyd's murder at the hands of police
a demonstration attended by thousands of
people at the legislature
i remember organizers in the lead up to
that event publicly communicating that
violent demonstrators were not welcome
i remember them working to make a plan
for the demonstration that would make it
hard for anyone who wanted to hijack it
with violent or hateful acts
and it was a successful demonstration
with many many people
who made their point and went home and
then have continued to be involved in
all sorts of continuing anti-racism
activity including protests and
demonstrations
but they didn't occupy downtown winnipeg
for weeks on end and we've seen even you
know camps of homeless who have nowhere
else to go
get cleared out in no time
by police
simply for being in some of the same
spaces that are being occupied now in
downtown winnipeg wasn't a problem to
clear out the homeless
i don't know
why it is that it's acceptable
to um
to
to allow folks to set up
um
in the way that they have when when
others who are just seeking to live in
some kind of community get get cleared
out
but i was talking just earlier about the
demonstration surrounding george floyd's
death in winnipeg i think that's what
responsible political organizing
committed to peaceful protest looks like
it takes work
and there are people who do that work
and you can tell in their public
messages i haven't seen that kind of
leadership from the organizers of these
occupations and i have to say if any
efforts have been made they certainly
have not been effective
i was pleased last thursday when the
member for portage lisker an interim
leader of the conservative party finally
called for the convoy to go home but
they haven't gone home
the the ottawa police have shown they
can't be trusted to send them home
and so we have to have additional
measures to move them along
i agree that the prime minister has done
a terrible job as a leader through this
crisis
while it's right to call out proponents
of hate and extremists in the crowd and
in the ranks of the organizers
it's wrong to lump in the far larger
group of canadians tired with public
health measures into that group and it
hasn't served our national dialogue
it hasn't served our country
it hasn't served our body politic
i'd be remiss if i didn't know that the
conservatives have been engaging in
their own brand of politics on these
issues
the conservative government in manitoba
was the first to implement a vaccine
passport system but federal
conservatives never showed up on the
steps of the legislature to oppose that
system
leaked letters show that the interim
conservative leader has been more
concerned to make this a political
problem for the prime minister
than to help the country find a way to
de-escalate and get out of this and well
there is
absolutely a sister to provide that
leadership
there is also responsibility on others
in this house particularly
the leader of the official opposition
leaked letters have also showed that the
conservative premier of manitoba has
been happy to beg the prime minister to
intervene privately while criticizing
his intervention
his intervention publicly
what i'm trying to say mr speaker is
that there's a lot of different
political agendas at work in and around
the convoy
but the upshot is that the people of
ottawa are being terrorized in their
homes for weeks now
while the country careens toward a level
of political instability we haven't seen
in my lifetime
and that's why it really is time for the
convoy to go home
that doesn't mean it's time for the
discussion around public health measures
to end
but it means that those who want to
demonstrate and those who want to
protest
have to start
doing that in a way and i know there
have been many who have done this in a
peaceful way
but like the organizers of other
protests i was referring to earlier
there has to be an effort to root out
the violence and the the extremists and
those who are intimidating people in
ottawa
that has to become far more a part of
the public message of this convoy
in order for the real issues that people
are concerned about and on which
you know they may not agree with me but
that's okay
but if they want that message to be
heard
then their political organizing has to
take a very different shape than the
shape that it has taken in the convoy
so i appeal to all those canadians who i
know are perhaps frustrated and angry
with me
because i haven't called for an end to
all public health measures right now
because i prefer to defer
to public health officials on this point
but i would call for them
in their good spirit and in their good
faith
to
to start actively
calling on on the convoy organizers to
promote peace to dislodge themselves
from downtown ottawa and anywhere else
that they're hanging on and then to
engage in the kinds of peaceful protests
that canada knows
very well and i think that's how we get
this dialogue back on track and create a
path to unity in canada thank you mr
speaker
questions and comments questions come on
terry the honourable member for
scarborough rouge park
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
thank my colleague for that very
thoughtful
intervention um i do want to
just highlight a number of speakers have
suggested that the prime minister meet
with those who are illegally blocking
parliament hill and engage in in
dialogue with them um i just want him to
reflect um my friend obviously reflect
and maybe give us a sense of why that's
not possible why uh political engagement
at that level is inappropriate just
given uh what's out there right now
remember for elmwood transcona
well look i mean i i don't think it
makes sense for prime minister to meet
with a group who has a stated objective
of displacing a democratically elected
government
with
some kind of self-appointed committee
and the governor general in the senate i
mean i read the mou
and i thought it was ridiculous
unfortunately it sounded so ridiculous
that i think too many people including
people in the ottawa police force and
the government failed to take
the threat that these folks represent to
stability
seriously and i think there's a lot of
canadians who have supported
them in good faith without taking that
part of it seriously but that part of it
and the determination that that
represents has been a big part of why
this has been such an obstinate
uh uh protest and why it's been so hard
to dislodge and that's the part that we
now need to deal with questions and
comments the honourable member for
dufferin caledon
well thank you mr speaker i want to ask
the member a question
what test has been met in order to
justify this extreme measure the former
ndp member of parliament sven robinson
has said i was in the house during the
1988 debate on the act
when we were promised that emergency
powers can only be used when the
situation is so drastic
that no other law of canada can deal
with the situation
the test has not been met
ndp
can you stop this it's clear from the
members speech they're not going to stop
this
what is happening in ottawa that regular
laws cannot deal with we saw all the
other blockades at borders removed with
existing laws what's the specific law
that has to come into place to take care
of something that's been taken care of
elsewhere
the honourable member for elmwood
transcona
well first of all i would note that some
of those border blockades were only
cleared out once the state of emergency
had been declared and so i do think that
in some of those cases the this
declaration has played a role in having
those clear out and secondly i would
note that
for as much as uh
there may be powers under existing laws
to clear out ottawa the ottawa police
force hasn't done it
so something in the context needs to
change
and uh
and so you know this is how we get to
the position that we're in i wish we had
had a more unified call across party
lines early in the convoy to send the
message that they should all go home
instead we saw a lot of people in this
place encourage them
and we're now
which is which is not to say
that they shouldn't be giving voice to
the legitimate questions about public
health measures even where there's
disagreement between the ndp and and and
those and those and those folks who hold
who hold views about
casting
[Music]
[Music]
um
but my question is
is
[Applause]
[Music]
heartily
[Music]
is
hello
thank you
[Music]
well you know it really is
is
is
[Music]
those are three people
so
[Music]
[Music]
they're growing
is
[Music]
true
on the last
stage to put
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
london street
it's a big surprise
[Music]
is
health guidelines
that's what he said to the profession
the stage where he starts looking for
solutions
[Music]
people thought that was a good idea
yeah
is
is
[Music]
always
he's going to make
he's going to make a 10-minute speech he
can give us some good news here he said
manifesto
well he told that protesters to go get
vaccinated that's all he had to say
leadership
[Music]
uh
as well
is
it's like one of those situations
in your legs
the government said well i have to do
something
soon you better pretend
he said
[Music]
he doesn't have to do anything
to preach
is
under the current
[Music]
a party that formerly defended workers
and they defended people
exactly
let me come back to the specific use of
this measure
for example in the depression we saw
john maynard king
he was an incredibly intelligent person
who changed the world
[Music]
[Music]
these are people who are incredibly hard
situations
wow mr speaker i don't know what's going
on but ever since the member uh the the
current leader of the uh official
opposition or the former leader
uh stepped down or was kicked out and
the member from carleton became the heir
apparent
to lead the party the black quebecois
has taken a massive
change in their approach lining up with
the conservatives time and time again
as though they have to regurgitate the
same rhetoric that we hear from the
conservatives all the time and that's
what we're seeing a brand new approach
to the block quebecois now and this
member you know spoke for 20 minutes of
which at least 19 minutes was just an
opportunity to air his personal
grievances about the prime minister
spoke very little to the actual
substance of this motion how is it that
the black quebecois has put itself in
this position when polling shows that 73
percent of quebecers support this move
the library the honorable mentions
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
is
if
[Laughter]
is
the prime minister should be the one
answering
this question question
questions and comments the honorable
member for nunavuts
i'd like to thank the member for la
prairie for his very entertaining
statement and for talking about
leadership
i'd like to ask
about the conservatives attempt to
minimize these extremist activities and
i'd also like to highlight that there
was news uh that law enforcement had
intercepted a new convoy uh heading to
the ambassador uh bridge recently
does the member agree that dismantling
the blockade does not dismantle the
leadership and that it is only the
uh potential of enforcing the these
measures is um what's going to be needed
to keep the safety of canadians indeed
the uh freedom of all canadians intact
free enemies
[Applause]
[Music]
when asking
them
[Music]
is
parliamentary secretary to the minister
of justice
um thank you mr speaker and and i really
um i want to thank my friend opposite
for his very entertaining uh
presentation today uh but i do want to
just put on the record
uh the report of the house at uh house
of parliament on the emergencies act
consultations and the extensive work
that was undertaken not just by the
prime minister but whole of government i
really do want to to
ask the member officer to reflect on
that but he did mention a couple of
things that i want to probe him on
particularly on media he said
the media is very supportive of the
position of the bloc
there have been a number of media
reports of individuals who represent the
media who've been attacked who were
under intimidation who have had to
obtain security just to walk through uh
the convoy um if you can uh suggest to
us
what measures um what what would prompt
the block to support um
such people who who have
made
very uh
incidentally remarks who've been
who are who appear to be racist on a
number of fronts and who are also
intimating the media what will prompt
the bloc to support them
perhaps that wasn't clear i'll try it
don't support
is
is
mr speaker it's a pleasure to be here
today i'd like to thank all the police
involved and especially the ontario
provincial police that are doing a great
job around the province
two points one is
on polling the liberal member from
kingston has mentioned polling many many
times
i don't think polling has any place in
what we're trying to accomplish here and
keeping canadians safe so we need to get
polling and that discussion right off
the table another problem is most the
people that are in here today have been
briefed by this by csis the rcmp or
anybody so a lot of what we're talking
about is hyperbole especially on the
other side i wondered if the member from
the block has any comment on that and
the importance of briefing senior
members in each political party to make
good decisions for canadians thank you
very
much
is
and ideas constructive ideas
is
thank you
foreign
where's
is
or enforced in quebec that's what the
national assembly said so we're saying
this is pointless
and it is pleased
continuing debates
thank you uh mr speaker mr lepros uh
it's nice to be here this evening uh mr
speaker i will be uh sharing my time uh
with the honorable colleague and friend
from
correctly
mr speaker
i've been in this house now over six
years
and i've spoken with pleasure
many many many times on this house on
various topics on bia bia legislation
this week on c12 or c8 or c2
but tonight
and this evening
i'm speaking on something that i think
merits much
pause much thought
much importance for
our country
and
we've reached a stage where
the government
needs to act
i fundamentally believe mr speaker in
the rule of law
in enforcing the rule of law
and making sure all canadians follow the
rule of law
sadly mr speaker events in recent weeks
have added a significant layer of
hardship to the lives of many canadians
who have already endured two years of a
global pandemic
and mr speaker when i say these these
two years you know
all of us all of us here went through an
election last
september
i canvass extensively in my riding and i
know the feedback i received and
and i was privileged enough to return
here to the house of commons to
represent the the wonderful
residents of von woodbridge and i
represent all my all my residents much
like we all do but i do know at that
time there was much feedback and much
frustration
uh what we were going through and the
comments i heard were we're sometimes
really really disappointing
uh and and that frustration is carried
through we have been in the global
pandemic but we are all coming out of it
mr speaker
um so when i think about tonight's
debate and what will happen over the
coming days
um
basically mr speaker invoking the
emergencies act will help authorities in
getting our country back on track
disruptions and illegal blockades at
canada's border crossings have halted
international trade and supply chains
at a time when canadian businesses are
striving to take part in the ongoing
global economic recovery
mr speaker just on that point when we
think about where we're coming out of
post-pandemic
and where the world is going
and the increased global competition
that we're seeing
the increase in economic nationalism
that we're seeing
the rise of what i would call uh
economic and regional blocs
uh the united states and its competition
with china
and realizing what's happening there uh
a reinvigorated europe a post-brexit uk
we know
that we need to stand up for canadian
businesses
we know we need to stand up for canada's
reputation
globally to ensure that we always
implement and follow the rule of law
so mr speaker on that now those thoughts
are in
my mind
we also know during this time here in
ottawa
and across the country that municipal
and provincial resources have been
strained the city of ottawa the city of
windsor and the province of ontario have
all declared a state of emergency
the situation has evolved over two weeks
in ottawa in almost a week at the
ambassador bridge
there's been a substantial impact on our
economy and those who are unable to work
due to the blockades and frankly the
occupation here in our nation's capital
madame the president uh welcome this
evening many businesses in our nation's
capital have been forced to close due to
safety concerns i know i've been here
these last three weeks here in ottawa
and i've seen all the businesses along
spark street that are run by families
uh they're run by families that are
unable to open the individuals who work
at the rideau canal who are at home not
earning a paycheck right now to cover
their bills and expenses for their
families this frankly uh madam the
president must stop this must come to an
end and invoking the emergencies act is
the right thing to do
with the president about a week and a
half ago or so uh i was able to do a
panel
on
on ctv power play
and that uh that inter that panel has
received over two hundred thousand or
approximately two hundred thousand views
on my facebook page
and i was
went and saw this the feedback that i
was receiving and i realized just how
how nasty some of those comments were
how unbecoming they were and they were
from the united states they were from
canada from parts of the world
and i thought to myself just how hey how
frustrated people were but how
the right wing
in parts of this country and other parts
of the world
were distorting the truth
we're distorting the law and we're
putting forward what i would say
mistress misleading canadians
and in my comments during those uh those
uh
interviews i said very frankly that the
individuals outside have a right to
peaceful protest the individuals that
are outside have a right for their voice
to be heard
like all canadians do whether it's at
the ballot box or whether it's in
assembling to do peaceful protests but
what they do not have a right to do
for now 21 days
is disrupt the lives
of the citizens of this wonderful city
that i and many of us here get to visit
that is not right
that needed to come to an end and i
called for it that evening i called for
it in subsequent
opportunities i had and i called for it
again tonight i truly hope the
individuals outside
here of this
parliament uh decide to go home and go
back to their families
uh their messages uh there are many in
there anti-anti-vaxx anti-mandates and
to the prime minister
uh
you know overthrowing our government
over throwing a democratically elected
government
um you know what you're all entitled to
your views i respect that
but you're not entitled to disrupt the
lives of the citizens of this city or
frankly the lives of the citizens of any
city across canada we all are rule of
law
and the invocation of the emergencies
act
is in my view justifiable
citizens here in ottawa sorry ottawa
residents have been harassed and in some
cases physically assaulted by protesters
from practicing basic public health
measures during the pandemic such as
wearing a mask citizens have been
targeting targeted
disgusting insults and gestures simply
for the color of their skin
other alleged crimes have even been more
egregious ottawa police are
investigating the attempted arson of a
downtown apartment building the
situation persists fueled in part by
foreign funding
ottawa residents are rightly frustrated
by the ongoing illegal activity
occurring in their city recently some
even took to the streets to counter
protests physically preventing more
vehicles from joining the disruptions
the chief of the ottawa police service
peter slowly
publicly announced his resignation on
february 15th in the midst of this
unprecedented situation the mayor of
ottawa jim watson publicly announced he
has negotiated with members of the
convoy to allow for certain residential
streets to be vacated of trucks how
would we feel if we went home to our
individual ridings to our home and there
were vehicles parked in front of our
house
and would be honking at any time of the
day i do not believe that any member of
the 338 that have the privilege of
sitting in this house that were sent
here by their residents would think that
would be cool i don't think anything
anyone would accept that
that is not acceptable in our country
that is not following the rule of law
an integrated command center has been
established to consolidate response
efforts between the ottawa police
service ontario provincial police and
the rcmp
the government of canada continues to
support the city of ottawa the province
of ontario and all the law enforcement
agencies involved as needed rc and rcmp
resources have already been deployed
invoking the emergency act will help
authorities clear downtown ottawa
streets of illegally parked trucks and
help restore order and peace in affected
communities mr speaker law enforcement
agencies in kutz alberta
are also fearing they're facing a very
real and worsened threats a tractor and
semi-truck attempted to ram a police
vehicle as my colleagues have noted the
alberta rcp also identified a criminal
organization operating among the
protesters and arrested 13 individuals
seizing firearms tactical vests
high-capacity magazines and ammunition
in the process
yes we download the president that
actually happened in canada they had
stored their weapons in trailers and
were reportedly prepared to use force
against the police if the police
attempted to disrupt the blockade
the cbsa port of entry remains open and
the supply lines continue to flow at
this border crossing in alberta madame
the president
throughout throughout the evolution of
these protests the government of canada
has been closely monitoring and engaging
with partners as needed this is a clear
threat
that is a national that is national
scope and not just impacting one of the
two provinces we recognize and
sympathize with the challenges that many
canadians have faced as a result of this
situation along with the sacrifices
sacrifices made by all canadians
including the residents of my riding of
vaughan woodbridge through the pandemic
which is nearly two years in which
thankfully due to vaccinations we are i
would say exiting in onto brighter days
sunnier days i would say the federal
government continues to call on everyone
involved to not jeopardize public peace
or endanger anyone and not to
participate purposefully
in illegal events such as what we're
seeing outside this building outside the
house of commons while the right of
everyone to freedom of expression and
peaceful assembly is an important part
of our democracy
unfortunately the honorable member's
time is up i was trying to give him i
gave him the two minute mark in the one
minute mark and
hurry up mark
so anyhow the honourable member will
have a chance to uh to add to his uh
speech through questions and comments
questions
the demonstrators are doing
[Music]
[Music]
woodbridge
thanks very much i'm a father of three
daughters and i understand well the
analogy of
when you're raising children
i also understand very well
that we are
a nation of laws
that the rule of law
needs to be enforced
that i again
ask
the individuals outside to please go
home go back to your loved ones go back
to your families uh let's do the right
thing
let's allow the citizens of ottawa to
return to their normal daily lives
and let's hope that this situation
resolves itself uh as
peacefully and we can all move on with a
lot with our lives especially the
wonderful citizens of uh our nation's
capital merci beaucoup
madam speaker and it's nice to see you
here i've been uh senior earlier today i
want to thank my colleague for his uh
his his well-toned speech i do
appreciate it i do have a question
though like what has changed a couple
days ago winds are cleared
surrey cleared coot's alberta cleared
emission is clearing all those were
cleared
under existing laws and existing
enforcement measures so those main
issues have cleared
why do bring why bring in this
sledgehammer now i hear a gentleman
cross away kind of heckling but well
they could return
is the intent then to
continue this forever
under the president all it could
possibly return so if you could just
fill us in like what has really changed
now that these items have been cleared
why bring in the act now
the our member for von braun bishop um
thank you thank you to the honourable
member from edmonton west uh for their
question uh what i would say is first
the invocation of the of the emergency
act is something done with much much
thought much diligence and much to
judiciousness uh it is timely uh
proportionate and targeted there are
many safeguards put in place uh i would
say that the situation outside is now in
day 21 it needs to be resolved
we need to act
as a country
the federal government is there working
with the province working with the
municipality uh and this is a
justifiable that's what it come downtown
is this it down to for myself is this
justifiable and my answer is yes thank
you president questions and comments
y'all remember for edmonton greece back
a brief question please
thank you madam speaker just this monday
the city of ottawa still claimed they
didn't have enough resources from
provincial and federal government to
deal with the occupation
and just just the day before that the
minister of emergency preparedness was
blaming the police for the lack of
enforcement
while there were while there may be some
truth to both claims both or sorry
finger-pointing and blaming each other
is not what canadians need they need
leadership do my liberal colleagues
agree that it's unacceptable that we see
arguments about resources in the third
week of this occupation and why hasn't
this been figured out yet
a brief answer from the honourable
member for vaughn woodbridge
thank you to the honourable member
member from edmonton greensback i do
look forward to meet meeting
them when they're here in person i will
say this i don't believe in monday
morning quarterbacking what i believe is
in leadership and acting and our
government every step of the way has
worked with the city of ottawa provided
resources whether it's rcmp officers
whether it's intelligence and
intelligence gathering and we will
continue to be working with the province
with every single province and territory
and with our municipal uh leaders as
well thank you madam the president
resuming debate they are a member for
daval nasal
thank you madam speaker
and thank you for the opportunity to be
able to speak
in this debate
invoking the emergencies act was a
difficult but necessary decision our
government chose to make for the good of
canada
it was made after carefully considering
all
other possible solutions to our ongoing
emergency
we recognize that the powers of the
emergencies act
which was enshrined into canadian law in
1988
should only be utilized in very specific
and dire circumstances
their criteria are strict
but we believe that the current
situation meets the definition of
threats to the security of canada as
outlined in the canadian security
intelligence service act
as the minister of public safety has
noted
numerous consultations were completed
prior to moving forward
it is important to note that this
decision is not a catalyst for military
intervention
we are not preventing canadians from
exercising their right to peaceful
assembly or to protest
legally we are not suspending
fundamental rights or freedoms or
overriding the charter of rights and
freedoms
we are not limiting canadians freedom of
speech
this decision
aims to keep our citizens and our
institutions safe
through these new powers
the government is enabling the rcmp to
have jurisdiction to enforce municipal
bylaws and provincial offenses
prohibiting taking part in a public
assembly where it's considered a breach
of peace and goes beyond lawful protest
regulating the use of certain property
including goods used in blockades
designating secure and protected places
and infrastructure that are critical to
the economy such as the airport or
border crossings
compelling those capable to render
essential services
so in this case
ordering tow truck drivers to move
vehicles blocking roads
imposing fines of up to five thousand
dollars or imprisonment of up to five
years on those who breach any of the
above orders
madam speaker the current situation
requires additional tools not held by
any other federal provincial or
territorial law
these disruptions and illegal blockades
are being supported by funds which
appear to come from foreign sources
therefore
the following first-time deterrents will
be put in place
directing canadian financial
institutions to review their
relationships with anyone involved in
the illegal blockades and report to the
rcmp or csis
giving federal institutions new broad
authority to share information on anyone
suspected of involvement with the
blockades with canadian banks and
financial institutions
and giving banks and other financial
service providers the ability to
immediately freeze or suspend an account
personal or corporate without a court
order
madam speaker as the prime minister
mentioned earlier this week
we cannot
and will not
allow illegal and dangerous activities
to continue
blockades have stifled the flow of goods
between canada and our largest trading
partner the united states
the rcmp has arrested 11 individuals who
are part of the blockade at cootes
according to the rcmp press release the
group was said to have a willingness to
use force against the police if any
attempts were made to disrupt the
blockade
as part of the operation
the rcmp seized long guns handguns
body armor
high capacity magazines and a large
quantity of ammunition
meanwhile
residents in the city of ottawa continue
to be subjected to what has now been
weeks of unlawful behavior that has
challenged the capacities of local law
enforcement and closed local businesses
in recent days ottawa residents have
taken to the streets themselves in order
to prevent additional vehicles from
joining the occupation
the invoking of the emergencies act
sends a strong message to protesters
across the country
you've been heard
stop hurting this nation
it's time to go home please
and if you
are a company owner and your truck is
being used in a in an illegal blockade
it's time to put it back on the road
so it may serve a better more productive
purpose thank you madam speaker
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for yellowhead
thank you madam speaker and thank you to
my honorable colleague for her
statements i have to ask the question
though i mean in your speech you're
basically implying that there's
terrorism and terrorism acts that have
been performed or are going to be
insinuated throughout this you and your
fellow colleagues have always talked
about this
all questions and comments uh to the
chair through the chair uh and not
directly to the member the only member
for yellowhead thank you madam uh madam
speaker as i was saying with their acts
of terrorism or the type of terrorist
activities but what proof has actually
been brought forward we have never been
talked about this and we never told
about this
that's where i'm questioning what
information has this member not been
sharing with the public or with even her
fellow members of this caucus
when you hold a city hostage when you
hold its people hostage
and you try to compel
change through force and violating the
rights of others
that is terrorism
when you scare people you honk
throughout the night they are confined
to their homes there's a women's shelter
where women who already victims of abuse
have suffered trauma
are terrified to go outside
this is pretty much the definition
our city is being held hostage
and this is no way to ask for change
there is peaceful protest there is legal
protest
and this
that's not it
thank you
is
[Music]
in
[Applause]
no one was able to move these wellington
wellingtons
unless you have the floor um i would ask
members to be very respectful of those
who have the floor if you have questions
and comments wait for me to ask you if
you have uh if if it's time for
questions and comments wait for me to uh
to put that question to the floor
honourable member
speaker um
[Music]
thank you madam speaker and thank you to
the member for your intervention as i
helped my neighbor recently pleading to
the occupiers that have held residence
in ottawa hostage back into her home she
said to me nothing i do matters nobody
cares and nobody is helping
unfortunately i could not say anything
to ease her concerns it should have
never come to this a lack of clear
leadership on the part of this
government is why we are here today
workers have lost wages
businesses have shut down and residents
of ottawa's health and well-being has
declined does the member agree that we
could have avoided where we are today if
the liberals had shown immediate and
clear leadership from the onset
a brief answer from the member from
dorwan nassar i thank my colleague for
her question she's raised some very
important points
[Music]
we respected
jurisdiction and as the prime minister
said
if he were to be asked for additional
help he would give it he was asked and
he gave it and this is as quickly as our
government could have acted
and i really really hope that everybody
can get on board with this and realize
that things
need to be settled and people need to go
back to peaceful lives and they can
continue protesting legally and
peacefully but not the way it's
happening right now thank you
resuming debate
the honor member for calgary knows hill
thank you madam speaker
tonight i make an appeal to every
canadian we are a nation on the brink
our country has not been tested like
this in generation
after two long years that have tested
nearly every one of the societal systems
that sustain our peace health and
prosperity we have reached a tipping
point of confluent crises
many cannot afford food energy and
housing our health care system is broken
many have lost jobs and are struggling
with the burden of a loss of identity
and meaning that comes from work
many are struggling with children who
have had more days out of school than i
just want to uh interrupt the honourable
member because i i'm not sure if i
missed it because i was sidetracked but
i'm just wondering if the honourable
member had mentioned that she was
splitting her time
yes the member from fundy royal thank
you i'm sorry i didn't hear it at the
beginning uh they don't remember
and many are struggling with barriers
magnified over the last two years like
racism misogyny bigotry and poverty
and all of us admitted or not are
struggling with the trauma that comes
from the loss of personal control that
happens when our freedoms are restricted
when trust in government institutions
and democratic systems are eroded when
we are in conflict with one another and
when there is a lack of clarity on when
or if life will ever return to what it
once was
and most of us are guilty of finding so
soulless in social media algorithms
politicians and news outlets that
discourage us from finding common
grounds with one another while rewarding
us when we calcify or radicalize our
beliefs
and so to the convoy in front of
parliament hill let me be clear
protests can be peaceful but still break
the law and the blockade occurring in
downtown ottawa is breaking the law
trucks have never been allowed to
legally be parked in the middle of a
major thoroughfare or on the ambassador
bridge or on the middle of border
crossings to those of you who are
illegally blockading public
infrastructure the law must be respected
move out do not afford the federal
government
to attempt to justify the use of the
emergencies act with recalcitrance
to those who don't believe covid
restrictions should come to an end let
me also be clear as one of my liberal
colleagues stated last week not everyone
can work from the comfort of home
precious few of the class of politicians
and bureaucrats who have been making the
decisions to extend restrictions with no
plan to do the heavy lifting of fixing
the broken systems that have have
actually experienced the conditions of
frontline workers in canada over the
last two years
if you cannot find empathy and common
ground with the people who bear the
burden of your restrictions then you
have lost the authority to be in your
position be better and rise to the
occasion
and to those who would inflame these
frustrations and divisions with rhetoric
outright lies diversions borderline
slander conspiracy uncompassionate
behavior and hate for your own political
or personal gain as
leading us through the breach as instead
of leading us through the breach for
shame
left or right we will resist you with
critical thinking understanding and
radical compassion
to those who had used these frustrations
and division to preach violence against
leaders front-line workers and to those
who don't share your brand a rigid
worldview for shame left or right right
or left we will resist you with the law
and with courage
and to those who would use these
frustrations and divisions to suggest
that our democracy should be overthrown
or thrown out for shame
left or right right or left we will
resist you by fighting to protect our
democratic system strengthening it and
cherishing it and so to the matter at
hand the historic and unprecedented
decision of a prime minister of our
nation to invoke the emergencies act
a representative democracy only survives
when it can demonstrate to the people
who put the trust of their liberties
into it that their voices will be heard
due process will be given and the
independence of the judiciary will be
held parliament will reign supreme and
that the rule of law will be maintained
over the last several years we have
witnessed the federal government attempt
to take the speaker of the house of
commons to court the firing of canada's
solicitor general over refusals to
interfere
interfere in the independence of the
judiciary
the suspension of parliament massive
spending with minimal scrutiny hiding of
documents delayed freedom to information
requests underfunded auditors and more
and we have seen federal copied
restrictions extended with no metrics or
end game not once has this government
demonstrated that it will give back the
power that it took from the people of
canada and for that reason the emergency
act in the hands of this government
should be opposed
the federal government has not
demonstrated to canadians that existing
laws and measures which are bound by
judicial oversight are not sufficient to
end the illegal blockades that is there
is no evidence that we cannot end
illegal blockades without the use of the
emergencies act
in ottawa systemic failures of local law
enforcement and delayed reaction by all
levels of government likely has led us
to this juncture however the federal
government has not made a compelling
case that the suspending of normal
democratic processes via the emergency
act is necessary to resolve the
situation
the reality is the federal government
went from doing virtually nothing about
the crisis to invoking the nuclear
option that is the emergencies act at a
time when they are asking canadians to
trust them they are not providing
briefings to parliamentarians on the
situation or what action they have or
haven't taken
there are many existing laws that could
be used by the federal government but
they have not explained why or how they
are not sufficient which undermines the
arguments of proportionality for example
while many liberal partisans will say we
can't direct the police the fact is that
the federal government very much can
offer direction to both the rcmp and the
public prosecution service of canada the
section 5 of the rcmp act states that
the government governor
in council may appoint an officer to be
known as the commissioner of the
canadian
royal canadian mounted police to hold
office during pleasure etc this section
actually provides this type of direction
in another example minister of justice
and attorney general has the power to
direct the director of public
prosecutions under section 10 of the
director of public prosecution act
the federal government also has the
authority under section 273.6
of the national defense act to issue
directions authorizing the canadian
forces to provide assistance in respect
of any law enforcement matter if the
governor and council or the minister as
the case may be
looks at several considerations
all of this is to say that the federal
government had multiple legal options
when it came to showing some leadership
to put an end to this crisis through law
enforcement and prosecutorial means
instead the liberals chose to go
straight to the emergency act without
justification to parliament in fact
blockades at the ambassador bridge and
the kloots crossing were resolved prior
to its invocation this lack of clarity
is reason enough for opposition
the liberals insist that these measures
are compliant with the charter of rights
and freedoms as the emergency act itself
states that any temporary measures must
be compliant with the charter and bill
of rights however many civil liberties
advocates and experts have already
expressed concerns that the oic the
order and council has many issues with
the respect with respect to the right of
canadians to peacefully assemble under
section 2 the right of all canadians to
life liberty and security of person
under section 7 for example how can you
conscript towing companies without
violating their liberty and protections
under against unreasonable search and
seizure under section 8 how can you
freeze assets or report transactions
without
violating this section
the liberals argue that all such
violations are reasonable limits and
justifiable under section 1 as a pro as
proportionate to the objective of
clearing the blockades the issue with
section 1 arguments is that these
matters are for the courts to determine
through well-established legal processes
like the oaks test all of this could
take much longer time than the emergency
act could be in effect but would have an
impact on the actions taken while it was
to justify the use of the act the
liberals should table a charter
statement to further explain their
reasoning as to why and how they're
proposing what they're proposing is
charter compliant the fact that they
have not done this
is reason to oppose the act
further to date the liberals have not
engaged the privacy commissioner to
demonstrate how canadians right to
privacy will be maintained today i wrote
to the commissioner to ask him to begin
an inquiry into this matter
the illegal blockades in ottawa must end
the escalation of rhetoric and tension
in our country must end
covet restrictions must end and a path
forward to empower and inspire canadians
coming in coming through the brokenness
of the last two years is what we should
be focused on at this juncture not
extending government power over the
people of canada without jurisdiction
our justification
madam speaker this is an unprecedented
use of power in canada
we should be looking for every way
possible to de-escalate this situation
as was done at the ambassador bridge as
was done at the coots border process
crossing using existing processes the
use of the act should never be
normalized and in debate today i fear it
is becoming so
our nation needs hope
we need to come together
and further extending the power of the
federal government without scrutiny
without use of the oversight by the
judiciary is something that will not
heal these divisions and for that reason
madame speaker i believe the acts should
be disbo opposed
i call on every canadian watching this
tonight to come together in uni unity
and move forward through the crisis of
the pandemic thank you madam speaker
questions and
comments the honorable prime minister
secretary kerry to the government house
leader thank you madam seeker i'd like
to read a quote
um the quote is
what we have seen in the the occupation
of ottawa and blockages at border
crossings is not the right of protests
enshrined in our constitution but
illegal activity that represents a
national security and economic threat to
canada that is a quote from february
14th from peter mckay
previous member of parliament as i'm
sure this member knows very well i'm
curious if she can comment as to whether
or not she agrees with peter mckay's
assessment of what's going on
the member for calgary knows him
minister former minister mckay was faced
with many national crises and many uh
any many instances when he had to
use his power as a minister to help
de-escalate situations in the country
that is the exact opposite of what this
government has done at this juncture
instead of trying to seize power from
canadians we should be trying to give it
back to them that doesn't mean that
these blockades shouldn't end they
should the federal government should be
assisting law enforcement in doing so
but instead of it looking at ways to
de-escalate the situation and give power
back to canadians this government is
doing the opposite and for that reason
this act should be opposed
to the honorable members
of the scope
earlier this weekend
does my colleagues
yes madam speaker
we should be finding ways to de-escalate
tension and try to find common ground
instead of using division and
escalation of tension for personal or
political gain this is something that
has happened far too long in this
country and it needs to stop our country
is at a breaking point right now we need
to figure out how to make people
have hope how to feed them how to fix
our broken health care system that's
what people are looking us to us for the
use of the emergencies act is
unprecedented and unnecessary it does
not secure our democracy in fact it
erodes it
and for that i will be opposing it
questions and comments you'll remember
from it
i'd like to thank the member from
calgary nose hill for her statement
uh
yesterday we heard from the member
opposite that the emergency act was not
needed to settle the rail blockades of
2020 the oca crisis or the crisis at
caledonia
these are not comparable to today's
realities
the emergency emergencies act is a
drastic measure
for the sole purpose of protecting our
safety okatiti for the last three weeks
continuing to today our safety continues
to be threatened we have heard today
from her party
in a way that i interpret them as trying
to minimize the dangers being posed by
these extremists can the member explain
why they chose to ign ignore these
extremist behavior and continue to put
canadian safety at risk for enemy
the honourable member for calgary knows
hill
we need to respect the right of
indigenous and first nations persons in
canada
at this juncture
i believe that the illegal blockades in
ottawa must end i said that throughout
my speech i also outlined how the
federal government could be using many
of the tools that are
at its disposal or could have used it in
the past to do so but instead chose the
nuclear option of the emergencies act
this benefits no one this power grab
takes away
uh power from everyone in canada
including first nations and indigenous
persons we should not be supporting it
we should be trying to find ways to come
together to uphold the rule of law while
resolving our differences without giving
further power to the government of
canada
resuming debate
well thank you madam speaker it's a
privilege to be able to speak in this
house this evening on what is a very
important matter today we are debating
the unprecedented measures this
government is taking by invoking the
never before used emergencies act i want
to be clear that i'm not arguing that
there's no place in law for the
emergencies act what i'm arguing and
many others of course is that it is a
completely disproportionate tool to
effectively deal with these protests and
that the government's rationale for
using it has way too many plot holes to
even begin to enumerate the predecessor
legislation to the emergencies act
the war measures act was used only three
times
once in world war one once in world war
ii
and then in the flq crisis in the 70s in
order to even think about invoking the
emergencies act we have to look at the
context in which its predecessor
legislation was used and how rare in
fact it was implemented number one there
has to be a national emergency and we
look at how the act itself defines a
national emergency the act describes a
national emergency as an urgent and
critical situation of a temporary
measure
now we all know that the protests are
not an urgent and critical situation of
a temporary measure i'm sure that the
prime minister would have jumped into
action 20 days ago
if that was indeed the case
regarding the acts requirement that a
national emergency be of a temporary
measure well that part i can agree with
because the situation has been so
temporary in fact that all of the
blockades at international border
between canada and the u.s have already
been cleared before
the emergency act was ever implemented
completely without the benefit of this
legislation the definition goes on to
say that a national emergency seriously
endangers the lives health or safety of
canadians and is of such proportions or
nature as to exceed the capacity or
authority of a province to deal with it
let's be honest madam speaker the
truckers parked outside of parliament
today do not seriously endanger the
lives of canadians and again when it
comes to international border crossings
the provinces have both the capacity and
the authority to bring that to the end
and indeed they already have the act
goes on to describe a national emergency
as one that seriously threatens the
ability of the government of canada to
preserve the sovereignty security and
territorial integrity of canada that
cannot be effectively dealt with under
the any other law of canada if an
emergency does not fit that description
then the emergencies act is not to be
used if a few hundred parked trucks pose
a threat to the preservation of the
sovereignty and security of canada one
of the greatest countries in the world a
g7 country
that's a sobering testament of this
government's
dismal and failed leadership leaving our
country so vulnerable that its very
existence could be called into question
by a group of protesters on wellington
street i think it's very clear to all
members in this house when we look at
this
through the vantage point that we have
of being here in ottawa that the
threshold for a national emergency
simply
has not been met but for argument's sake
let's say that the prime minister and
his entire liberal caucus truly and
sincerely believe that the trucks parked
on the street just outside these doors
are a real emergency requiring
unprecedented action from the federal
government to that i would just have to
say what a sad state of affairs if this
is what an emergency looks like to this
liberal government what incredibly
privileged lives they must leave when i
think of the the dealings that my own
constituents in fundy royal have had
over the past two years facing dire uh
ramifications and consequences of
lockdowns back home an emergency looks
like a gym owner who's lost their
business after two years of personal
sacrifices in hopes of keeping their
business afloat an emergency can look
like the single mom who's lost her job
because of this government's vaccine
mandate and then had that same
government tell her cruelly that she
couldn't collect employment insurance
ultimately liberals are trying to use
unprecedented emergency powers
to respond to an event that doesn't even
meet the threshold of a national
emergency as described in the act itself
but while the emergency the liberals say
they are trying to address is not an
actual emergency the consequences and
infringements on the civil liberties
that we so dearly hold as canadians and
our rights as canadians the consequences
are very real the canadian civil
liberties association has stated
yesterday that the government has not
met the threshold necessary to invoke
the emergencies act they also warn of
the threat facing our democracy and
civil liberties that if the emergencies
act is inappropriately applied as it
clearly is in this case the bc civil
liberties association just today
called on liberal members
and all members of this house to vote
against this and to revoke for the prime
minister to revoke the emergencies act
crisis that we faced as a nation without
invoking the war measures act or the
emergency act include in 1990 the oka
crisis a 78-day standoff between mohawk
protesters and law enforcement and the
canadian armed forces in 2006 when a
group of extremists now known as the
toronto 18 plotted to carry out violent
attacks here on parliament hill
in 2010 when the g20 protest turns to
riots in canada's largest city causing
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
property damages toronto's chief of
police at the time was none other other
than the liberal minister of emergency
preparedness currently and it wasn't
invoked on october 22nd 2014 when many
members of this house will remember
a terrorist attack on parliament hill
and on the war memorial which killed
corporal nathan cirillo before center
block itself was stormed these were
serious and at times fatal incidents
that were entirely more dangerous and
destructive than the truckers parked
outside the government invoking the
emergencies act at this time just does
not add up the emergency act bypasses
the democratic process we cannot become
complacent and allow these unprecedented
powers to become a tool of government to
shut down dissent that it doesn't like
civil liberties the rule of law and
democratic norms are never guaranteed
these principles require constant
vigilance to defend canada was built on
the foundation of these principles and
we cannot allow cracks to form two days
ago
i met with a man who immigrated to
canada from romania he had tears in his
eyes and he said this is a sad day for
me he lost his father to the romanian
regime under a brutal dictator and he
came to canada in hopes to find freedom
and he recognizes coming from a
totalitarian regime
where you are persecuted
perhaps for your political beliefs he
recognizes what he sees here
it's hard to imagine what it must feel
like to live in a country where you're
not allowed to think or speak freely
under the threat of persecution but this
gentleman i spoke with knows it all too
well and to see the division being sold
by this prime minister
and the great lengths he is going to
stomp out dissenting opinions is much
too familiar
that's what this is the prime minister
is trying to eradicate any opinions that
don't match his this is a political
crisis for the prime minister the prime
minister's instinct unfortunately we've
all seen it in this house over and over
as recently as yesterday his instinct is
to divide we know that not everyone who
disagrees with this government is a
racist a misogynist or a white supremist
but it's a lot better for him if
everybody thinks that just yesterday in
this house the prime minister accused a
young jewish member of parliament of
standing with swastikas you may be
wondering what triggered him to make
such a disgusting statement the member
from thornhill had dared to ask the
prime minister when he lost his way
since he stated in 2015
that if canadians are going to trust
their government their government needs
to trust canadians it speaks volumes
that pointing out his own hypocrisy sent
the prime minister into this rage
the prime minister has no problem
joining in protests that are promoting
ideology ideology that he agrees with we
all know this in this house when when he
agrees with it it would be a good look
for his brand then he's there but now
that the protests don't align with his
views he's going for the nuclear option
by invoking the emergencies act the
thing about being the leader of a free
and fair democracy like canada is that
you don't get to pick and choose who
gets to speak out and on what issues the
prime minister does not get to
unilaterally suppress
civil liberties of people he doesn't
like that madam speaker is what
dictators do
all canadians should be concerned by the
actions of this prime minister and his
liberal government all canadians should
be concerned when a group is targeted by
the federal government for their
political beliefs and indeed all
canadians should be concerned by the
precedent being set by this government
and i will be proud to vote in
opposition to this government overreach
thank you
[Applause]
so the point of order uh the honorable
government whip
uh sorry the honorable uh
whip of the official opposition
well i i like the way you think
madam speaker so
madam speaker in accordance with
standing order 43 to a i would like to
indicate that the remaining conservative
party of canada caucus speaking slots
are hereby divided by two
the honourable member for is that a
point of order
oh okay i thought it was a point of
order sorry i heard point of order okay
uh
the honorable parliamentary secretary to
the minister of families children and
social development
thank you madam speaker and uh
i've heard the words of my colleague on
the other side of the floor and so i
have a few questions
um as a jewish member of parliament
myself and a descendant of survivors of
the holocaust as well
i like many canadians were shocked to
see nazi flags confederate flags
dismayed and angry and hurt
horribly hurt
so how many nazi flags does it take
how many donors from the capital riots
it's eleven hundred and counting
who have donated to these illegal
blockades
how many guns
need to be seized
how much vitriol
do we have to see of hong kong which is
an acronym for hail hitler
do we need to see by these
protesters on social media
how much
how many
times do we have to see clear indicators
that what is out there
is not about the hard two years that
every canadian has suffered
but is it about something much deeper
and darker and uglier that is
threatening the stability of this house
the work that we do as legislators each
and every day for our constituents
the democracy that we have to uphold
when will it be an emergency for you and
your colleagues across the honourable
member uh knows full well that she needs
to address the questions that comes to
the chair and i've been trying to single
her because there's other people who
need to ask questions as well so the
honorable member for fundy royal
well thanks madam speaker and clearly
all members in this house
denounce any anti-semitism in all of its
kind but when we look out when i look at
the people that have come here to
protest and we've conservatives have
been saying
that it's time to move on it's time for
the trucks to go we've been saying that
but what is very clear is the
emergencies act is an absolutely
inappropriate tool seizing the bank
accounts
of individuals that you disagree with
because of their political beliefs it's
unprecedented and it's wrong
emergency
is
[Music]
is
thank you
yes thank you madam speaker i thank the
honorable colleague for his question
absolutely the the prime minister at one
point said measures like this should be
a last resort but in fact in this case
it's been his first resort he did
nothing to de-escalate inc in fact as
many people have said he's thrown
gasoline on embers this is something
that at all the border crossings are
open the protest here in ottawa i walk
amongst the protesters every night on my
way uh from this place back to my
apartment and they have been peaceful
everyone in this house knows that
they've been peaceful so this is an
inappropriate tool to use on a peaceful
protest
uh questions and comments i have a time
for a brief question the honorable
member for churchill kiwanis ascii
thank you madam speaker well to that
final comment uh it's clear that ottawa
residents uh would disagree completely
residents that have been the targets of
um
racist misogynistic homophobic attacks
uh from uh from people involved in this
illegal occupation let's be clear it's
lasted as long as it has in part because
of the way in which conservatives
including the conservative leader have
aided and abetted this illegal
occupation just today uh we heard from
news media that a conservative mp was
giving the thumbs up
to uh members of this illegal occupation
what will it take for conservatives to
condemn the illegal occupation
occupation and uh
and to take a stand against those that
want to overthrow democracy and
movements led by white supremacists
before i go to the answer i just want to
maybe um ask the honorable member that
maybe next time she wants to ask a
question that she adjust her mic because
we were getting a lot of feedback from
it um the honorable friend of royal
brief answer please thank you man
speaker a lot of people in this house
seem to be confused something doesn't
have to if something's an emergency or
an inconvenience or something that you
want to change or something you disagree
with that is a matter of debate but the
fact of the matter is to enact the
emergency act the territorial integrity
the security and sovereignty of canada
has to be at risk no one can seriously
claim that the protest on wellington
street is impacting the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of our country
if it is then we have bigger problems
than we think
[Applause]
resuming debate
represents
resuming debate
the honourable member for spanish golf
violence
okay i just want to remind members that
if they don't stand up i can't
acknowledge them because i don't know
that they actually want to speak
madam speaker i apologize for not for
not rising i'm still
working on my new knees uh i'm
honored to rise tonight on one of the
most important debates we've had in this
place
in the time that i've been a member of
parliament i'm extremely
i'm on the horns of dilemma madam
speaker first i want to acknowledge that
i'm standing in the traditional
territory of the people of the
algonquin
nation
and acknowledge that that
their patience intolerance with us is
indeed generous and i say mcglinch
this is a very difficult debate and it's
difficult for many reasons
and one of them for me is that i have
not yet decided how i will vote neither
has my parliamentary colleague from
kitchener center
we are
looking deeply at the emergencies act
the implications of it
the
downsides which are evident
and the need for which remains a
question
i i want to say that this is going to be
more legalistic than usual madam speaker
i'm essentially going to go through an
exercise of statutory interpretation
and compare it with the facts and see
where we are so i'm actually grappling
with two questions tonight um you know
how how do we vote but also how do we
analyze the legal questions
um i think in this debate today and over
i know from 7 a.m till midnight tomorrow
the day after and the day after and part
of monday
we are going to hear debate which is
not grounded in statutory interpretation
but in which a lot of emotion and a lot
of charges and counter charges will be
heard
both sides have generously fastened this
debate already with wedge issues and red
herrings and i think his canadians and
certainly the citizens of this country
need to know what we're talking about
and i'll do my best to bring it home
the first question is well what is the
emergencies act
i i it's very important to say that it
is not
the war measures act
the war measures act as used by the
current prime minister's father pierre
trudeau and the flq crisis
was an egregious violation of rights and
freedoms right across the country it was
a suspension of civil liberties
everywhere all at once it was directed
against people of quebec even people
with no connection whatsoever to
anything radical but merely political
opponents of the government of the day
who were rounded up there was an
official apology in the last session of
parliament
we understand
that
by the way when the war measures act was
invoked in the 1970s police in vancouver
rode into peace camps and started
beating people up because civil
liberties were gone right across canada
you didn't need to have a reason
this is not that
this is the response uh the work that i
would have to say impresses me
of reflective parliamentarians gathered
in 1980s when they had no imminent
emergency
to which they had to respond
they looked at public welfare like a
pandemic well how would we respond to
that would we need the emergencies act
and what kind of emergency would it be
they looked at war they looked at
natural disasters and they looked at
this which is what the government has
invoked the declaration that we're
debating tonight is out of the public
order emergency category
but when they did that they made it
clear
this act by its very language means the
military can't be called in
by its very language it says the charter
of rights and freedoms will be honored
and
very much unlike the war measures act it
creates parliamentary oversight part of
which we're doing here tonight that
within seven sitting days of the
government any government
using its declaration for an emergency
parliament must debate the matter and
vote
and parliament will have a committee to
continue to oversee what takes place
under the emergencies act to make sure
it conforms to the law
20 members of parliament and 10 senators
at any time during the 30-day life of
this emergency declaration can gather
and request that we debate this again
and vote again
so in a minority parliament this does
suggest that the executive in other
words the cabinet and the prime minister
do not have the power to call the
emergencies active obviously they've
done the declaration it's in effect
right now but there's parliamentary
oversight something that was not present
under the war measures act
this is described as a public order
emergency and what that means under the
emergencies act
is quote
an emergency that arises from threats to
the security of canada
and both things must be met and that is
so serious as to be a national emergency
now in in analyzing this definition
it turns out that the words threat to
the security of canada are not the words
that one might take as a plain meaning
that we think through for ourselves
what's a threat to security no it's it's
specifically described as being the
meaning that you would find in the
canadian security intelligence service
act so you go to another act to find the
definition for threats to the security
of canada
this is fascinating and i think i may be
the first one to mention this threats to
the security of canada in the canadian
security intelligence service act is
defined with four heads to describe it
to save time i'll read only b because i
think that's the one that most applies
in this circumstance
includes threats of security of canada
means
foreign influenced activities
within or relating to canada that are
detrimental to the interests of canada
and are clandestine or deceptive or
involve a threat to any person
now
the second part of that definition that
we get from the emergencies act itself
says that not only must it be a threat
to the security of canada such as the
one i just read out in the definition
from the security intelligence service
act it must also be so serious as to be
a national emergency
national emergency we go back to the
emergencies act national emergency which
people have references house is an
urgent and critical situation of a
temporary nature
that a seriously endangers the lives
health or safety of canadians and is of
such proportions or nature as to exceed
the capacity or authority of a province
to deal with it
or
not both or seriously threatens the
ability of the government of canada to
preserve sovereignty security and
territorial integrity of canada so the
question here is has that test been met
has that threshold been met
and
that takes further interpretation based
on the facts
i personally and i found this in the
declaration itself
uh so the government is also troubled by
this and troubled by the foreign
influence aspect of what we're seeing
across canada
the declaration which we're debating
tonight includes this point
quote the protests have become a
rallying point for anti-government and
anti-authority
anti-vaccination conspiracy theory and
white supremacist groups throughout
canada and other western countries the
protesters have varying ideological
grievances with demands ranging from an
end to all public health restrictions to
the overthrow of the elected government
now madam speaker
that does seem very consistent with our
first question is this a threat to the
security of canada under the meaning of
the canadian security intelligence
service act
foreign influenced activities within or
related to canada that are detrimental
to the interests of canada such as
blocking access to trade blocking
communities shutting down communities
and are they clandestine or deceptive
you bet if the money is coming from
overseas and people use anonymous email
addresses and they send money into
canada
for the purpose of disrupting our nation
now what is that purpose where do we
find further evidence of what foreign
influence might be attempting to to
attempting
to
visit on canada but also on other
political regimes
this is from today's associated press
how american cash for canada's protests
would sway us politics and in this a
series of journalists working for
associate press make the case that this
convoy and the various protests across
canada under the banner of freedom
convoys
is quote really aimed
at energizing conservative politics in
the u.s
and elsewhere republicans think says the
article standing with protesters up
north will galvanize fundraising and
voter turnout for the midterm elections
no wonder we have such luminaries of the
of the far right
south of the border as texacan
republican ted cruz and georgian
representative marjorie taylor greene
calling the protesters in canada and not
ju
heroes
heroes and patriots
they are the darlings of fox news right
now
and senator rand paul says quote he
hopes that truckers come to the united
states and clog up their cities
in other words i think one aspect of
what ray raised this to the level of
national emergency is that it also has
tentacles that longer it goes on here
the more it's intended to inspire
disruption in other economies including
our number one trading partner
does it rise to the level of a national
emergency
this is a harder one for me does it rise
to the level of a national emergency we
have seen blockades being removed they
were geographically easier there were
fewer people the logistics of the
ambassador bridge compared to what's
going on right now outside this place
and i will disagree with colleagues in
this place who said if we're here in
parliament that means it's safe that is
not the case
friends of mine in this place and
members of their staff have had feces
thrown at them as they go back and forth
to work we've had people yell at us and
abuse us as we try to go through the
streets and be that at the moment i'm
someone with a disability i can't get
here at all without protective service
protection and assistance so no it is
not our usual parliament hill we do not
feel safe here and and going back to the
uh well going to the next point of
evidence that i want to bring before us
i'm very concerned about the nature of
our safety and security here we are not
just any city in canada we are the
national capital and we have attracted a
certain type
of and i'm not going to put a broad
brush on everybody who showed up in
ottawa to support the convoy there are
clearly people who are there thinking
it's sort of like a street party there
are people there who are not politically
radicalized but
the thread that runs through all of this
is a radicalization with an inherent
threat of violence that came forward
more clearly than anything
from
the guardian today
a very
chilling article by a canadian reporter
who i must say i've known for years but
my goodness jason justin ling is
distinguishing himself in this crisis as
someone who actually goes out and does
reporting digs up information
today in the guardian
here's the headline
canada was warned before the protest
began that violent extremists had
infiltrated the convoy now the
honourable member for medici medicine
hat carson warner made this point
earlier today
to excuse the protests he said it's not
their fault they were infiltrated
exactly exactly
now according to the article in the
guardian today from canadian journalist
justin ling
quote assessments of the canada's
integrated terrorism assessment center
known as itac
which includes the security intelligence
service canada
cesas
itec reported before the convoy got near
ottawa that quote the convoy organizers
advocate quote unquote advocate civil
war
convoy organizers hold up the u.s
january 6 insurrection against
a
fair
democratic election promoting the lie
that trump was
the election was trump's and it was
stolen from him
they hold that up as their model the
thesis and the
i-tech warned according to justin ling
warned the city of ottawa police that
this was the nature of what was coming
down ottawa it wasn't a secret
they left with great fanfare to drive
across the country and when this is all
over we'll have to find out what
happened within the chain of command in
the ottawa police to ignore these
warnings
some officers not all necessarily all
but welcomed the convoy there are
reports from uh local uh ottawa
journalists that when they interviewed
truck drivers they said well we only
plan to stay a little while but then the
police told us we could go park on
wellington we wouldn't have to leave for
a very long time
none of this had those truckers not been
truckers but indigenous people coming to
assert rights on indigenous territory
they wouldn't have been allowed to get a
single
stick into the ground to construct a
single thing before being arrested quite
quickly have they been people of color
have they been environmentalists or my
goodness look at how we treat camps of
homeless people moving in brutally they
didn't need the emergencies act to knock
over lots of homeless people in lots of
brutal police takedowns well
we know right now
that there is
an intention on the part of many of
these convoy participants to not leave
i don't want to worry about every social
media crank that puts things up on
twitter
but i know
that freedom convoy social media says
get downtown to victoria we're going to
take the legislature and we're not going
to lose and we're not going to leave
until all the mandates are gone forget
public health advice we are going to
demand that the government goes the
mandates go who knows
it also was reported in this article
about
warnings from itac
that they thought that the use of
vehicles trucks
fuel could present a real significant
threat of violence and all too often
those of us here in parliament have
wondered and asked other security forces
does anyone know what's in all those
trucks
we don't know
so i think we have clearly
a situation that has allowed to become
intolerable
and dangerous
but i'm still not comfortable voting for
the motion and i'll tell you why
the emergency measures regulations as
described are overly broad
when the prime minister said this was
coming forward he said it would be
geographically circumscribed to the
specific areas where we see
that were the normal authority lines of
authority protections for public life
and health
are missing
we have an emergency that's clear
but why does this which was promised to
be very limited and specific the
emergencies measure regulations
define infrastructure as basically
everything
and then say this applies right across
canada this designation of protected
places under section uh six of the
regulations
is far too broad and applies for all of
canada
now
that is a concern i have i also know
that i've heard many people ask
we need clarity
at what level of financial donation or
financial support of illegal activities
does your bank account get seized
i highly doubt
that the government of canada plans to
seize the bank account of anyone who
made a 20 donation on gofundme to the
freedom convoy i doubt it i think we're
looking for proximate
connection the kind that will exert the
pressure that makes the convoy go away
where's the pressure points insurance
finances
registration chance to make your living
as a trucker when this is all over i
don't think they intend to go after a 20
bank account but i have not heard them
say that
i am not comfortable voting until i see
more clarity that circumscribes the
overly broad reach of the regulations
i'll also say that i hear from many many
people virtually all the time how do we
know that this won't establish a
precedent that allows a crackdown on
civil liberties i want to read one more
section into the record very
specifically
for this is from the canadian security
intelligence services act in the
definition that has been transplanted
into the motion we're debating tonight
what is a threat to the security of
canada and it says at the bottom of the
paragraph of which i've only read
subsection b
it does not include lawful advocacy
protest or dissent unless carried on in
conjunction with any of the activities
referred to above so i feel quite secure
if the emergencies if i'm again and i
don't plan to get arrested again it
wasn't fun i was way outside my comfort
zone and the judge hated me so i got a
much more significant fine than my
friend who's now the mayor of vancouver
uh
i don't plan to go out to get arrested
again i believe that non-violent civil
disobedience is a vital part of our
democracy
it has its roots all the way back to
henry david thoreau in the 1800s it was
then picked up by the exemplar of
non-violent civil disobedience mahatma
gandhi
and then taken up by martin luther king
there are reasons that in a democracy we
must have peaceful protest
and
the right and the ability to break the
law if you believe that law to be unjust
but that does not include the right to
destroy other people's lives and
livelihoods in the process that does not
include a right
to in your own actions refuse to take
the consequences refuse to say i will go
quietly with you officer
that's the essence of what i did when i
performed nonviolent civil disobedience
what my colleague the honorable minister
of environment did when before he was in
office he also believed that something
as important as the survival of life on
earth in the climate crisis was worth
giving up
your own sense of safety by submitting
yourself to arrest
these are complicated matters and
complicated questions and i would beg of
all of us we must listen to each other i
am so concerned that so many of my
constituents believe this is actually a
peaceful protest out there
they think it is
there's nothing peaceful about
hunks of metal taking over your city
trucks do not have charter rights
honking a horn as the judge said in
granting the injunction is not an
expression of free speech
these trucks should have been stopped
before they got anywhere near the center
of our national capital they weren't
that's what constitutes the emergency
but i need the government to show me
that the regulations will be tightened
up before i can vote for this
questions and comments the honorable
prime minister secretary to the
government to the minister of attorney
general
uh and
the attorney general sorry
thank you madam speaker and i'd like to
thank
i'd like to thank our colleague for the
very insightful uh presentation as as
always
and i i do uh just want to assure her uh
that um that the the oversight that
she's looking for the uh certainty that
she's looking for is certainly there
within the regulations
this is meant
to target individuals who are breaking
the law
and of course there's an issue of
proportionality as well as
reasonableness that's that's embedded in
in the regulation and i i do invite her
to to to reflect on that um it is
important to distinguish between
those who may have innocently uh or
donated um
without
the right intent and those uh who
obviously uh have have donated with the
intention of breaking the law so i i
just want to remind her that there is an
element of reason reasonableness that is
already embedded in in the regulation
the member stanislaus islands thank you
madam speaker i say to my honourable
colleague the promised secretary
read the emergency measures regulations
there is no certainty in here there is
no precision it's far too overbroad i
mean i i could read into the record
critical infrastructure and how it's
defined uh to include ports piers
lighthouses canals tramways bus stations
i mean this is this is not in any way
specific to the circumstance we're in
right now and that's what makes me uh
have have a good deal of
resistance to voting yes while i do
think we need to do more because we have
a current emergency
uh casting camaraderie member for
yorkton melville
thank you speaker and i appreciate my
members intervention tonight and
appreciate also the the pain that she's
in and certainly hope she's well soon
madam speaker the order and council
released by the government authorizes
the government to do the following and i
think this would certainly add to the
members concerns around certainty so i
will just uh quote what is in
the order and council
other temporary measures authorized
under section 19
of the emergencies act that are not yet
known so the government is authorizing
itself to do things that essentially ask
this house to hand him unlimited
authority and we've seen in the past in
matters such as the documents from the
winnipeg lab that the prime minister has
little or no respect for parliamentary
oversight the snc lavalon scandal again
demonstrating his lack of respect for
independence of our justice system so
how does she feel about adding that
particular section
of the ordering council to her list of
reasons why she would be very
apprehensive about supporting this
emergency act
the honorable spanish gulf islands thank
you to my colleague from yorkton
melville yeah i i think that the fact
that we have
the next i guess
friday saturday sunday most of monday we
have the opportunity over th what's been
a day today and over the next four or
five days the opportunity to find what's
wrong here in terms of what would make
members of parliament who understand
something must be done about what's
currently happened which is not that the
city police didn't have the original
jurisdiction which could have prevented
this but where we are now
is a entrenched
well-funded well-supported
effort to and successfully
shutting down the center of ottawa and i
feel successfully
menacing
the parliamentary procedures in this
place we have an opportunity through
this debate and i hope that government
members will come forward and say all
right that ordering council we didn't
mean but let's clarify this we're not
going to say that we have given
ourselves a blank check uh the member uh
from um
uh
one of the members for forgive me for
forgetting the writing name and i don't
want to say his name out loud made the
point from the ndp from quebec
that this
um
this is not a blank check
but
i think it could be tightened up so we
actually know exactly the limits of what
we're about to approve and they should
be geographically confined as well as
specific to the circumstances
[Music]
[Music]
is
sorry i've been trying to give the
arnold member a single there just uh so
we can get to other questions uh casinos
come out to audio member for winnipeg
center
madam speaker and i have to say madam
speaker of the last couple of days i've
heard uh first of all inaccurate and
complete anti-indigenous racism in the
rhetoric around what is going on outside
this is not a peaceful protest
this is an illegal occupation and to be
stigmatized within what's going on out
here is is absolutely damaging and
violent to indigenous people from across
this country i want to um
i read the honourable member something
very quickly
and it says it's from the um
guardian from arwa mahawi
and this is what she writes she says
there's a lot going on in the world
right now if you're not a canadian then
the protest in ottawa might not be
the the top things you're worried about
but i'm afraid you should be worried you
should certainly be paying attention
what's unfolding in ottawa is not a
grassroots protest that has
spontaneously erupted out of the
frustration of the local
local lorry drivers rather it is astro
and astroturf movement
one that creates an impression of
widespread grassroots support where
little exists funded by global networks
of highly organized far right groups and
amplified by facebook misinformation
machine
and i just want to end off we know that
the soldiers of oldham and the yellow
jackets are involved in this
they are posing a threat to our
democracy our democracy is under threat
so i'd like to uh madam speaker through
you caution the member
uh to refer to indigenous people as
examples when we're talking about an
alt-right
white supremacist movement
fueled and funded by the white
supremacist movement uh on the other
side i wonder if my honourable member
can agree that that is not a
the honourable member for spanish gulf
islands yeah thank you
my honorable colleague from winnipeg
center i made that point earlier today
to the member for regina cappell who was
trying to say that somehow it was
hypocritical that the government didn't
crack down on what suetan
peop whom he referred to as protesters
those were with suit and hereditary
chiefs with legal rights derived from
the constitution of this country and
supreme court of canada decisions
there's i couldn't agree more with what
she said and i'll just add nothing to it
except to say thank you thank the
honourable member for making those
points
and i would like to say thank you to the
honorable member for her speech which is
always eloquent i think we all learned a
little bit something from her today uh
quickly i'd like to ask
what
should a responsible leader prime
minister wait for before
uh declaring an emergency what kind of
egregious harm should befall a country
its citizens
before
we do something or do we stop it right
there thank you
the member for saanich girl violence
brief answer i feel as though the city
of ottawa and many canadians are in the
situation of a battered wife where the
police say but has has your husband used
a gun on you has he hurt you yet that we
are menaced by an occupation and we
don't want to wait any longer to have
this problem solved we found guns in
couts we know that this group has been
infiltrated by the alt-right global
network to which the honourable member
for winnipeg center referred earlier
resuming debate the owner member for
cowichan malahat langford
thank you so much madam speaker and i
wish to notify you that i will be
splitting my time with the honorable
member for london fanshawe
i think i'd like to start off by just
acknowledging that you know we have all
been two years into this pandemic and
frustrations are mounting people
certainly want to be able to get on with
their lives and to some
extent this has culminated what in what
we have seen over the last few weeks
but make no mistake madam speaker we
really do need as parliamentarians and
indeed as an entire country need to
acknowledge
the intense gravity of the situation
that we find ourselves in this truly is
a watershed moment in canadian political
history
because we are now as a house uh
being asked by the government to confirm
the declaration of public order
emergency that was proclaimed on
february the 14th of this week
now this is something that has never
happened before it is the first time
that this act has been invoked in this
way
and uh i like i'm suspect many members
of parliament and
receiving concerns from constituents
who who are concerned with this drastic
step and so i owe it to them to the
great constituents of couch and malahat
langford
to talk about this extraordinary time
and why we have found ourselves here
we need to have a serious conversation
about why we find ourselves in a place
where the inaction
of the emergencies act is suddenly a
necessary action
because madam speaker it should never
have come to this
the use of the emergencies act even the
consideration of using it it's an
acknowledgement that we have had a
failure of leadership from many
different levels of government
if you look at the citizens of ottawa
they have
rightly felt abandoned by their own
police
the provincial government has not been
there but more importantly the federal
government and that's what i'm here to
focus my remarks on because
we are now two and a half weeks into an
occupation
it might have started off with many
people joining this thinking it was a
protest and certainly
people have that cherished right in our
democracy that is that is a right that
is very fundamental to a
well-functioning democracy that that
citizens have the right
to peacefully assemble
and protest to make their views known
and to really push for
change but what we see in ottawa and
what we saw at many of canada's border
crossings
were not
protests they were not peaceful
assemblies
they were occupations
and they were blockades and they started
having very negative impacts
on residents
on small business owners
and workers
that is where the line was crossed madam
speaker
people in ottawa didn't feel safe in
their own homes
we saw reports of attempted arson in
some of the buildings
we know that people have been suffering
verbal abuse on a daily basis sometimes
it's been physical
they have had to deal with all sorts of
noise complaints of ongoing pollution
from idling trucks
the city of ottawa our national capital
has seen some of our most precious and
honored national monuments defiled
and in some cases
completely walked over it has been
completely unacceptable and from the
border blockades madam speaker that has
impacted far more people we know that
the trade between canada and the united
states
numbers in the millions of dollars every
single day
and
many we we had factories in southern
ontario that had to shut down this was
impacting families there we had indeed
many agricultural manufacturers
processors and producers out in the
prairies and indeed across canada who
were negatively impacted by the
blockades
this was having an impact on those
people
and
it's those people that we need to keep
our remarks focused on to answer the
question of why we are here today
suddenly debating the invocation of the
emergencies act
so madam speaker
the emergencies act of course was
first brought in as a piece of
legislation all the way back in 1988
and
pursuant to section 17
1 of that act
we have had a public order emergency
declared
by the liberal government
and so there are a few things that come
about as a consequence of this now the
government has the ability to designate
specific areas
and declare that any assemblies in those
areas will henceforth be unlawful so
this will include the downtown core of
ottawa so that the main thoroughfares
can be cleared of all those trucks and
so that the residents can get their
lives back it will also
include some of our critical
infrastructure notably our ports of
entry with the united states the windsor
ambassador bridge coots alberta and
emerson manitoba being the most recent
examples but we also saw disturbances
in vancouver and in other ports of entry
like sarnia
it is going to allow the federal
government to direct essential services
so such as tow trucks so mobilizing tow
trucks to help with clearing those
streets it's going to give
fintrac the ability to cover
crowdfunding
and also the federal government is going
to have the extraordinary power
of freezing commercial bank accounts and
personal bank accounts of people
who are funding these illegal
occupations it's a it's a very real
and extraordinary attempt to cut off the
funding that is
supplying
the occupation of ottawa and causing all
of this misery and of course it's going
to give the rcmp the power to come in
and act
as provincial police officers municipal
police officers and enforce their
respective laws
it must be made abundantly clear here
madam speaker because i i certainly have
personally wrestled with this about you
know
am i doing the right thing and
supporting this
and i think what
gives me
uh some level of comfort is that i want
to be very clear to the constituents of
couch and langford that this is not a
blank check
and that the powers that we are granting
to the government
will be carefully reviewed on an ongoing
basis
and i will not hesitate to withdraw my
support
if i feel the government is overstepping
its fines so by that madam speaker i
mean that the application of these
powers have to be specific
they must be in relation to
the disturbances that we are seeing the
blockades the occupation
they must be
only used in relation to those
and they must be quickly withdrawn once
we get back to a place where public
order has been restored
now it's taken a long time to get this
to this point and you know i'm very
proud of the fact that
my caucus colleagues in the ndp and i
have been trying to push the government
to take this seriously because the
warning signs were there from the
beginning
i as the public safety critic was able
to initiate a study at the standing
committee on public safety into
crowdfunding platforms and their
possible involvement in funding
movements like this
i also was able to move a successful
motion to call upon the rcmp the cbsa
the ontario provincial police and ottawa
police and the minister of public safety
to eventually come before our committee
to explain to our committee how we got
to this point
where was
why did we have such an intelligence
failure a lack of coordination over the
last two and a half weeks that got us to
the point where we now have to use the
sledgehammer that is the emergencies act
and of course i have to recognize my
colleague the member for new westminster
burnaby and his private members bill to
basically ban symbols of hate of which
we unfortunately have seen evidence of
in this occupation
also our leader was able to initiate an
emergency debate in the house of commons
so that we could give parliamentarians
that first opportunity
to focus on this
in my remaining minute madam speaker
because i know my time is drawing to a
close
i just want to say this
you know parliament
is where we make the laws of this
country
it is the pinnacle of our democracy and
every single
one of the 338 members who serve in the
house of commons
they were duly elected
to this place
to make laws to hold the government to
account on behalf
of their citizens in their writings and
to try and subvert that
is an affront to the people who
participated in our democracy and we
must uphold that cherished right
so
i will end by saying madam speaker that
it is with great
reluctance that we are going to be
giving our support to this emer to these
emergency powers but i can assure people
that we will not take our off the ball
and we will not hesitate to withdraw our
support
should any powers be used past their
intended purpose thank you
that's the only member of king's hands
speaker i'd like to thank my honorable
colleague for his remarks he and i have
the privilege of working together on the
agriculture committee i always find him
to be uh balanced to be reasonable and
to be quite elegant in his remarks i
didn't catch all of his speech but i did
catch the tail end but i've heard a lot
in this host particularly from black
quebecois members and conservative
members that they want to see more
leadership from the government of canada
and of course this member would know
that policing is inherently a municipal
jurisdiction provincial jurisdiction as
well and that really the role the
federal government would be to impose
some of the measures we've seen today
ultimately at the very last resort would
be to call in the army
can this member at least opine on what
he's heard from leadership i mean the
conservatives are calling for the
government to acquiesce to what the
protesters are calling for the bloc says
that this shouldn't apply in their
jurisdiction what does he think in terms
of leadership from the federal
government does he agree with this being
a step to give the tools to the
provinces and municipalities to
address the situation at hand
question uh sorry the honourable member
for cowichan malahat langford
well mr
sorry madam speaker i i appreciate the
question from my colleague and i do
enjoy serving at the agriculture
committee with him i i think what i
would say is
specifically with respect to the last
two and a half weeks is that history
will not be kind uh to municipalities to
the province and to the federal
government i think there was a failure
at all levels but the federal government
i think had an important role to bring
all of those separate pieces together
there was a failure in intelligence
there was a failure in coordination
and i it was like we were just asleep at
the switch in figuring out how bad this
was eventually going to become so yes
i'm glad that we are now taking this
important step to reassert control and
to give people their lives back so that
workers small businesses and residents
can actually enjoy
their lives again
questions and comments you'll remember
for king bonham
thank you very much madam speaker i've
been waiting a while to speak and i want
to speak on behalf of my constituents of
king vaughn i have been flabbergasted
today by the number of emails that i
have received from the constituents of
king vaughn and i'd like to share this
with the honorable member the freedom
convoy is not asking that people don't
wear masks if they choose to
they are not telling people not to get
vaccinated
if they choose to they are not telling
people to stay home if they feel safe
they should do
they are simply saying we should have
the freedom of choice to do what we feel
is best for us as individuals
that right that freedom is what our
brave and heroic veterans
fought for us in the wars this is the
right of our country to be free and
strong
i'd like his comments on that please
thank you the our member for cowichan
malahat langford
well madam speaker i mean i very
strongly do agree with individual rights
but we also have responsibilities that
come with those rights and the
responsibility we have as individuals
also goes beyond our personal selves but
to out to the larger community as a
whole
we have just gone through two years of
an incredibly deadly pandemic
and if you look at the success i know
we've had our failures but the success
that we have had
in dealing this with this disease with
in comparison with other jurisdictions
that have had a more libertarian
approach this has been about saving
lives and about making sure that we get
through this pandemic together there
have been tough choices that have been
had to make but
with that individual freedom comes a
greater responsibility to the community
as a whole so that's how i would answer
that question madam speaker
questions
[Music]
foreign
well very briefly madam speaker i would
say it's not a bank blank check because
if you read the act there is
considerable room for parliamentary
oversight and furthermore all it takes
is for 20 members of parliament to
indicate that they no longer wish to
have the application of this act if they
submit a letter we can initiate debate
and debate will conclude with a vote on
whether these powers should remain in
force so there is that strong
parliamentary democratic oversight and
like i said in my speech if i feel the
government is overstepping its bounds i
will not hesitate to withdraw my support
for this current course of action
resuming debate the honorary member for
london fanshawe
uh thank you madam
speaker it's with a heavy heart that i
rise today
and i feel that we are standing at a
crossroads
i have heard so much frustration and
disappointment from people in london
they are frustrated by this pandemic
that will soon mark its third
anniversary
people are frustrated that they have
sacrificed and struggled to help one
another they have done the work that we
asked them to do to keep people safe
and to them i want to say thank you
i want to tell folks in london that i
understand your frustration i'm tired of
this pandemic too and i share in the
wish for this to be over
but i also see the bigger picture here
madam speaker
people aren't just frustrated because of
pandemic this is much bigger than that
they are frustrated that even though
people are working harder than ever
sacrificing more and more their
government has offered less and less
there's a growing sense throughout
canada that our elected leaders aren't
listening and don't appreciate the
struggles of canadians
the protests that we have seen in our
streets in our communities are a symptom
of what of that frustration
it is understandable why someone would
feel like that because for years now
successive liberal and conservative
governments have asked canadians to do
more with less to pull yourself up by
your bootstraps when you don't even have
shoes
today many people feel that their
government has let them down especially
when they needed support the most
these last few years have been tough on
my community like so many but within
this last year we experienced the loss
of the assault family to an extremist
act of hatred and violence
and yet in spite of that i saw my
community come together in incredible
acts of love and kindness
and that's what i hold on to tonight
madam speaker i i grew up in a very
political household and watching my
mother at community meetings and
standing up for what she believed in
fighting for a better world it truly
shaped how i saw my role in the world i
knew that i benefited significantly from
the systems and programs that people and
governments had created for me and that
i had a responsibility to pay that
forward
i came to this place because i wanted to
make that the necessary changes for
people to pay it forward
as people continue to struggle i fear
that we will lose that sense of
community that people will turn away
from each other more and more
the more people struggle the less they
have for themselves the less they feel
they can give to others the more they
have to fight
for what they have uh the little that
they have and the less that they have to
fight for the greater the divide between
the riches in this world and the rest of
us the worse this will get people will
turn on their governments and they will
turn on each other because they believe
their governments have turned on them
canadians are looking for answers and
they are looking for solutions
the system has been rigged and they want
to do something about it and solutions
offered by right-wing politicians and
extremists online must be called out as
entirely completely
unacceptable
i'm often in awe that conservatives seem
to provide simple solutions to complex
problems that we face
and this isn't unique to canada we saw
these simple solutions offered in the uk
on the vote for breakfast brexit saying
that life will get better
but it didn't
we saw many simple solutions offered by
donald trump just south of us base ones
based on racism sexism and fear
this did nothing for working americans
their lives didn't improve under his
administration
and we see these so-called solutions
being offered in this house as well lift
all public health measures and let your
neighbors and friends fend for
themselves
simple solutions are often the most
dangerous
madam speaker i hope that this protest
will end shortly but the reasons for it
will not go away
if you look at any crisis it takes a
long time to get to that critical point
and it takes even longer to fix it
now let me be very clear madam speaker
nothing makes the racism the hatred the
threats of violence that we have seen in
ottawa over these past days acceptable
nothing
but to truly address the causes that
have led to so many people feeling
disenfranchised to feeling like they
aren't being heard or that they are
abandoned by this government resulting
in them resolving to occupy the streets
here in ottawa or critical
infrastructure across canada we have to
address the systemic issues at the heart
of the matter new democrats are offering
alternatives to move forward rather than
what is offered by the right wings who
have allied with them
there are concrete measures the
government can make to address rising
inequality in our country we can tackle
rising drug costs with a national
pharmacare plan we can tackle the
housing crisis that is impacting every
community in canada in my home city of
london by getting the canadian
government back into the business of
building housing
we can take on poverty and disparity in
our streets by establishing a guaranteed
basic livable income we can address the
lack of education and access to it by by
making post-secondary education
accessible removing those financial
barriers we can take on the growth of
low paid insecure work by updating labor
codes creating a living wage tipping the
scale back in favor of canadian workers
we can sign trade agreements that
protect canadian jobs instead of making
it easier to ship them overseas we can
strengthen and safeguard workers
pensions ensuring pensioners can retire
with dignity and security
we can ensure that the rich pay their
fair share and close tax loopholes
madam speaker many people now are
rightly concerned about the impact of
the emergencies act
it should have never come to this
the use of the emergencies act and even
the consideration of it
is an acknowledgment of failure of
leadership from all levels of government
including
the prime minister
they've allowed things to escalate
unchecked since the beginning and i
share the concern of many canadians and
people from my constituency that the
government may use misuse the powers in
that act
so i want to be very clear
we will be watching
we will withdraw our support if at any
point we feel these powers are being
misused
people in communities across our country
are feeling the impacts of the convoy
healthcare workers retail and grocery
store workers truck drivers themselves
small business owners and residents have
been harassed intimidated and even
assaulted during these illegal
occupations
thousands of workers have been forced to
stay home from their jobs making it
harder for them to feed their families
and to pay their rent
canadians have been missing the national
leadership that they need during this
crisis they're tired of jurisdictional
excuses and they just want this to stop
we owe them to use every tool available
to stop these occupations that are
harming canadian workers and their
families and to work on a plan to get
this to end
i want to reassure my constituents
that the ndp is taking the use of the
emergencies act very seriously we won't
give a blank check to the government we
also believe that the federal government
and all governments need to take
responsibility before things are allowed
to escalate further we cannot abandon
canadians to deal with this on their own
over the coming days we need to see
action from our police and ending this
occupation and returning the streets
back to our communities
over the coming weeks new democrats will
remain vigilant in watching and
protecting canadians rights and freedoms
holding this government to account
and in the next few months we will push
for more supports to remain until the
pandemic is over and to call for a
science-based approach to see us out of
this pandemic
better as possible but it will take
tough and courageous choices for us to
get there
is not too late my friends to make a
better world thank you madam speaker
questions and comments
questions
just a minute
i remember for london north center
thank you very much uh madam chair and
uh thank you to uh my colleague from
london for her speech i think she did a
very good job of outlining why this
measure is justified but i want to ask
her a question about what happens after
in terms of combating hate and what
members of this house cross-party lines
can do to do just that we've seen hate
expressed by the alt-right in the united
states in recent years and evidently
it's made its way
northwards unfortunately what can we do
collectively as elected
officials in this house to work together
to uh to fight hate because we've seen
its effect in london
i remember for london fan show
i think the the honor call my honorable
colleague and my neighbor uh in london
um for his question
uh this is this is something that that
we've been talking about i know in
london for for quite some time um
especially after the murder of the
offshore family to to come together to
ensure that there are legislative
solutions um i know that we have been
pushing um for the government to
introduce uh legislation on online hate
i believe that's that's now come forward
again we need to ensure that that's
passed we need to hold those internet
companies um social media companies
accountable uh as well and to be part of
that solution um i think
overall in and larger solutions involve
education
they involve ensuring that
we
do as i said in my speech that we're
providing for each other that we're um
making sure that we're not
closing in on our on ourselves um
because of that fight against poverty
and that fight against that desperation
that we have to work harder on those
social programs and those social
solutions that provide for each other so
that we can share with each other and
and fight for each other and be together
thank you the honorary member for
calgary shepherd
thank you madam speaker to the member as
she talked about withdrawing support if
the if they see abuse as she knows the
emergency measures act provisions are
already enforced what we're essentially
talking about here is a confirmation
vote by the house of commons on whether
to keep these provisions in place
i thought we should be doing is what we
should be doing is preventing harm from
happening in the first place which i
think what my caucus and many
conservative members want to do is to
prevent the harm that we see going on
both to innocent people who have their
bank accounts frozen
based on commentary that's been made by
the minister of finance i want to draw
the member's attention perhaps to what
the ndp caucus did in 1970 11 years
before i was born
and i was born in a country where there
was martial law at that time
and it was in 1970 under tommy douglas
who took i think a courageous and
principled stance many people would say
that i would have probably disagreed
with this position but it was definitely
courageous to do so and they stood
against the war measures act at the time
today the ndp has decided to side with
the government and allow the government
extraordinary powers for 30 days i
wonder if she explained why
for london fanshawe
um i i thank the honorable colleague for
his his uh question and for revealing
his age um i wouldn't do that um
i uh i have to recognize that those are
two very very different situations
and that the
thoughtfulness however that tommy and
the caucus at that time took
to think about that war measures act and
the implementation of it is the same
thoughtfulness that our caucus has taken
on this
implementation of the emergencies act
we
and our and and the leader uh for the
party the honorable member for bernabeu
douglas he he talked about that today
and he said directly to the prime
minister we will not let you off the
hook and that we will be watching and so
i stand here today again like i said
with that heavy heart because so many
things are at play
but
i know that i have spoken to people on
the street and they are and they are
worried and they've been assaulted and
that cannot stand and this hatred cannot
stand
question
yeah
but there was one thing
[Music]
there's only time for a very there's no
time at all actually but i will allow
the honor to remember to make a very
brief response
the the uh investments that the the
honorable member is talking about
absolutely those are long-term solutions
um what i was referring to were excuses
that this federal government
consistently makes to not and to avoid
their responsibility um when it comes to
uh what they have to do to to ensure
that they're fulfilling their role to
the provinces thank you madam speaker
you may debate the honorable prominent
sector to the government house leader
thank you uh madam speaker and you know
right after the beginning i would like
to to reflect on the comments what the
prime minister made earlier when he
talked about families
he talked about the importance of their
freedoms
and their rights
we talked about our small businesses
and the economy
and the impact
of what we've been witnessing over the
last few weeks
how critically important it is that when
we have this dialogue over the next
number of days that we don't lose the
focus
of
those particular points
the impact on canadian society is in
fact quite significant and severe
and
here we are
after
a couple of years of having to go
through the pandemic actually
approaching the third year mark
what we
should have been talking about what i
would have liked to have been talking
about uh mr speaker
is more so the heroes
of the pandemic
i think of the community in which i
represent of winnipeg north
and the people that have really
responded so
well
encouraged others
we stepped up together when we were hit
with the pandemic we saw people of all
political stripes
we saw volunteer organizations
individuals private businesses
governments of different levels all
coming together recognizing that the
battle that had to be overcome
was the pandemic
and we are starting to see
more light at the end of the tunnel
and it is in good part because of the
residents of winnipeg north and
residents across this country that said
we want to be able to
listen to the science
follow the health experts
and get vaccinated
that
vaccination rate
that we have in canada
is virtually second to no other place in
the world
and as a result
we have been able to see different
provinces
even the federal government look at
loosening some of those mandates mr
speaker
what we're seeing today
is not what i would have liked to be
talking about
because it's not a true reflection
of canadians and our values and the hard
work that we collectively put in
together
in order to get us to the point where we
are in terms of battling uh the corona
virus mr speaker
i could have spent a great deal of time
talking about the individual effort
or
from my perspective what it is that the
government of auto from
from ottawa has been able to come up
with
to support uh canadians
very tangible things mr speaker
that's what i would have preferred
to talk about
when we look in terms of the need
for the emergency act
let me just reflect in terms of a walk i
make the walk every day since the
since the convoy has been here as many
of us have
and the type of things that i see
are
a downtown
that should be full
of activity
much like downtown winnipeg
edmonton
toronto
montreal
halifax vancouver big cities small
cities alike
we all value our downtowns
they contribute so much to who we are
in many different ways
they are a hub of economic activity
and opportunities
for people to be able to connect even um
even
nowadays uh mr speaker when we are
starting to see more of the mandates
being lifted
i walk down
and it doesn't matter the time of day
where you can look down queen street you
see all the skyscrapers
and there's no people
and it's because of the convoy
one block over you go on to wellington
and you see protesters
that are
not
protesters in the traditional way
what they are
is they're individuals that put up
blockades
they're individuals that are shutting
down
downtown ottawa
and it's just not
along wellington
as i say i walk down wellington and up
metcalf in order to to get to my
apartment mr speaker
wellington's been the same way
if it was happening in winnipeg
i wouldn't
tolerate it and i suspect that there
would be many residents in winnipeg that
would be quite upset with regards to it
because
it is not
a legal
law-abiding
protest
it is hurting
the people of ottawa in particular the
downtown uh area mr speaker
the types of things that i've observed
you know
i don't know how many gas cans red and
yellow gas cans underneath large semis
on the roof of vehicles
cars and trucks that are constantly uh
running
it was past one o'clock in the morning
just last saturday
and you could hear the horns just a
blaring
and i'm quite a ways out
uh mr speaker from the downtown uh area
out on on lisgar
and i can only imagine
what it would be like for those that are
even closer
could you imagine
bringing children into an environment
where you're constantly inhaling
gas fumes
where
you
see the different whether it's weather
or different
tents being established uh you know
right on on wellington
where hay is brought in i take it it's
to provide some sort of comfort on the
ground i have no idea but it surrounds
uh tents that are being permanently put
into wellington
and i've seen several tents
i've seen tents established
uh on metcalf
and those are just the areas that i walk
on
every day mr speaker
i see an incredible truck
that's right below the flame
and it's not you know it's a crane of
sorts it has that big iron ball members
of the chamber would be aware of it
that's a destruction ball you know it's
the one that swings in the air to bring
down buildings
you know i think in terms of i don't
know what's inside those trucks
i suspect no one knows what's inside
those trucks that's sitting inside this
uh chamber uh right now uh mr speaker
i believe
i truly believe
that the need to act is there
and it's very real
and i am disappointed
in the conservative party
in their in their approach in dealing uh
with this this issue
and i think that if we put all the facts
on the table
that a vast majority of canadians would
understand the need and i'm going to
kind of go into that mr speaker
the need for us to have and enacted the
emergency act and i find it interest
interesting
how the conservatives
who once again work with the bloc
it's almost like a given the
conservatives and block they talk about
other coalitions there's no coalition
more stronger in the house of commons
today than the unholy alliance between
the conservative party of canada and the
bloc party of quebec
that is the strongest uh alliance that i
see uh mr speaker
and at the at the end of the day
and at the end of the day uh mr speaker
they're being critical because the ndp
are at least giving it serious thought
with the idea uh mr speaker that yes
they're listening to their constituents
as i'm listening to my constituents and
realize
that these blockades
have got to come down
it is hurting people
it is hurting our economy it is hurting
our society in many different ways
and the official opposition
are all over the place
you know i was just recently shown a
picture of the leader of the or of the
intern leader of the conservative party
dining out with some of the organizers
of the event uh mr speaker
i'd i'd be very much interested in the
leader of the official opposition you
know tell us what it is that she talked
about when she was having supper or
dinner or whatever it was
let me
talk about
inconsistency
on the one hand
you have the newly elected interim
conservative party leader
who advised senior conservatives now
this comes from a leaked
email mr speaker
newly elected interim conservative party
leader
advised senior conservative mps not to
tell members of the trucker convoy to
leave ottawa
and instead make the protest
the prime minister's problem
according to the internal email obtained
by ctv news
in an email sent on monday
then deputy leader told her colleagues i
don't think we should be asking them to
go home
how is that fit
the interest
of canadians uh mr speaker
i would suggest to you that that is very
much
very much a slant
of politics
purely politics coming from the official
opposition
go on to another point mr speaker
opposition leader in the state's name
wants the prime minister to step up to
solve the crisis
on the other hand just a week after
meeting with the protesters and telling
them
quote
don't stop it's working
so she's out there
dining
and telling them
don't stop
it's working
and then the other day when i was
speaking inside the chamber i said you
know you've got to be consistent
inside the house
the conservative leader says
okay
the blockade
is bad
and it's time for people to go home they
can get anyone that's following the bait
tonight they can get that actual quote
and much more
[Music]
didn't really have an impact outside
but the comments that i had for the
member then is
well you know it's it's one thing to say
something in here what are you saying
outside take a look at the social media
feeds going out of the conservative
party
listen to some of the the words that
they're espousing even today inside the
chamber
they are giving a mixed message at best
uh mr speaker
i would suggest to you that they are
causing more harm
than good
but they have their friends in the block
that are more than happy to to assist
them in the best way that that they can
uh mr speaker but you know i tell my
conservative friends the block have a
different agenda
their agenda has their agenda has a lot
is a lot different
i like to think than the conservatives
so before you start criticizing
other uh political parties you might
want to start reevaluating
the people the associations that you
have
inside the chamber on this issue
at the same time
the association that you have
and the role that you played
with the convoy
uh outside in in the protest uh mr
speaker
the irony of the protest
doesn't escape me
you know back towards the the end of
january
it started off
with truckers that were concerned about
mandates about truckers going into the
united states
before
anyone arrived in ottawa the united
states made it very clear unless you're
vaccinated you can't go into the united
states
[Music]
no the president of the united states
does and i don't have a phone line i
didn't tell the president to say that
you know mr
speaker you know then what ends up
happening
is
fast forward today where we have
these
semis
and trucks and others
that started to
shut down
the auto ottawa downtown ottawa
not to mention the other blockades
and i want to quickly go over that uh mr
speaker
when i think
of the weeks of illegal blockades in the
occupations
how important it is that our borders
remain open
in kutz alberta
think of 48 million dollars
a day
in
uh economic trade mr speaker
in windsor
roughly 390 million dollars
in emerson my home province
73 million dollars a day
i want to
get a couple of quotes
and because members say well why did we
why did we take this action and i can
make reference to whether it's the mayor
of ottawa declaring an emergency here in
ottawa i can talk about the premier of
ontario declaring an emergency in the
province of ontario
let me talk about my home province of
manitoba
you know if you read yesterday's
winnipeg free press
in a february 11 letter and i have been
able to get a copy of letter through
through the media
it states a letter obtained by the free
press said premier stephenson asked the
prime minister to take immediate and
effective action as she pleaded
for national leadership that only the
prime minister and the federal
government could provide
that was just a couple days before it
was actually brought in on monday
you know the letter said the situation
was urgent and the blockades that
disrupt this critical corridor event
even temporarily create potential
dangers impose severe hardships for all
manitobans and cause severe economic
loss and damage to manitoba and canadian
businesses
her letter warned of urgency and dangers
again
look in terms of the impact of just the
emerson border
here's the uh another story mr speaker
that appeared in the free press
the trucker blockade of emerson border
crossing not only added additional time
and cost to shipments but will also
damage the reputation of the province
manufacturers
so say stakeholders
although the rcmp announced on tuesday
afternoon that demonstrators are leaving
and should be gone by wednesday
ron kowalski
the vice president and head of the
mattoba operations for the canadian
manufacturers and exports
said
95
of whom manitoba members rely on regular
cross-border shipments at emerson
said
of the emerson blockade
the impact has been massive
windpak limited
the large packing material manufacturer
that is headquartered in winnipeg and
has manufacturing plants throughout the
u.s had to shut down one of its
production lines because it couldn't get
the raw material it needed
all vermough windpak ceo said overall
the whole blockade damages the canadian
reputation at a large and specifically
wind park
the emerson thing hurt us significantly
mr speaker the federal government
invoked the emergencies act
on monday
the measures
are based on geographically specific
targeted targeted only to where they are
needed
they will also be time limited
we are not limiting people's freedoms of
expression in any way
mr speaker when it comes to peaceful uh
demonstrations
since monday mr speaker we have seen
the coots blockade was in fact
dismantled wednesday the block at the
blockade in emerson
we've provided more tools for law
enforcement in which in part are already
being utilized
mr speaker at the end of the day
on this side of the house we recognize
the harm
to our society
on a many different ways as a direct
result of these illegal blockades and
protests and would suggest that the
conservative party revisit its
positioning it's not like you haven't
flip-flopped before
take another flop
and get on the right side support what
canadians expect the royal opposition uh
to to be doing
and ensure that there's accountability
on the measures that are needed at this
time in order to bring back order uh mr
speaker and secure the type of trade and
support the canadians deserve and uh the
opposition should be providing
now i know the member is an experienced
member of the house and make sure that
we come through that come through the
chair i know he was really trying to
engage the opposition on this one but
try to keep things through the chair uh
questions and comments the honorable
member for calgary shepherd thank you mr
speaker so um
i have a commentary to make about the
member speech just to set the record
straight and correct the misinformation
i too for the last three weeks have been
walking downtown every weekend and every
day across this line
i've met a lot of very friendly people
and of course some people are profane in
what they say this is a protest after
all but he was talking about a wrecking
ball in a vehicle
it's not a wrecking ball that's actually
a hook weight at the end of the cable
first of all there's a difference
between the two
i've met a lot of people families like i
stay at a hotel when i'm down here i've
met people who bring their families here
there's music shows going on
the
impression the member is trying to give
to the general public to people back
home in calgary is that this is some
type of riot that's going on downtown
yes people have blocked streets and yes
we have said they should go home we've
heard them we're hearing them we're
addressing their concerns but what the
government is doing here is going far
too far they're asking for powers that
has not been given to anybody since the
1970s they're asking for much too much
more than a house should be willing to
give
everything that i've gone here i haven't
seen the same things the member have
seen i i'm getting thousands of emails
from constituents demanding that we vote
against this measure so i just wanted to
correct that from the member it's it's
the weight at the end of the hook on the
cable it's not a wrecking ball just want
to make sure that i've seen that too i
just want to make that correction and
for the vast majority of people i have
met i've seen people play street hockey
on the street
like just the impression that he's
giving is that this is like a chaotic
scene it's unpleasant i understand it
for people live here it's been
unpleasant for three weeks for me as
well thank you speaker for the honorable
parliamentary secretary
you know mr speaker and the member kind
of makes my point you see the
conservative party says
what's wrong there's nothing wrong with
what's happening in ottawa downtown
today the activities by this blockade is
shut down downtown ottawa
there's no cars there's no traffic
there's no people in terms of businesses
are closing down
to try to give the impression to the
residents that he represent that
everything's okay in ottawa
i don't know what the member might be
engaged in but it's definitely not
reality mr speaker okay maybe it's not a
wrecking ball but it might be a 200
pound iron ball that's positioned right
above the prime minister's office that
stephen harper used to be in
you know is there any way in which that
member could foresee
problems with
thousands of gallons of gas along
wellington uh on trucks and cars on
roofs under the vehicle question
questions and comments i know i'm we're
going a little long here all of a sudden
i know we have lots of time to to ask
questions but we're going to run out
really quickly question come on dad let
her have the deputy to bullpur
my friend
thank you mr speaker um
[Music]
one thing that really caught my
foreign
[Music]
live in ottawa the honorable
parliamentary secretary yes thank you uh
mr speaker unlike maybe some members of
the block
within the liberal caucus all urban
centers matter
when an urban center no matter what its
size whether it's a quebec city montreal
ottawa winnipeg brandon vancouver
victoria you name the municipality we
are concerned when in fact there are
issues in that municipality that would
involve
issues that we should be concerned about
mr speaker we have an obligation to be
there and that's what's good in terms of
what's happening through the emergencies
act it's a very much focused on ensuring
that people can feel comfortable in
being safe and our economy can be
protected those borders are critically
important to our country no matter
questions and comments the honourable
member for london fanshawe
thank you mr speaker
i would like to ask the honorable
colleague um
[Music]
in my community uh i've received some
some complaints from folks who are upset
because confederate flags
have have shown up on their neighbors
lawns i'd like to ask him um going
forward after ideally
we can we can move past this convoy and
and hopefully things settle down
a little bit
um
where the government is going to go from
there um how are we going to stop this
from spreading
in the way that we've seen it spread to
communities and that emboldering and
bolstering i'm not sure that the word
exactly of of that of that hate and that
and that and that horrible
symbolism of hatred
the honorable parliamentary secretary
yes uh mr speaker it's an excellent
question and i can tell you many years
ago um i used to uh be a critic for um
diversity and i often talked about the
issue of racism and the best way in
which you
fight racism is through education and i
can tell you i was so impressed
when the member from hall elmer
raised in a an so31 a statement on
racism
and if i was a school trustee in
winnipeg north
i'd be inclined to encourage every young
person in school to listen to that so31
it gave a very strong personal
touch to how racism hurts us all mr
speaker
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for king's hands
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
my honorable colleague for his remarks
today just two quick questions uh for
him one is around powers i had the
opportunity to speak to a constituent
actually just a few minutes ago
who was concerned that this was a broad
overreach by the government when i
actually explained the different
measures within the public order
he actually understood and said well
look that's reasonable because it's
giving tools to police to actually be
able to address this could the member
speak about how these are really
restrictive powers albeit under the
emergencies act to give those tools and
that it's about leadership not just here
in ottawa but in his own city in
winnipeg as he mentioned in other places
in the country to make sure that the law
enforcement if they choose to use this
discretion have the tools to stop the
blockades and the protests that we've
seen that are truly illegal
honorable parliamentary secretary yes
thank you mr speaker i'll give a good
example yesterday
or maybe it was tuesday when i was
walking down to the parliament hill
there was a police officer and he was
meeting with some of the individual
protesters and he was handing out a
piece of paper and as i was walking by
he was referencing the emergency act
and what this is is another tool
for law enforcement agencies to be able
to ensure that the illegal blockades and
protests come to an end
that's why we have it before us today
there are measures within
such as a standing committee to review
it on an ongoing basis we also have an
inquiry once it's all said and done
there's all sorts of transparency and
accountability to make sure that it's
not abused and it is a wonderful tool
that uh that can be effective mr speaker
well hey come out to our questions and
comment have time for a pretty short one
the honourable member for a destiny miss
nippy churchill river
thank you mr speaker mr speaker it's
always a pleasure to listen to my
colleague from winnipeg center it's both
entertaining and and enlightening often
it is
it's often it's interesting for him to
talk about the political aspects of this
it seems that the first thing that comes
to mind is the pot calling the pedal
kettle black but mr speaker the prime
minister expects us to believe that the
emergency act will be geographically
targeted and that's a quote that's what
he told canadians when he made the
announcement
yet the iron council itself states that
the emergency exists throughout canada
and again that's a quote we have nothing
to suggest otherwise nothing in writing
to suggest otherwise i can assure you
the premier from saskatchewan alberta
manitoba many other provinces in this
country
do not want this in their provinces so
how does this member explain the
contradiction
and why should we trust him and his
prime minister
when the first thing they did was to
mislead canadians in the in the
announcement of the act
the honorable parliamentary secretary in
30 seconds yes um
mr speaker i would recommend anyone
that's just listened to the members uh
question to take a look at what the free
winnipeg free press wrote yesterday in
regards to the province there was a
letter that was written by premier
heather steffensen virtually begging
ottawa to get more involved it was
urgent there was a crisis there's a
serious problem in the province of
manitoba at the emerson border crosser
it was devastating to our industries we
need that border and
open and this type of legislation that
we're passing today is not only good for
manitoba it's good for ontario alberta
it's good for all canada
resuming debate the honourable member
for
selkirk interlake eastman
thank you mr speaker and i can tell you
it's uh disappointing that we actually
are here debating
the use of emergency powers
that has been laid out by the prime
minister
really this is an indictment on failed
leadership this is about a prime
minister who has dropped the ball when
it comes down to dealing with this
crisis but also has failed to unite
canadians because he constantly just
divides stigmatizes insults and
marginalizes those that
have concerns about vaccine mandates
about
the restrictions that have been brought
in by the federal government and he
doesn't seem to listen
i don't believe
that the emergencies act needs to be
used i don't believe that under the
division the definitions of the
emergency act that the threshold has
been met
and i don't believe that the federal
government has used the powers that they
already possess
to deal with these situations
what i do believe is that under this
order and council that we're looking at
under the emergencies act uh under i
believe it's section 19 of the act that
there is open ended powers that have
been handed over to
this prime minister and we know at the
beginning of this pandemic that this
prime minister tried to ascertain as
much power and control as possible over
parliament over the treasury and over
the executive of the government
because he thought that he needed it to
grab on to that power and we know that
that lust of power that the prime
minister has brought us into
an early election because he thought he
could win his majority in the middle of
a pandemic
and ignored the plight of canadians who
were dealing with the issues surrounding
the pandemic he ignored the
plight of afghanistan refugees who were
trying to get to canada who'd worked
alongside our soldiers all because he
wanted
the prime minister wanted more power he
thought he could get his majority
now
in the past we had the war measures act
and i acknowledge that the emergency act
is a modernized version of the war
measures act
but it still has the same
ultimate goal
of dealing with major catastrophes in
our country
so have we had you know a major
hurricane or did we have earthquakes
were we attacked no we weren't
are we in a world war like world war one
world war ii
you know have we gone through the 1970
flq crisis has somebody been kidnapped
have leaders of government been
kidnapped or murdered no there hasn't
and so there is no way that this the
sovereign nation of canada is under
threat that we have to go and use this
emergencies act
what we see out on the streets
yes
is
sometimes annoying
to those that live i i got i'm a
property owner there's no doubt and i
want to denounce all those that have
signs of hate i spent my entire
political career and before that
denouncing racism denouncing
anti-semitism denouncing those that fly
nazi flags and dress up as nazi soldiers
i denounce those that that are carrying
the confederate flags we have to stop
racism and so each and every one of
those people that have infiltrated the
the convoy need to be called out and
held responsible for those hateful acts
but at times to get attention and to
make a point
part of being
a canadian is having a peaceful protest
and sometimes that includes civil
disobedience and i've said it in this
house before when the liberals had their
long gun registry i refused to register
my long guns that was my act of civil
disobedience
to stand against an overbearing
overreaching
liberal government policy
now
i'll also say this because there's a lot
of concern about you know how traffic's
been blocked how borders were blocked
infrastructures have been blocked i've
always opposed blockades we cannot hold
our economy hostage i believe that
everybody has made their point i'm glad
that they're going home and they went
home off our border points without the
use of the emergencies act it was
provincial governments local policing
local municipal leaders that were able
to negotiate and remove those blockades
the same way this government in the past
has dealt with blockades at our
vancouver port at pipelines at railway
crossings you know they went on for days
we didn't call the emergency act to get
those blockades removed because we went
and listened to the people with their
concerns this government refuses to talk
with the truckers out on wellington
street
that is disturbing to say the elites
the biggest concern i have in this mr
speaker is that this is suspending
the civil liberties and our charter
rights
because it's open-ended at this point in
time and i just want to remind you that
under the war measures act
in world war one
and guido you know you know i'm of
ukrainian descent and they came to
canada on austrian passports they were
declared enemy aliens and for four years
had to go one way 20 miles to the rcmp
station every week to register summer
winter fall and spring didn't matter
what they're doing on the farm they have
to register
even though my bubba's brother was
fighting for canada in world war one
and they still had to report in and they
had to for two years after the war ended
because
the government refused to lift
the war measures act and that violation
of their charter rights
now
i'm concerned that this government will
want to continue to erode the civil
liberties that we have here now and
you know we've got to make sure
that
that doesn't happen so i do appreciate
and acknowledge that or that the
emergency measures act does provide
parliamentary oversight and that's why
we're having this debate tonight that we
can
make sure that we call it back and not
to be revoked if it passes with the
support of the ndp and i gotta say i'm
really
really
upset that the ndp
would stand against freedom
would stand against the charter and
would support the liberals and the prime
minister in bringing even this ham
fisted approach to dealing with the
crisis that they think is out on the
street
now
section two of our charter
right now is undermined peaceful
assembly i walk through the the the
convoy every day everybody says hi you
know everybody's been been very polite
out there you know sometimes you know
hawking the horns like this morning at
10 to 7 was was annoying but they don't
do it all day long and this is just
short periods here and there the first
week was a bit overbearing i'll give
them that
section seven
life liberty and security
so how are they
going to ensure that to the tow truck
companies
when they are commandeering
the equipment to tow out the vehicles
out at our on the street right now
and then
what's beyond the pale in all this is
that they have brought in the violation
of section 8 of the charter for
unreasonable search and seizure
the locking down of bank accounts of
people who gave generously to help with
the trucking convoy because they
couldn't join they feel they have no
other voice and that they financially
supported the convoy now to have their
bank accounts locked down
is
disgusting this is an overreach of the
government of canada and i'm concerned
that now that they're on fintrac that
they're going to be treated like they
were funding a terrorist organization
that they will not be able to get a loan
get access to their savings account no
one won't be able to even you know
get a mortgage like that that to me is
really disturbing and
really what's next section 19 of the
ordering
of the emergencies act and what's
referenced in the ordering council
says that there is going to be other
temporary measures authorized under
section section 19 of the act that is
not known mr speaker
so again come back to this issue
of failed leadership of inaction and
paralysis
by the prime minister and i'm shocked
i've been here for quite a while you
know 17 years
i'm shocked that we don't have an
emergency
management plan for for for the
parliament buildings in ottawa as the
capital city you know i was here for the
terrorist attack that happened in 2014.
we witnessed what happened january 6
2021 on capitol hill with the riot that
was there
and
we know that that um you know there
should have been plans made to deal with
the situation like this but i can tell
you that the minister of emergency
preparedness when he was the toronto
police chief in 2010 when the
protests were happening at the g20 in
toronto
arrested in a matter of a couple of days
1100 protesters and they were able to
bring in rcmp opp
and toronto city police and regional
police in the area and deal with the
situation we don't need an emergency
measures act to do that now then why do
we need it now and i can tell you mr
speaker that
it's time to de-escalate this situation
the prime minister has to stop
stigmatizing marginalizing traumatizing
and name-calling those that don't agree
with his policies and actually bring
people around take the heat out and
these restrictive and divisive mandates
so that we can get back to a normal life
again and live as a strong
united canada
christian contact questions and comments
uh the honorable minister of families
children and social development mr
speaker and first of all i'd like to
begin by thanking my colleague for his
strong denunciation of hate of
anti-semitism and racism i really
appreciate that and thank him for doing
that so strongly
mr speaker i want to also just comment
that the emergencies act specifically is
designed to uphold the charter of rights
and freedoms and i'm also happy to hear
conservatives speaking so highly of the
charter of rights and freedoms as well
but mr speaker the question that i
wanted to ask my honorable colleague in
a sense i think he answered part of it
when he spoke about the danger to tow
truck operators
why is he concerned with their security
if everything that's happening out there
is so peaceful the second question that
i would like to ask him because i know
he has a long history when it comes to
protecting the safety and security of
canadians he spoke about the financial
transactions and he spoke actually about
january 6. the anti-defamation league in
the united states has put out a list of
eleven hundred donors who also donated
to january sixth insurrection in the
capital how can he
square that circle mr speaker and does
he not believe that foreign interference
in our democracy is an issue that we
must stand firmly against thank you mr
speaker the honorable member
interlake eastman
well i think
the the minister misunderstood what i
was saying about the tow truck drivers
how
can they have section eight of the uh of
the charter of of uh security when they
are being forced to tow people that they
don't want to tow
they and we've already heard this a lot
of tow truck drivers do not want to be
out there towing because these are their
customers these are the people that they
work with every day and they don't want
to be put in a position where they're
they're being in an adversarial nature
that's their concern it's not that
they're going to hurt them that's that
these are their friends these are their
customers and why should they be forced
into it and so their their their charter
rates are being violated in this as well
i'll say this if the government is so
concerned about foreign interference
then why haven't they denounced what
we've already seen as what was
linked to the communist regime in
beijing and interfering in the last
federal election here that cost us as a
conservative party at least nine seats
why don't they announ denounce when tide
foundations and other money from the u.s
flows up and funds things to block our
energy products and our transportation
systems in this country
come on questions and comments
jean care
the honourable member
[Music]
is
[Music]
mr speaker we know that there's a number
of provincial municipal and federal laws
that are already in place including the
criminal code that that can be used to
deal with the situation out on the
street uh you know
sitting on the street illegally parking
well guess what you get a parking ticket
you get towed and and it's just a matter
of having enough police members out
there to do it as i've used in this
example we witnessed with both the
olympics in 2010 in vancouver as well as
the g20 meeting in toronto in august of
2010 that there was
lots of police that were able to be
brought in from across the country by
using federal provincial municipal
powers to provide the proper security at
the olympics and arrest over 1100
protesters that were at the g20
summit and have them all locked away and
made sure that everybody else was safe
after a quick one uh the honorable
member for port moody coquitlam
uh thank you uh miss
uh mr speaker and uh i i just wanted to
mention that you know there has been
some words tonight about this being an
inconvenience or annoyance and i just
want to point out the privilege that we
have uh in this house that exists that
we can look at something like this is
just as an inconvenience and an
annoyance when there's families and uh
individuals struggling right now with no
income because of their lack of ability
to go to work um i just wanted to speak
about the policing my question to the
member mr speaker is why does the member
think that policing has not been
enforced even though we know that there
are infractions happening and crimes
happening on the street right now
i don't remember for a selkirk interlake
eastman 30 seconds or so mr speaker i
think it's pretty clear that we've had
such weak leadership from the prime
minister
that uh he he hasn't at all provided any
direction uh that the the public safety
minister and the minister of emergency
preparedness have not been at all
concerned about this until it became to
the 11th hour they should have been
acting on this sooner they should have
had poor police on the streets and they
should have had proper ticketing and and
arresting individuals especially those
that were that were promoting hate on
the streets thank you resuming debate
continuing debate uh the honourable
member for st albert edmonton thank you
mr speaker i rise to speak this evening
to speak of the government's
unprecedented invocation
of the emergencies act
this act has been on the books for
34
years
and in those 34 years it has not been
used on a single occasion
not during the oca crisis
not during caledonia
not in the wake of september 11th
not following the 2020
blockades of critical infrastructure
including railway lines and pipelines
that went on for
two months never before
and there's good reason mr speaker that
this act has never been
invoked
before and that is because
it is
exceptional
legislation
meant for the most extreme
of circumstances
and with that
it provides
government
with sweeping powers
that infringe upon
the charter rights
and civil liberties of canadians
powers including
prohibiting
public
assemblage
seizing property
freezing bank accounts
without warrant
limiting or prohibiting travel within
canada
and i could go on
extraordinary powers indeed mr speaker
and in light of the
exceptional
nature
of this legislation intended for the
most extreme circumstances
the threshold that must be satisfied
in order to establish
that there is a national emergency
pursuant to the act
is indeed an extremely high threshold
an emergency
under the act
is an urgent and critical situation
that seriously endangers the lives
health or safety of canadians or
that seriously threatens the ability of
the government of canada to preserve the
sovereignty security and territorial
integrity of canada
and not only that
mr speaker
the emergency must be
of a nature
and so as to exceed the capacity
or authority of a province to deal with
it
and
not only that
no other law on the books
can effectively deal
with the situation
mr speaker it is patently clear
that that threshold
that very high
threshold has not been satisfied
indeed it has not come close to being
satisfied
the government
in justifying the invocation
of these extraordinary
powers
talk about ending
blockades
indeed when one turns to the order in
council
issued on monday
that specifies the nature
of the purported emergency
the order in council speaks of the
continuing blockades of critical
infrastructure
including trade corridors
and international border crossings it
speaks to the adverse impacts that these
blockades have had with trading partners
particularly the united states
and it speaks of a breakdown
in the supply chain
and availability of goods
as a result of these blockades
however mr speaker there's a big problem
for this government
there are no blockades in canada today
not on the canada-us border
not anywhere
and mr speaker there were no such
blockades on monday
when
the government invoked the order in
council on the emergencies act now there
were
blockades on the canada u.s border
at coots windsor
and surrey
those blockades were unlawful
they were wrong
and they were dispersed prior to the
invocation
of the emergencies act
under
tools already available to law
enforcement and under existing laws
i remind the government
that in the act
in order
to
utilize the emergencies act
it must be demonstrated that no other
laws on the books
can reasonably be used
that simply has borne out not to be the
case
so we are now left mr speaker
with the situation here in ottawa
there are trucks
outside on
wellington in front of parliament hill
there are
some protesters
and
in addition to the street in front of
parliament hill being affected there are
some
streets immediately around the
parliamentary precinct in downtown
ottawa that are affected
and yes it has created
unpleasantness yes it has been
a nuisance
yes there have been
illegal activities by certain people who
are here
and mr speaker
the that does not constitute or that
does not make
a national emergency
indeed all of
the tools that exist
are there
and have been used for example
the honking of horns
that has largely been addressed
by way
of an injunction
issued by a judge
when it comes to the criminal code
uh
transportation laws
municipal bylaws those are tools on the
books
to address this situation
but mr speaker
what cannot be justified
is invoking the emergencies act
the emergencies act
is not
needed
it's not
warranted
because mr speaker
there is
no
national
emergency
and so
what we have
is a prime minister
who has
invoked the emergency act
absent a national emergency
that mr speaker is an abuse of power
on the part of the prime minister
it is a perversion
of the rule of law
it threatens
the rights and freedoms of canadians
right across canada not just those who
are standing outside parliament hill
and it sets
a dangerous precedent of normalizing the
extraordinary powers
authorized
pursuant to the act
the prime minister knows that the
threshold has been has not been met
but the prime minister doesn't care
because for the prime minister
it's all about
political theater
the prime minister knows what he is
doing
is wrong
and that he is acting
unlawfully
and so
the members on that side of the house
the members in the ndp the coalition
partners of this government
have a choice
they can follow the law
pursuant to the emergencies act
or they can aid and about
this abuse of power on the part of the
prime minister the choice is clear thank
you mr speaker
now since i've taken the chair i've
noticed a lot of helpful people trying
to help every everybody out in their
speeches and i know it depends on who's
who's actually got the uh got the chair
um to how where the help is coming from
but we've got lots of debate to do we've
got lots of opportunity to be able to
speak in the house we've got lots of
opportunity to ask questions so let's
get to questions and answer um the
honorable
minister of families children and
social development mr speaker it's a
long title mr speaker the member
opposite and i were elected together in
2015. we've gotten to know each other
and one thing i've gotten to know about
him is that he
stands or has stood for law in order the
member opposite has said that there is
no national emergency that there are no
illegal maybe some illegal activities
but those illegal activities taking
place are okay they're not that bad so
450 million dollars of trade a day
was blockaded
uh the emergencies measures the
emergencies act was announced on monday
there were still blockades at that point
at our border points today
in windsor ontario a woman was arrested
for threatening to bomb the house of the
mayor a blockade was stopped on their
way to the ambassador bridge in fact if
you just walk out parliament there's
there's a blockade in ottawa uh mr
speaker i
the member opposite is saying to the
thousands of residents who've been held
hostage for the last 20 days
that their safety and their security
doesn't matter
what is he saying
to the canadians who
had elected members in all parties in
this house just a few months ago to the
people who are out there that he served
coffee to that he took pictures with
that's right that have
said they want to overthrow not the
government every elected member the
honor the honourable member for saint
out of st albert edmonton
thank you mr speaker and i want to thank
the honorable minister for her question
and the issue at hand
is whether the threshold has been met to
invoke
the emergencies act that is the question
and based upon a review of the
legislation it is very clear that that
bar has not been set with respect to the
blockades it was existing law
enforcement tools and powers under the
authority of the provinces that
dispersed the situation at coots the
situation was dispersed by many of the
protesters themselves what the prime
minister needs to do
is to take turn down the temperature
and instead of pouring fire
on this situation and with respect to
the honorable minister i say this could
be ended very very quickly the path
towards ending it is for the prime
minister to move forward and lift his
punitive and discriminatory vaccine
mandates that would resolve this issue
all right
now the same old
and clear two months
um
i understand my colleagues
[Music]
with the protesters right here in ottawa
and elsewhere
well thank you mr speaker there are 119
conservative members of parliament who
are working every single day to fight
for revere constituents including those
who have been adversely affected by this
government's radical policies
[Applause]
questions and comments questions are the
honourable member for winnipeg center
thank you so much mr speaker
i know my honorable colleague frequently
refers to indigenous peoples
who are peacefully protesting on their
unseated territories i i wonder if he
was in government
mr speaker what he would do if a
national police service refused to
enforce their rule of law like they have
been in west surton including what we
saw with militarized police where they
took an axe a chainsaw mr speaker and an
attack dog to take down the door of two
unarmed indigenous women on unseated
territory something that was affirmed in
supreme court rulings uh and the fact
that we in now are witnessing uh in
ottawa police in ottawa that have been
dangerously lenient to these so-called
protesters i would refer to it as an
illegal occupation mr speaker in fact we
even have photos and news broadcasts of
police officers hugging
blockaders i'm wondering what he would
do if he was
uh he if he was in government mr speaker
the honourable member for st albert
edmonton with a very short answer thank
you mr speaker but the ball is in the
prime minister's court he created
this crisis
it is up to him to solve the crisis
and solving the crisis does not begin by
invoking an emergencies act that cannot
be justified in the circumstances
[Applause]
represented by our continuing debate
uh
um
tragic
[Music]
minister
that it um
[Music]
bleed
but
rather completely
back to bed
responsibility to the ottawa
first
is
montreal decided to go to dorval
international report
here we are in 2022 nothing has changed
at the very moment
the tortoises
even though the prime minister had
claimed for three days
emergency measures
assemblies that may reasonably be
accepted
foreign
let's be clear
is
is
is often used
during which the problems
is
there
oh
is
municipalities have the means to
actually
yes
they've made it
independence
[Music]
in quebec
was
at the time
arrests that they would slow down
the war
[Music]
does this sound familiar
for partisan purposes in 2022
i'm aware
another major difference
is
that we were forced to resign ourselves
to using this last resort law it's a
symbol
currently in place the institution is
prime minister in this government
thank you mr speaker
thank you very much mr speaker
when it's time to complain we can always
uh
who aren't sleeping
because
uh the honorable member for destiny miss
nippy churchill river
thank you mr speaker mr speaker far be
it for me
to quote an ndp mp in this house but
considering the honorable tommy douglas
was from saskatchewan
um i think maybe i'll do it just this
one time
in describing pirelli trudeau's use of
the war measures act
he said it was like using a sledgehammer
to crack a peanut
mr speaker i'm sure my colleague from
the block would agree that what is
happening outside
is pale in comparison to what was going
on in 1970 he referred to that in his in
his comments
i would ask my colleague from the block
what he thinks the great tommy douglas
would do if he were here in this house
of commons at this moment in time
the deputy
the use of the
the emergencies act in both cases it was
not justified there are institutions the
police exists
[Music]
you'll get there you'll get it
made an admiral president
uh
before us right now um the war measures
act uh from 1970 but
um
for the people of canada
this is something that was very
tremendous for the people of quebec
vote against
[Music]
later
and comments deputy
member for king's hands mr speaker
through you of course look i i'm quite
gobsmacked listening to the members
speech particularly because the member
started by saying that the government of
canada should have acted sooner the
quebec quad normally has a lot of
respect for jurisdictions and of course
we were there to support municipalities
we were there to support the provincial
governments that asked for our
assistance with additional
forces with creating an integrated
command
so we were there right from the start
have we done something more sooner they
would have been also screaming to say
look overreach as the federal government
his own critic for public safety on
monday said this that the federal
government needed to show leadership
does he not expect the federal
government showing leadership is
creating tools to the provincial
government to actually use their
discretion to be able to stop protests
across the country including the ones at
lacall that are being contemplated by
provincial police in quebec and it's
great that he mentions the hosts uh the
national assembly in quebec
72 of quebecers agree with this measure
what does he have to say to them
a survey is a survey and
or looked at the question that was asked
100 of the national assembly is
that seems to be impossible
questions and comments the honourable
member for port moody
report moody go quickly
thank you mr speaker and i just wanted
to
ask a question to the member just around
policing as well as some of the members
tonight have talked about uh you know
the slight inconvenience and the
annoyances but others have spoken about
the fear in the community and i note
that we've all seen that the police have
not been able to enforce crime uh have
not been able to force enforce the
municipal
level by line fractions so i'm just
wondering if them through you uh mr
speaker if the member could just say why
they think
that policing has not been enforced in
this situation
in ottawa
in 45 seconds please 45 seconds
that it was well applied
it was implied on the ambassador
debate the honorable member for south
shore saint margarets
thank you mr speaker
today i rise to speak on historic and
unprecedented situation situation facing
our country for the first time since its
passage
in 1988
the emergencies act is being invoked by
the prime minister
this law outlines a type of situation
that
that would merit its invocation it notes
that it must only be used during an
emergency that arises from threats to
the security of canada
and that is that are so serious as to be
a national emergency and while it's the
prime minister's decision to invoke the
act it's a duty of members
in this house
that have been placed in us to either
reject it ratify it and ensure if the
measures are taken that they're
justifiable and appropriate
the act
enumerates four circumstances that would
justify the use of its powers
let me outline those
emergencies described in the act and
hold the circumstances of the current
standoff up against these provisions to
see if today's situation
meets any of these criteria criteria one
espionage or sabotage that is against
canada or is detrimental to the
interests of canada
or such activities directed to toward
and in support of such espionage and
sabotage
i've seen no clear evidence
that blocked aids have been infiltrated
by spies or other acts of espionage
nor has the government brought any such
evidence forward to this house
criteria two
foreign influenced activities within or
relating to canada that are detrimental
to the interests of canada
and are clandestine or deceptive or
involve a threat to any person
the prime minister has alluded to
foreign funding by individuals however
it remains unclear how this is
detrimental to the interest of canadians
there is no foreign country that is
financing or otherwise supporting the
blockades financially and that's the
test
if the prime minister believes it is a
foreign government funding this then he
has an obligation to share that with the
house
[Applause]
criteria three activities within or
relating to canada directed towards us
or in support of the threat or use of
acts or serious violence against persons
or property for the purpose of achieving
political religious
or ideological objective within canada
or a foreign state
there has been no concerted violent
effort made by any members of the
blockade in fact we saw mostly peaceful
removal of the protesters on the
ambassador bridge and isolated acts of
violence do
do not equate to full-blown acts of
violence that are aimed at achieving
political objectives
criteria four activities directed toward
undermining by convert unlawful acts or
directed toward or intended ultimately
to lead to the destruction or overthrow
by violence
of the constitutionally established
system of government in canada
every day i've been walking to my office
into the house of commons like all mps
unimpeded by protesters to be sure
they've effectively blocked several
streets created a lot of noise and made
life more difficult for those of us
living downtown
but what's happened in downtown ottawa
in the last three weeks is nothing
remotely close to the violent overthrow
of the constitutionally established
system of government in canada
the security intelligence services act
explicitly prohibits the use of these
kinds of powers
on lawful protests or dissent if the
present circumstances don't warrant
using the act for the first time
they absolutely pale in comparison to
the previous times the act's predecessor
was invoked
i was a legislative assistant to the
government that created this act
to replace the war measures act to
prevent the suspension of charter rights
and over government overreach
through our long history there are only
three other times this has happened
during the two world wars and during the
october crisis when there was an armed
insurrection when a diplomat and a
politician were kidnapped pierre laporte
was murdered and bombs were set off in
quebec
it was a horrible experience and even
still some called it overreach so mr
speaker i ask you does a traffic jam
on the street in front of parliament
hill merit the same type of response
as those three incidents
of course not
the act must only be used as a last
resort
that's what the prime minister said
but if this measure is his last resort
what was his plan a b and c because we
didn't see it did he make himself
available to meet with the delegation of
protesters to hear them now
of course not did he dispatch a
delegation of his ministers to meet with
them any key caucus members or senior
officials other than the rcmp
of course not
the government's report to parliament on
the emergency act consultations confirms
this
there are 58 engagements in this list i
searched and i searched through the
details of the 58 engagements did i find
reference to one government official
one minister
or the prime minister
meeting with canadians on this
no i did not
the government this prime minister
had meetings with themselves
not with canadians
they went from sitting on their duffs in
non-productive meetings to implementing
the most heavy-handed act available
governments
the prime minister said he did not take
it lightly
but the evidence in his own documents
shows otherwise
the government does not need the
emergency act to arrest illegal
protesters this is done often
just ask the minister of the environment
cutting off funding of an illegal
activity does not require the emergency
act the proceeds of crime legislation
deals with that
the executive director of fintrac
in his statement before our
parliamentary committee said there is no
evidence of foreign extremists financing
behind these demonstrations there is no
need then for the emergency act to stop
foreign funding
for 21 days the federal government has
had the regular
legislative tools to deal with the
ottawa protest but they've not used them
they have not stopped one jerry can of
fuel
one hot tub
one barbecue propane container from
being carried through the protest right
by the police
meanwhile provincial governments in
ontario manitoba and bc
used standard policing tools to dispense
with the protests
days before the convoy had even arrived
in ottawa
he was stigmatizing and vilifying the
participants he called them racists and
misogynists
fringe minority who hold unacceptable
views this is how the prime minister
operates he divides stigmatizes and
drives wedges between himself and those
who don't agree with him and he does it
for the most naked of political reasons
he thinks it makes for good politics for
himself and for the liberal party and
that it goes over well with his base
mr speaker this is not a prime minister
of all
canada
or all canadians
this is a very selective prime minister
one who picks and chooses his causes
based on the degree to which
they further his vain glorious
self-image
or the interest of the liberal party not
long ago
this prime minister calculated that it
would be in his interest to opine on the
agriculture reforms that were being
proposed by the government of india the
world's largest democracy and a fellow
member of the commonwealth
in the ensuing diplomatic spat that
resulted from his unsolicited and
righteous remarks
the pm justified his intervention in the
domestic affairs of the world's largest
democracy by saying and i quote and i
know the opposition the government's
listening because this is what the prime
minister said canada will always stand
up for the right of peaceful protest
anywhere around the world
except
apparently at home
yes mr speaker the prime minister
passionately supports the principles of
free speech and peaceful protest it's
just the practice of free speech and
peaceful protest he opposes
especially at home in front of the
symbol of free speech and democracy
parliament hill mr speaker conservatives
sympathize with those canadians who have
been affected by the blockades
critical trade links
were
halted but have now been restored and
many small businesses have had to shut
their doors in light of the protests the
protesters here in ottawa
came bringing a message that message has
been heard the conservatives have heard
them and we will stand up for them and
all canadians who want to get back to
normal life and we will not stop until
those mandates are ended
canadians have sacrificed so much we all
know that every member of parliament has
heard and seen firsthand the sacrifices
however in a country more divided than
ever the prime minister has decided to
purposely policize the pandemic for his
own game
time is up but i'm sure he'll be able to
add through questions and comments uh
questions
the honorable
minister of families children and social
development thank you very much madam
speaker and thank you to my colleague
for his question and speaker as i was
listening to his remarks i felt like we
were living in two different worlds uh
you know it's not lost on me that he
kept talking about these peaceful
protests that ended uh quietly and
through dialogue well i i saw the news
in in kutz alberta uh they ended because
there was a huge cachet
of weapons um and so you know that that
was something that i think is quite
concerning to all canadians uh he was
talking about you know the premiers that
could do this without emergency
in ontario uh they actually enacted uh
i'm
so the only member for census defines a
point of order and i believe i know what
it is yes it's standing orders 16 and 18
which are being violated i can't hear
the minister trying to ask a question
because of the heckling from the people
she's trying to ask the question
um i've stopped the clock i'll allow the
minister to re-ask her question and i do
ask members if they have other questions
and comments to wait until it's their
time and i am sure that the arnold
member who
from south shore st margaret's is going
to be able to answer this without the
help of his member of his colleagues the
honorable minister thank you madam
speaker and while i always uh you know i
appreciate the comments i do appreciate
the opportunity to ask this question you
know he was talking about premiers who
were able to do this without emergency
measures but in fact in ontario last
friday the premier actually brought
forward a state of emergency
extraordinary powers and then was very
supportive of the federal government
bringing this forward because of the
extraordinary damage to our economy and
the security of canadians at border
points as well as right here in ottawa
madam speaker again what i hear from the
members opposite is a complete disregard
for the safety of people in ottawa and i
just asked the member
when will he recognize that people are
unsafe and they are scared and it is our
job as parliamentarians to protect them
the honorary member for south shore st
margaret
well thank you very much for the
question from the minister now i agree
with her we do live in two worlds
your world where you watch the cbc to
find out what's happening address the
questions through the chair
well the minister and the government who
watch the cbc to get all of their news
or our world our world where we actually
go and talk to people we actually go to
the protests and the borders where
people are to find out what they're
hearing and to try and represent them in
parliament we don't just sit in meetings
in west block talking to each other in
those ineffective meetings that you
always have in the government side that
produce absolutely nothing
you went from zero
zero
initiatives
at this government to the most draconian
piece of legislation that exists in this
country and you're using
i do want to ask some more questions uh
get some more questions ask questions
questions and comment the r member
report quickly uh oh excuse the pope
thank you
[Music]
i'd like to hear
well i think the prime minister should
have actually enforced the existing laws
and tools that he has before him without
using the act
well i'm hearing from members opposite
madam speaker that it's not his job
that's the problem with this government
nothing is their job whether it's
inflation or whether it's this crisis
it's always somebody else's fault the
honorable member from nova scotia my
colleague who i respect a lot i've heard
him also saying not our problem we
didn't create the economic crisis we're
in i'm sorry you did that's your excuse
for everything in this house yeah
i want to remind the member he's to uh
maybe not use the word you that would uh
prevent me from having to get up so
often and and redirect him uh the uh we
have time for a brief question the honor
member report muliko quitlin
thank you madam speaker and i just
wanted to say that i've heard some words
around this house today that that people
aren't talking to constituents that
people aren't talking to workers that
members of parliament aren't talking to
the communities and i just want to say
that we are and madam speaker what i'm
hearing is that people are traumatized
by this and i just wanted to ask the
conservative who says the conservative
party and the member who says they will
stand up for the occupiers
do they endorse illegal occupations
going forward or is that just this one
that they're supporting
the arnold member for south shore st
margaret's uh
please
well the
honorable member uh i don't think i said
that what i said is we will stand up for
ending the mandates but in her
relationship with the liberals and
supporting bringing in
the reduction in people's freedoms i
would pose a question to her why is she
not listening to the people
that that she's hearing from who are
complaining about wanting these mandates
reduced and relieved provinces are doing
it provinces out west are doing it all
kinds of provinces are doing this
government's ignoring and continues to
ignore the needs of canadians who want
to get back to a normal life and they're
putting their own political agenda to
try and wedge and divide us ahead of
everyone
resuming debate the honorable member pit
medals maple ridge
thank you madam speaker and
glad to be speaking to this bill
actually i'd rather not be speaking to
this bill i don't think we should this
measure i'd rather not be speaking
around i don't think it's necessary i
think it's a total overreach total
overreach of the government for
political expediency and it's
inappropriate and it's very selective
and that will be probably the nature of
my comments here tonight
but first of all i do want to thank
all the members of the staff here this
evening
table officers
interpreters food services maintenance
we appreciate what you do for us during
these late hours of the night
and
[Applause]
yeah they
think of the cafeteria workers are here
half an hour later than we finished
tonight so
thank you to them also want to thank the
parliamentary protective services who
had
long hours over here on the hill for the
past three weeks in order to keep order
they've been having a lot of polite
conversations with the protesters
and approaching them with a calm
professional demeanor
and i can't help but wonder
that if the liberal government
would have had the same approach
that the situation would be where it is
today matter of fact i'm sure it would
not be they made absolutely no effort to
reach out
and it's not just in the past three
weeks madame speaker
this is the approach they've had
that's just
what they've had over the years
during the pandemic and beforehand
i can't think of a single time
that the prime minister or a member of
the cabinet for that matter has even
taken a minute to voice any degree of
willingness
to listen to the canadians who disagree
with them on the measures that the
government has taken to promote the
exclusion of canadians based on
vaccination status
prime minister
and many other liberal caucus members
try to paint anyone not fully vaccinated
or not supportive of exclusionary
mandates as enemies
question questioning whether they should
be tolerated
canada we're talking about
it's known for our tolerance it's known
for our multiculturalism
and and this is the type of approach
that our government is taking constantly
constantly
it's their mode of operation
let me give go back to last year when 50
churches were
burned down
they said
the prime minister said this
one of my reflections is i understand
the uh
the anger that's out there against
institutions like the catholic church
it is real
and it is fully understandable the
shameful history that we've all becoming
more and more aware of
and engaging ourselves to do better such
pious words
it's wrong
that i'm a speaker
burning abundance of churches for the
prime minister in this liberal
government
is understandable
but no desire to show concern for those
protesting now
he told several church leaders
that evangelical christians
were the worst part of canadian society
yes
exclusionary tolerance that's what i'm
speaking about talking about
about three percent madam speaker order
uh
you know i just um
ruled on this a few minutes ago uh for
the minister
and uh
now i'm having the minister do exactly
what you know was being not
what somebody had asked not to do and i
know that the ministers want to ensure
that they are role models in this house
and i would ask them to hold their uh
their discussions and their thoughts uh
when it's the appropriate time to do so
and i would also ask the honorable the
opposition members as well not to engage
in the discussions as well especially
when i'm speaking uh so resuming debate
the honorable member for pitt meadows
maple ridge thank you madame speaker
for those comments and i'm happy to
answer the questions afterwards
i think of something that the prime
minister once said regarding exclusion
and
intolerance let me quote here
he spoke about an event
that killed several people
and wounded hundreds many of them losing
arms and legs
he said
but there is no question
that this happened because there is
someone who felt completely excluded
and our approach has been
it has to be
where do those tensions come from
where do those tensions come from who is
he speaking about he was speaking about
the boston marathon bombers
not families and others here in front of
us
that's his approach
to those that he might identify with and
yet he's excluding many others shameful
it's shameful it's divisive
why now has he no unders no willingness
to understand where these tensions come
from
it is because he knows
that the answer to that question of why
there's these tensions these problems
is in the mirror you just have to look
in the mirror
does it does the prime minister
think that calling anyone that is not
fully vaccinated or against their
exclusionary mandates calling them a
bigot a racist is a way to help relieve
tensions
no it's not
does asking if their very existence
should be tolerated help relieve
tensions of course it doesn't
but you know what it does do
it drives wedges through the population
and they are masters at wedges that's
their whole op this is that their way to
win elections is wedges who cares if
dividing canada yes shame on that
government
shame
and that's what this prime minister has
called colleagues like to do
for them it's a great electoral strategy
i understand that
it's electera if all this was was an
electoral strategy and don't ask me you
can ask members from their own liberal
party that's what it is electrical
electoral strategy
we it's obvious from this side
it's not
and it's obviously different ones in
that side even within their own benches
cater to 35 percent approximately maybe
uh toronto montreal maybe downtown
vancouver listen we can win the election
with that we'll expand it a bit
who cares what we're doing to canada who
cares if we exclude alberta most of
alberta saskatchewan rural parts of
canada oh conservatives or nazis you
know who cares as long as we get out of
35 percent locally can sit on that side
who cares what happens to canada
do you care
screw them to you three of them speaker
through you
do they care
i don't think so it's ridiculous
honestly there's some things principle
is a lot more important than just
winning elections
do we get it
so just miss other parties
they're obsessed with poll numbers no i
understand polling is important
so
point of order order
again maybe the remember wasn't in and
is just walking in but it's not
questions and comments at the moment
was there a point of order down there
for the same reason
the government's side i took i took care
of it yes
order order order i already uh ruled on
that so um again i would ask the
honorable members of the
uh government side to please uh hold on
to their tongue until it's time to do so
the honorable member for pitt meadows
maple ridge has two and a half minutes
left
two and a half minutes merci
with poles
[Music]
[Music]
still having that debate in between i'll
tell you i actually had a call from
someone from wendover this week who had
indicated that it's it's really not
pleasant for them to listen to debates
or listen to votes uh when people are
heckling in the house and uh i'm sure
he'll if he's listening tonight he'll uh
he'll appreciate the fact that i i i put
this forward so again uh questions and
comments will be in just under two
minutes i'm sure that the honourable
members can wait and the honor ministers
can wait until then to ask a question uh
the honorable uh member for meadows
maple ridge yes madam speaker this is a
precedent setting first time ever
invocation of the emergencies act
they didn't seem to be so quick to
to impose it
recently when there's block when we're
blockades
i disagree with blockades with violence
anywhere spoke out against it when i was
an mp as an mla in british columbia and
as a conservative mp
but they pick and choose
go way over the blockades were actually
here on the orders they're already gone
before the imposition this was totally
unnecessary it's totally a purpose of
diversion let me just say one thing
and that is this
what why are we having this all of a
sudden
well it seems to me a couple of things
things like their pandemic strategy
might have been well what's going on
here let's impose
impose mandates upon truckers who'll be
able to drive back and forth in the past
two years
keep the supply chains open bring that
in and try to double down when they when
there was push back they don't care if
thousands tens of thousands of canadians
are losing their jobs and i talk to them
i talk to truckers i talk to many others
there is not a compassion it's like
that's political fodder
for them
to win to strategize that thinking not
realizing how many countries how many
countries are opening up how many
provinces are opening up no we're going
to double down on this right here
thank you madam speaker
the honorable minister for families
children and social development thank
you madam speaker i
the the honorable member made some
interesting comments um
i was glad to hear him denounce violence
although i didn't hear that with regards
to the blockade here in ottawa um i was
concerned by some of the rhetoric that
he was using um i think we all need to
be
reducing the volume and and
de-escalating however he was being very
accusatory towards the members on this
side who have always stood against
violence i would like to ask the member
opposite
how he feels that
the words that he used de-escalated the
situation i would also like to ask him
about the nine i have other people ask
questions as well uh questions and
comments y'all remember pitt medals
maple
ridge thank you madam speaker i don't
happen to be the prime minister
okay
i'm not so
[Applause]
the prime minister
is the person that is right in front
supported by the cabinet supported by
the liberals and here's the thing when
he i used direct quotes i was using
direct quotes that our prime minister
has said i'm not just making things up
right here these are the words he called
them a misogynist racist extremists
nazis that's the word oh flippant oh is
it the truckers this is unvaccinated it
is christians is it this is the western
or whatever we'll keep our little power
base we will grow that a bit sorry
inappropriate for canada inappropriately
[Music]
[Music]
things have
[Music]
let's see
uh thank you madam speaker you know
i've had to be in this house
for a couple of years
where the anti-indigenous racism here is
fierce
and i understand madam speaker that it
is an intense moment
but we are in the process of recovering
our children we just discovered 52
children
in unmarked graves
this member of parliament
madame speaker uses
our pain
as an example
and i would like to ask the member if he
has humanity
and will apologize
for his comments
i remember for pit medals maple ridge
thank you madam speaker what happened to
be indigenous my family went to
residential schools okay i understand
this but that isn't about what this is
this is about emergency measures act
being imposed like it's never been
before disgraceful
thank you
we have time for a brief question you're
a member of saanich gulf islands thank
you madam speaker following up on the
question from the honourable member for
winnipeg center i also heard
anti-indigenous racism in the decr and
as most indigenous people in those areas
also did say it's not right to burn down
the churches but
the quote from the prime minister was
absolutely appropriate to the
circumstances of the pain of discovering
the children who were stolen from their
homes and never came home and their
bodies are being found as the honorable
member for winnipeg senator just said
and i do think the honourable member
could have expressed himself more
clearly to show some signs that he
understands the pain of the communities
that are going through this now it is
re-traumatizing people across this
country in our in indigenous communities
a very brief answer the only member for
me
these are examples of the uh tolerance
and intolerance of our of our prime
minister in the liberal party primarily
and i just gave you a variety of
examples throwing out including unit
bomber all sorts of different examples
there are so many
of his approach constant approach and we
as we oppose this imposition of the of
the emergency measures act as extreme
thank you
resuming debate beyond member from
scarborough center thank you madam
speaker
i will be sharing my time with the
member for fleetwood port health
madam speaker
it is with sadness but with resolve that
i rise today to take part in this
historic debate
the country and indeed the world is
watching
what is happening here i hope that we
can prove to be worthy of this moment in
canada's history
i would like to begin by thanking the
members of the parliamentary protective
services
who have been working hard to keep us
all safe and to ensure that the people's
servants can continue the people's work
uninterrupted and it is
and it is so important that our work
continues
that we show the people outside
and indeed the world that our democracy
is strong and we will not be intimidated
madam speaker we are three weeks into
the occupation of ottawa
centered as it is on our workplace we
have been unable to avoid its impact and
as we reflect
i would ask that we remember
that your experience may be different
than mine
somewhere some may feel comfortable
walking through the lines without fear
as a racialized woman a very visible
muslim woman
because of my choice to wear the hijab
my experience has been different
i cannot ignore the ties to white
supremacy
islamophobia and anti-semitism within
this movement
one of those arrested in kutz for
possession of a weapon and other charges
has a history of islamophobic social
media posts
and means
pushing the conspiracy theory that the
prime minister is working
with
court islamist unquote to take over
canada through immigration
we have seen how online hate can
transition to real world violence so it
is with worry that i walk to parliament
each day
watching carefully those around me
it is a heavy weight to carry
madam speaker it weighs on my soul
my husband and my children are worried
for me but i told them that i am going
to keep showing up i will not be
intimidated
madam speaker i would like to address
some of the points i often hear from the
supporters of this occupiers
they say this is a peaceful protest
it is just hot tubs and bouncy castles
no
no
it is much much more
these numbers are maybe a day or two old
but ottowa police have launched more
than 172 criminal investigations 18
arrests 33 charges over 3 000 tickets
issued includes four charged with
conspiracy to murder rcmp officers
13 arrests with the seizure of more than
a dozen
long guns handguns ammunition and body
armor
in windsor police have made more than 42
arrests
and they have seized 37 vehicles since
the protest began there
people have been verbally and physically
assaulted for exercising their freedom
to wear a mask
this is not a peaceful protest
but though actions don't have to be
physical to be violent
being prevented from earning a living to
go to work to run a business
that is a violent act
the riddle center and many other
downtown ottawa businesses have been
closed for weeks because police can't
guarantee their safety from massless
protesters seeking to intimidate and
frighten employees and the customers
hundreds of minimum wage retail and food
workers unable to go to work and earn
the money they need to pay their rent
and feed their kids
declare of the ambassador bridge
costs
390 million dollars in two-way trade
every day it was closed
auto workers and others reliant on their
trade faced temporary layoffs
this is not a peaceful protest
the two major grocery stores in core
downtown
have been forced to close at times
during this occupation for safety
reasons making it difficult for the
residents to even buy their groceries
bus service has been shut down through
most of the core and not everyone is
able to walk especially at -30 as it has
been some days
this is not a peaceful protest
making residents feel unsafe
walking their children down the street
taking away their freedom of movement by
occupying their streets polluting their
air with diesel fumes 24 7 honking so
constant and loud it took a court order
to somewhat reduce it
this is not a peaceful protest it is a
torture
i support peaceful protests and for
those for whom
this is about vaccine mandates
especially those outside of ottawa that
don't see what life has been like for
people here in ottawa i want to say that
is a fair debate and you have a right to
protest and be heard
and i understand your frustration
we are all frustrated we are all tied of
this pandemic i want it to be over as
much as you do i have family overseas i
have not been able to visit in two years
believe me your voice has been heard and
understood but we cannot just wish this
pandemic away canadians have sacrificed
too much i believe i hope we are close
to the end
but i don't want to risk seeing
restrictions lifted too early
and people dying that didn't have to
that's the challenge here i believe
i support your right to protest on these
points
peacefully park your vehicle
take the lrt downtown stand on the lawn
and protest all day
but peaceful protests does not mean
blocking city streets it does not mean
blocking trade and commerce
it does not mean threatening and
intimidating local residents who are
just trying to live their lives
it's time to give the people of ottawa
their city back
and allow me to say to the people of
ottawa i'm sorry
we are sorry for what you have had to
live through and into
you don't deserve this
i won't prejudge the commissions and the
inquiries that will follow
right now the focus must be restoring
order
but you have deserved better from all of
us
madam speaker i would like to speak to
our staff
i started my career in politics as an
assistant at queen's park and i know how
hard our staff works
we get to
go home on the weekends back in our
ridings and away from this occupation
they have to stay here because our
ottawa staff lives here many of them in
centre town or the byward market in the
heart of this
i urge my colleagues to ask their staff
who we couldn't do our jobs without how
do they feel
how are they doing
how is their mental health through all
this
what is it like
on the weekends when we have gone home
but thousands more people bent on
trouble and violence descend on the
downtown core
i'm so sorry they have had to go through
this that their families have had to go
through this
and that
some have had to watch
as their bosses have posed for photos
with the people making their lives
unbearable photos they then have to post
on their boss's social media i am sorry
and i hope you have the support you need
to get through this
madam speaker i believe in the charter
of rights but i feel like so many that
quote it haven't really read it with
rights comes the responsibilities and
your rights don't override my rights we
have a responsibility to one another
that's part of living in a democratic
society
canada is founded on the principles of
peace order and good government
across our country today that is under
threat by a foreign foreign-funded
movement
that under the guise of vaccine mandate
seeks to disrupt our lives disrupt our
trade and commerce and disrupt our faith
in our institutions our faith in one
another the mayors in this act are
targeted they are proportionate they
respect the charter and they give the
police the tools and the powers
they need to restore law and order in
our country it's time to put our
democracy first i will be supporting
this order thank you madam speaker
questions and comments questions
for battle river prophet
thank you very much madam speaker and uh
you know there's certainly much from
from uh my uh
the
the liberal member across the way speech
that i'd like to comment but
comment on but there was one uh specific
thing that she said that uh that really
piqued my interest so i would simply ask
her this she referenced that there will
be commissions and inquiries related to
the response to these blockades and i'm
glad to hear that i wish in fact that
the prime minister had said that so i'm
pleased to hear that they're willing to
look into it so my question is simple uh
if the prime minister and the actions of
of of other members of this liberal
government are have
are found to have been inflammatory to
have have played a role in in in what
has been taking place madam speaker i'm
wondering if she will accept the
findings of those commissions and
inquiries
honourable member for scarborough center
uh thank you madam speaker and i would
like to thank the honorable member uh
for his question
having now declared the public order
emergency
this declaration will only last for 30
days unless renewed and our government
is conscious of the need for
transparency and parliamentary oversize
as we have undertaken this action in the
coming days our parliamentary committee
will be stuck to provide oversight while
the emergency has been in effect
questions and comments
thank you bye
[Music]
options
thank you madam speaker and i would like
to thank the honorable member for his
question
speaker as the prime minister has made
clear the emergencies act is not the
first option exercised or even the third
or fourth it's important to remember
that local police are the first
responders and the force of jurisdiction
in this case of ottawa that's the ottawa
police services from the beginning since
the city of ottawa began to make
requests for support and resources the
government has worked with the city to
ensure the rcmp provides the support
they asked for
first the city of ottawa declared an
emergency then the province of ontario
and we continue to coordinate with and
support those local authorities we
established an integrated command center
with the ottawa police opp rcmp to bring
more resources forward only when it was
clear that this was a crisis
national in scope and that existing
authorities available to the local
police of your
were insufficient that the government
reluctantly
took this action
should send comments from london panzer
thank you madam speaker uh and i thank
my honorable colleague for her speech
i've worked with her on several
committees and associations and and
she's always so so good to work with
um
there's been a lot
of discussions
uh in this house um
on both sides about the level of of
disputes i guess we could call them
outside um
on the other side of the house
uh the conservative members are have
said that these are about honking
annoyances
and traffic jams those are the two
direct quotes that i've heard uh over
the course of today's debate
um i'm wondering if she could share her
thoughts on the dangers of downplaying
what we're seeing outside when i know
that i have spoken to people about the
assaults and the harassment that they
have endured throughout this convoy
thank you madam speaker
the iron man for scarborough center
thank you madam speaker and thanks to
the honourable member for her question
and it has always been a plea you're
working with her or many
committees
i totally agree that peaceful protests
are important part of our democracy and
everyone should have the right for
peaceful
protest but these illegal blockades
blocking our trade corridors blocking
our borders
like as i mentioned in my speech that
the closure of the ambassador bridge has
costed like
390 million dollars per day in the loss
of trade with our most important trading
partner us so these are not peaceful
protests these are illegal blockades we
need to finish end these illegal
blockades so that the people of ottawa
can have their life back
resuming debate
the honor member for fleetwood port
kells
thank you madam speaker i have a message
tonight for all my colleagues here in
the house of commons and especially for
everyone here at home in fleetwood port
cals who are having a rightfully good
debate right now about the
justifications for using the emergency
measures act
i wanted to provide my own thoughts the
rationale behind my support for the
government's actions
to do that let's focus specifically on
the questions in this debate
is the government's use of the emergency
measures act justified and are the
measures being invoked legally
well the second answer is the easiest
to or the second question is easiest to
answer because that answer is yes
if
the measures being used to con to to
deal with the situation conform with the
legislation that's been on the book
since the 1980s but given that this is
the first time that this legislation's
been used there should be scrutiny of
the measures
to make sure that they do conform with
the law but that is the easy part
but we have to talk about the
justification
the act is right to the point it says a
national emergency is an urgent and
critical situation of a temporary nature
that a seriously endangers the lives
health or safety of canadians and is of
such proportions or nature as to exceed
the capacity or authority of a province
to deal with it or b
seriously threatens the ability of the
government of canada to preserve the
sovereignty security
and the territorial integrity of canada
so let's take that apart and look at the
evidence does the current situation
endanger the lives of canadians
well the border disruptions certainly
endangered the economic quality of life
for canadians and therefore their
well-being and there is ample evidence
of that in windsor especially in the
auto sector
or for so many businesses and their
employees in ottawa
the threats of physical violence to
people in ottawa's downtown neighborhood
have been real
and charges have been laid
against the 13 in kutz alberta
apparently because they appeared ready
to murder our cmp officers
does the activity endanger our health
well there's no doubt that the premature
lifting of public health measures as
demanded
demanded by these protesters would do
this we saw this very clearly in alberta
last year when they lifted the mandates
for the best summer ever and it wasn't
so we don't want a repeat of that
but the stated aim of the protest is to
force the government to abandon public
health measures regardless of the advice
from the public health agency of canada
and provincial authorities
do the blockades endanger safety well
when protesters harass and bully people
and threaten assault yes
when protesters allegedly tried to set
fire to a residential building in ottawa
gluing the door shut in the process yes
indeed
when police find that cache of weapons
such as was seized in kutz alberta how
could there not be a perception that
public safety was endangered
does the situation exceed the capacity
or authority of a province to deal with
it well not in every case but certainly
in some notably in ontario which is why
the use of the emergency measures act
clearly sets out that it could be
specifically targeted to locations where
provincial authorities need additional
help to restore order
and
to the point that's been raised a few
times while all these things were
cleared up just as the emergency
measures act was being uh you know
announced let's face it
we want to prevent them from bringing
disorder back to those locations which
is a real and current threat
do the current actions threaten canada's
sovereignty and security
well the manifesto of this group
calls for canada's democratically
elected government to be deposed and the
government turned over to a committee
made up of in part
by them
so we put a check mark next to that one
but there'll be some who say well the
answer is no if you consider the
protesters at face values just some good
old boys and girls and kids in big
trucks challenging the government to
preserve god-given and charter and
shined rights and freedoms
but the people who believe that like
some of our conservative colleagues have
been deceived
they've been gamed by crafty intense
grey-faced agents of passive aggressive
manipulation and sedition
one can only imagine the information our
security services have on them
and the gaming that they've performed
has been intense indeed canada has had a
long and sometimes very colorful history
of civil disobedience where people break
the law
and the police show patience and
restraint while the protesters make
their point
then having made their point on a
reasonably transparent agenda they and
the government trade ideas the deal is
done and the protesters go home
well those behind the blockade and
occupations know this and they have
gamed us to a fare thee well
they allegedly gamed the ottawa police
service oh we'll do our thing for a few
days and then leave while planning to
use this grace period to dig in
they may have also gained ottawa's mayor
who thought there was a deal to get some
of the trucks out of the residential
areas until one of the leaders patrick
king stepped in and said hey no deal
we're not going anywhere
so do the current action seriously
threaten canada's sovereignty and
security well the evidence says yes
when you take a close honest look at the
people calling the shots in the protest
do their actions seriously threaten
canada's sovereignty and security
yes absolutely
patrick king who's demonstrated
significant influence in the ottawa
occupation has deposited a great deal of
material online
i'm going to quote him and the you in
the quote refers to the prime minister
i quote someone's going to make you
catch a bullet one day
to the rest of this government
somebody's going to do you in
and in another quote the only way this
is going to be settled is by bullets
the 13 people charged in kutz alberta by
their history of arrests and violence
represent a very clear danger to police
and the canadian society want to know
what their motto is for change in canada
guns or rope
how many times
madam speaker have we seen news of mass
shootings and tragic bloodshed and loss
of life only to find out in the
aftermath that oh there were signs that
the authorities should have picked up
well signs have been picked up and this
government will not want the postscript
to an act of domestic terrorism to be an
indictment by canadians that we didn't
act
and this gets us to the real point of
the protest the real agenda of the
people behind it
you see theirs is a world of anger
resentment and hate of minorities of
immigrants of the liberal values and the
democracy they represent
the core people behind the protests are
precisely as the prime minister has
described them
and many agree glenn pearson writing in
national news watch today noted
this hatred for hatred sake doesn't find
an easy landing in canada as it might do
south of the border but as the convoy
protest revealed the hate movement is
increasingly interested in this country
hoping to undermine its authorities and
replace them with chaos
the goal of such insidious agents was
never to help the truckers succeed but
to make sure the government and security
forces didn't